the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
play is sizzling at the American Cup in
St Louis the double elimination format
led to must-win games with yesterday's
defeated fighting to avoid elimination
winners kept winning with Nazi fakiti
joining the leaders after getting her
first Victory to shoot into the top
bracket Hikaru Nakamura cruise to the
next round drawing his game with tense
playoffs deciding who would join him in
the Winner's Circle the fight for
survival is on who will search ahead and
who can battle back to the top day three
of action-packed Chess coming up next
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back everybody to day three of
the 2023 American Cup hosted here at the
St Louis chess club we start a day in
the World Chess Hall of Fame as we are
waiting for the players to arrive for
the first time in clubs history the
games are played here at the World Chess
Hall of Fame it's been a fantastic event
so far let's go to studio and start the
action with yasu enjoy
we welcome you to Saint Louis Missouri
the capital of Chess in America this is
day three of the 2023 American cup from
the Saint Louis chess club
[Music]
and we wish you a very warm welcome from
the Saint Louis chess club studio and
I'm drank houseka and it's a great
pleasure to be calling all the action
today as we eliminate some players with
the Grand Master yasa Sarah won Jovi as
always a great pleasure to be calling
all the action with you and Christian
hello everyone and welcome to day three
of the action and new new matches
um eight players face elimination but in
the first matches it was the top seeds
that did particularly well Arena Crush
2-0 let's lead to zero and Hikaru was
the only player who went through the
Champions bracket without a playoff
thanks to a one and a half half victory
over Sam Savion do the honors uh Jovi
and tell us about uh the new matches
let's start with the ladies yeah
definitely because we have so many
exciting matchups ahead and as we saw
Arena crash was dominance against House
of abrahamian and as a reward she will
now face Tokyo Tokyo jonova and Tokyo
jonova played a fantastic match as well
against Katarina and then we have Naji
pakizi who played a beautiful game to
defeat Anna satonsky and as a reward she
will face off against the 13 year old
Wonder kid Alice Lee and in the
elimination bracket oh things are going
to get fast they're going to get furious
and we're going to sadly say goodbye to
some players fighting for their lives
Tate abrahamian against Katarina nemsava
as well as Anna satonski and patusa or
cashion and in the Champions or open
section yeah we have some incredible
matchups ahead Hikaru Nakamura simply
breezed past Sam Sabian and he also will
face linear Dominguez who clinched a
clutch win against Levon aronian in the
tie breaks and then we have a huge match
up ahead between Wesley so and Fabiano
Carona both these players are winning
their fourth game in the playground
playground
playoffs and in the elimination bracket
in that playground that playground yeah
we see that the players are once again
on their last lives they are in The Last
Chance Saloon Sam Savion will play
against 11 aronian meanwhile Samsung
faces off against Ray Robson remember if
anyone loses these ones they leave the
competition absolutely and our format
for our double elimination match
competition yeah so it seems like we're
playing two tournaments now yes because
in the Champions bracket they're playing
a very sedate if I can say that
classical 90 minute plus 30 second
increment but in the elimination bracket
well the play completely shifts to Rapid
the two players will play a two game at
25 minutes plus 10 second increment and
for sure we are gonna see some Playoffs
today absolutely and schedule yeah let's
uh take a look because we have a lot of
Chess in store so today in the
championship bracket they would simply
play one classical game and then a
return with opposite colors tomorrow but
in the wrap in the elimination bracket
things will get fast they will get
furious because they will be playing two
games of a rapid chess and if the match
is still tied then we move on to a
faster time control of 10 minutes plus
five seconds and then if it's still tied
three minutes plus two and then finally
the crowd favorite Armageddon to decide
the match strangely enough they haven't
seen the Army get him yet but I I I'm
sure we will Christian good to have you
in studio a breakdown uh these matches
will go a little deeper if you will good
to see you guys great to be back for a
day three here at the American Cup and
what a fantastic first set of matches we
had here in St Louis just incredible
opening preparation and the resilience
of these players is just simply
mesmerizing but let's take a look at
what's happening in match two as we
enter in the Champions bracket well
we've seen that smooth sailing of Hikaru
Nakamura that you were mentioning Jovi
in his first match against Sam Savion
but right now he will be facing Lanier
Dominguez and this one is a huge matchup
let's take a look at how the head to
head of these players is looking like in
this one and as we can see this one is
quite tied one win for Hikaru Nakamura
one loss and a lot of draws that's 12
draws and once again these players are
meeting each other this one I have to
say is going to be a very tense battle
but the one that I'm having my eyes on
is that huge matchup between Fabiano
caruana who uh this post of Ray Robson
in the final game of rapidly in
yesterday's playoff and he will be
facing Wesley so who is so difficult to
beat and let's take a look at their head
to head as we enter this incredible
match four wins four losses and 26
straws Guys these two guys know each
other so well they've played in so many
tournaments together they know
everything about each other who's going
to be able to surprise first that is the
big question let's take a look at the
ladies Champions bracket as well we have
Irina Crush who I have to say is just
simply impressive in the American Cup
she's been impressive in last year's
Edition and while she started with 2-0
against state of abrahamian in this
year's Edition as well she will be
facing tohirjonova who she managed to
beat last year but will she be able to
do it once again that is the big
question she is Irina Crush that is the
only Grand Master in this event and
going into this matchup I have to say
she is the favorite she already beat to
Hero Nova twice no losses two draws but
will beg him be able to pose more
problems this time around we will find
the answer to that question shortly and
another matchup that I'm having my eyes
on is the one between Naji paikidze and
that 13 years of age Alice Lee who is
just impressing everybody in the studio
everybody in St Louis I have to say
whoever is watching this show cannot
remain unimpressed with Alice Lee she's
just incredible a future Grandmaster
that we have here in St Louis lifetime
matchup between these two players they
only met once one win for Alice Lee no
losses no draws well we're going to see
two more games between these two players
and I have to say Nashi by kids
definitely seems in shape going into
this matchup guys we're going to have
some amazing games coming up your way
absolutely Naji confidently won against
Anna with the sacrifices that we saw
yesterday as we were coming on air Jovi
you said to me that are good friends at
chess.com had did an analysis of Alice
Lee's games and she had an unbelievable
tpr yeah and yesterday's game in
yesterday's game they had done like a
game report and they had given both
players a rating performance and they
said that Alice Lee had played at get
this
28.50 level
I know that's what accuracy and her
opponent didn't place so badly yourself
exactly she played it at 25 50. wow and
here's who we're talking about 13 years
young and already a veteran of the game
with three world championship titles
and she's taking University level math
classes as well I mean in California
next summer she's going to run for
governor
what can't she do it was amazing and and
what you were saying there Christian
about the match-up between Wesley and
Fabi it doesn't get any closer than that
no no that is extraordinary it's so
difficult to separate these players to
be honest every single match has been so
tense except maybe the one between
Hikaru and Sam Seville that one it felt
like it had a clear favorite indeed it
did as here we see the players really
seem to be enjoying themselves something
going on in the playing Hall as
everybody has arrived in pretty good
move and even though he doesn't try to
smile at the board Hikaru couldn't yeah
help himself there was something going
on he seems very relaxed doesn't he
heard you know and I have to say he's
been doing Recaps on his YouTube channel
of every single game that's uh
impressive and what I especially like to
say yesterday we asked him did he feel
Rusty and he was like no no no right I'm
not Rusty at all I'm always playing
chess and then yeah
I finally shaken off
hey wait a minute that's our light just
a second and again
he seems like he's been lifting recently
because he looks like he's put on some
muscles I'm hearing that he's doing
power lifting have you heard about that
yes no no but certainly
bench presses and all those things a
little bicep action yes the top players
are doing this you know they have to do
it because I mean you're in for the Long
Haul when you're playing this classical
game you know you sometimes you have to
put in seven hours of work of pure focus
and concentration and you know I was
talking to a performance coach and he
was saying if you push yourself
physically you know give yourself 100
you you actually get used to doing the
same mentally as well exactly it's an
endurance and some of these matches once
you go deeper into them you go past the
Rapids you get into the blitz it feels
like that endurance really uh comes to
four again a great matchup one Victory a
piece lots of draws between these two
great players and we have one E2 E4 and
uh for Lanier I mean he's been a king
pong player are I think most of his life
E7 E5 will be expecting we're not
expecting a second there's a pause
yes yes that's that's an option command
linear we're waiting we're waiting uh
answer our
and that's quite intriguing because he
usually plays his first moves at least
the ones that he knows very very quickly
yes and then later on when the first
move that he doesn't know he usually
spends like 40 minutes on it
the other thing that kind of caught my
eyes again we're coming on air and Arena
versus begum just a great matchup I mean
again begum was our our number one uh
player for our U.S women's Olympic team
so I I mean this is a huge matchup and
the crazy part is for begum it's deja vu
all over again Groundhog Day she's
playing exactly the same as 2022. Jack
defeated gotcha but now she's up against
Arena and in 2022 Arena one and it was
kind of the same color situation as well
you know she started off with a draw
with the black pieces against Arena and
then in game two it all went to Pieces
when she lost with the white pieces I
see
a completely winning position with the
black pieces now I remember I said in
day one that Arena didn't have any
problems in the American Cup last year
but she did indeed she was losing game
one against begging with the white
pieces exactly
um okay uh now we're seeing a little bit
off the Beaten Track let's jump to the
game between Alice Lee and the kitsa
because this is not a defense that you
see often at the very top levels one D4
not the move C7 C5 normally if you're
going to get into a benoni or a king
side fee and Shadow you often preface it
with the move Knight F6 so c5's a little
bit unusual and allowing the setup that
often comes from the perk defense move
order where White's night you know is in
front of the pawn this this is actually
considered a little bit awkward for
black the reason is is after the move
Knight F6 which is the most standard
move by far I've discovered in my own
practice that the movement Bishop B5
check is incredibly annoying for the
second player for example after the move
Bishop D7 I played the move a four and
you're not attracted to trading at all
and then the problem is for example
after castles H3
you're kind of stuck the bishop on D7
stops the Knight you don't want to play
E7 E6 and it's this move Bishop B5 check
that's really off-putting a lot of
players start there for with the move A7
A6 intimating that you want to play the
move B5 provoking the move A4 and only
in this case continuing with Knight F6
so Bishop G4 and Away you go A6 does
have its disadvantages I just wanted to
kind of point out because it's often a
common plan in these type of positions
actually to put your knight on A6
maneuver it to C7 and uh meanwhile yes
is highlighting white
but what you like to say is that it's
often this is very critical this kind of
plan right on C7 and then prepare B5
in my experience one of the very few
players who was willingly assaying these
types of defenses for black was Michael
tall and for me it was very risky but
okay it worked for him let's see if
Alice is familiar with all of us because
she's blitting out her moves but she's
done it I'm a little surprised by Naji
right right opening up with one C5 and
playing what it's actually called the
pterodactyl defense
sounds like a dinosaur who studies these
defense guys I mean I understand you
studied it because you faced it maybe
your 20th year of experience you finally
managed to get to this position and
understand that Bishop B5 and A4 is the
right way to do it but she had 13 years
of age she knows everything like what
doesn't she know right in the opening
phase it seems like she's out preparing
out foxing her more experienced
opponents very early on indeed and after
the move a7a6 I would prescribe the
simple Retreat Bishop E2 and once again
if you look at the position on the
analysis board for a a second
um white has crisscrossed her opponent's
plans you mentioned Michael Tall in
Knight A6 Knight C7 you now put your
Pawn on A6 your Bishop on D7 strangely
enough is in the way of your knight and
you almost feel like
you're obliged to play a move like
Bishop G4 and voluntarily give up the
two Bishops in order that you can
smoothly complete your development but
White's going to enjoy the two Bishops
and the space so I do feel that Alice
Lee although she's been surprised she's
handled it incredibly well and I I by
the way again I'm still reeling from
what you told me about the 2850
rating performance that is just
extraordinary that is just like really
really scary it goes to show you know
she just plays with clinical Precision
right and you know when you and when you
add that that a Tusa her opponent from
yesterday played well at 25 50
performance you know but no problem for
Alice playing with the black pieces as
well incredible just incredible uh let's
uh uh I just wanted to ask you a
Christian too is when do the Rapids
begin I believe the Rapids begin at 3
P.M
no they started I think I oh they have
actually started or they have some as
well maybe it's a free-fall
ah three o'clock is the second rapid
game got it well let's just jump to the
ladies Rapids for a moment because we do
have uh as you so uh well put it Katya
and Tata fighting for their lives uh and
we do have in English with this floor
variation
yeah very popular nowadays
that that's that was the one opening I
studied inside and out as a teenager is
white and I played against Victor
korchnoy the number two player in the
world and he fell right into my analysis
it was like the greatest preparation
I've ever had in my in my life and once
I defeated him with the white side
Bishop is doing some weird stuff right
now so for example she played this move
Bishop to E7 early on right
um it's not that precise in general you
want to start with the move Bishop to F5
why is that the reason because you want
to wait for your opponent to kick that
Knight away with the move D3 this is how
the uh opening usually goes D3 you take
on C3 take on C3 and after the move C5
D4 we have this position which has been
studied in and out uh I think one of the
topical games is between if I'm not
mistaken a museechuk versus juwen June I
know Juan June was
um a part of that matchup very very
important game it was against goryachka
during the world championship match a
couple of years back so this was the
stem games Bishop E7 and C5 doesn't seem
to pose the same problems for white and
if I remember correctly from my analysis
white already enjoys a pretty
significant Advantage because once you
take on C3 I take back with the B Pawn
and I basically won a Tempo but even
more importantly I want the control of
the B1 H7 diagonal and now you will have
to spend a lot of time to get your
Bishop to challenge my Bishop on D3 with
the idea of Bishop to G4 Bishop to H5
and then finally you get to G6 and
challenge my Bishop on D3 which is just
simply insufficient in terms of uh
timing and that's going to give white
the advantage can I can I pose you the
question uh Christian for just a moment
what happens if I play Bishop F5 I'm not
mistaken you're already kind of in
trouble I do that I won't disagree I
don't mind it might be one to B3 Queen
to B3 I will have to check it I don't
remember the opening
as well but I do have a chance
it still feels like you know the jury I
mean the jury is definitely out yeah
yeah I'm not yes so I I take on B7 let's
say take on B7 I'll take on D4 I take
and then I give you a check on B5 yes
Christian is speaking Yeah you like it
you both are maybe I take on D5
wow and then we'll hang on a second
here I know uh the problem I'm facing is
the bishop on E7 is that's right is
hanging and my desirable Queen A5 check
is just going to be met by King F1 but
you see what she's doing right now in
the game she took on C3 and then she
played Bishop to G4 that's just simply
going to um yeah that just leaves white
with a very nice Bishop G4 I understand
you want to play page five and go
between the G6 but you're just too slow
if it it feels like uh you just get
seated white uh great central control
for simply nothing absolutely even the
move Rook B1 starts to look attractive
right now because there is this weakness
and if I can provoke B6 oh Rook B1 is a
great one yes all right in fact the
engine is giving already a white a one
Pawn advantage wow okay so definitely a
slip up in her preparation and we're
just going to go quickly to the game
between Anna satonski and etusha uh very
standard stuff in this classical Nims of
Indian with Queen C2 Knight b87 and
let's go see how uh the
um
the elimination games are going on
between Lavon and Sam sevillan
Lavon is white
playing this D3 yeah this is very well
whoa whoa whoa whoa if I gave you this
position and you've already seen what
Sam Savion played which was Bishop D7
does that move pop into your mind at all
I mean G5 pops into your mind castles
short pops into your Bishop to E6 pops
into my mind T5 is the rage these days
right that's what I've noticed but would
Bishop D7 is I mean isn't that like low
man on the totem pole what's Bishop D7
Christian you're gonna have to bail me
out on this one here uh oh I'm looking
at the different games
let me try to figure out Bishop decent I
mean of all the moves G5 visual p7 I've
played this type of move before uh in in
general is aimed at defending in the
future that pawn on B5 so ideas of A4
followed by Knight to A3 and these are
very typical and you try to Target that
pawn on B5 very often with that Bishop
on D7 you will be able to defend it by
for example just retreating the Knight
or even going with the Knight to A5 or
to E7 opening up the diagonal opening up
the defense of the Pawn on B5 this is my
guess also
what do you where else do you want to
put a bishop is the question if you put
it on B7 that obviously has its
drawbacks specifically this idea of A4
and Knight 283 targeted in the pawn on
B5 if you put it on E6 obvious drawbacks
as well if you put it on G4 I can Target
that I can go H3 and that's going to
kick your Bishop around so Bishop to
this I mean look this is the Ruby Lopez
guys
so many ways right okay uh Bishop D7 a
very surprising move out for me I'll
return the favor yes what is Queen C1
that you guys were showing Queen what I
think you were showing the queen on C1
in your analysis yeah Sweeney did find a
cell phone
you explain it to me now it's the old
mouse slip what happens is I just
couldn't get it there okay we'll we'll
keep an eye on that two uh heavyweight
theoretician uh going at it here between
San
um Sam shackland and Ray Robson uh let's
see because they've blitzed their way
through this Berlin
and
B3 okay
this is
wow C5 okay this is news for me takes to
eggs King C7 Rook V1 and they're
blitzing so fast I have to assume we're
still in the there
theoretical uh Waters here I would say
that Sam is just judging by the clock
times I mean I work is like 24 minutes
and Ticking whereas uh Ray you know
hovering around the 18 minute Mark okay
so all Theory all been played before we
can actually see some games it's I have
to say it can be quite demoralizing that
when you're 18 moves in it's like ah
been done before they've done that
exactly yeah
and the game is only going to begin on
maybe move 20. I had some lines like
that in my caracan book and I had to say
look I know it's disappointing but this
is the way it is and you you know play
starts from move 17. okay uh just break
down this position a little bit for me I
see Reyes just played the move A4 a move
that I find very attractive because
whenever you can
develop your Rook on a half open or open
File by not moving it that's a good
thing that's a good deal for you so
getting to play A4 takes B3 and then you
know furthermore continuing with Rook A3
it gets my not a not of approval what is
it that White's aspiring for uh Jovi
well the first
Springs
is you can spring forward you can jump
forward yeah with the move Knight D6
okay and if I take you would recapture
with the wrong yeah with a pawn with a
pen and grab G7 of course okay that so
if you if you start with Knight D pardon
me if you start with Knight D6 am I
supposed to then
perhaps I can take on B3 first right
let's see how that is are you actually
going to take on F7 is that yes
having said hey I should say I have more
bottle yeah
uh uh okay one second just give me one
one second sure I know this might be a
far far-fetched idea but after I take on
B3 you go Knight F7 yes can I take on
A2
yes it's legal or perhaps even this
different idea of C4 no no that is not
enough it's not enough I had the
impression that the pawns are on H2 and
on G3 for white and after C4 this bishop
to C5 uh check comes with more oomph
yeah unfortunately with opponents on G2
and H3 it's not enough exactly but I we
didn't have the spring forward we did
have after A4 F5 also another option
that came to my mind as well you go fish
I like yeah maybe that makes the most
sense maybe you're jumping well one of
the benefits maybe of F5 is you're
definitely stopping Bishop E6 so it's
not that easy for
black to Target the pawn other than may
I ask the obvious question
Rook B3
I do agree that I'm not exactly
including these guys at the moment that
bad form they're not the MVPs in the
position you know
I'm trying to find some sacrifices here
but what side of the bed did you fall
out of it's our sacrifices you're a
chess coach you have principles protect
your pawns and pieces that's what you're
teaching here that's a good joke that's
a good joke yesterday when you got
criticized for not being aggressive yes
that was great right exactly I'm looking
for aggressive ideas
let's go for E6 E6 followed by F6
wow take and now F6 wow
okay that is that's something okay
that's exciting stuff we have this
expression do you have it the same in
the U.S the proof of the pudding is in
the eating true did you have that we
don't use it as it's not as commonly
used but we do say you know
uh so okay uh I I get it you you're
threatening me terribly terrifying
that's right on a G7 that's right and
the moment you get to play Rook F7 I'm
gonna be really really hurting so let me
know
my intention G7 and Knight F6 and I
think you uh yeah at least a piece down
yes at least a piece down yes so
um
and if you take on F6 I take with the
Knight hmm
this is not that easy anymore is it
so I think this is um
Sam's idea F5 E6 again you have to do
something fast because if black manages
to stabilize the position
that was my open position an open Center
like this pawns on both sides of the of
the board he's going to enjoy a nice
Advantage but
you do have those two points E5 and F5
ready to create a very Advanced very
scary but I mean well we did sidestep
this F6 E6 combination of moves with the
move Bishop C6 actually the most solid
if you look at it but it's inviting this
96 right yeah that that's inviting the
spring forward line although
if can I take it on can I take it in
this case in this way because maybe
bishop takes but then you can cement the
bishop right on the G7 I know that's one
way of looking at it you know you could
call it traffic
you can self and mobilize you can
immobilization yeah self emulate there
we go there we go uh yeah uh but you're
imprisoned by the way how is this
position I
perhaps I don't even have to defend that
pawn on G2 no no I'm defending that pawn
really oh come on Jovi be aggressive
move your king okay King F1 yeah okay
now let's try to Checkmate ourselves
right
right okay wait but now I can take on D7
yeah I don't know I can take D7 in
Bishop f8 I think it's over
ah because my Rook is hanging that's
right that's right very good okay I I
wanted the Rook check that uh I I agree
wholeheartedly is because my Rook is
hanging uh Bishop takes D7 leaves The
Rook on Prix and if you go King the
eight bishop f8 and I think that's the
that's the keynote and I get in time
finding my Bishop on G7 does something
right exactly very impressive okay so
we'll uh let me just refresh my board
yeah and by the way there is a way that
our audience can join the commentary
yeah they can so if you two want to get
involved in the farm the action ask us
your questions then please remember to
tweet us using the hashtag the American
Cup and we'll try and feature them on
the show or costume and Talia I'll tell
you I will be on hand to answer all your
questions indeed we look forward to
being challenged that's uh that's very
fun for us Ryan
and a very relaxed Fabian he's the one
with the 90 minutes he's watching the
game where the players only at 25 so
yeah so he's strolling around very
happily uh am I right to think that the
players uh pardon me the that Sam
Shanklin and Ray Robson are still in
theory is this because everything
they've done is very very consequently
no no it's easy because we can look at
the clock right the clock like how are
we doing on the clock I I Believe In
Minutes Ray is already down to his last
15 minutes the last time I checked
maybe we can see
and 20 minutes 15 minutes and 20 minutes
for Sam so yeah we know if Sam knows
he's going to Blitz out his moves well
he's one thing he's doing pretty good
yeah yeah that's one thing he does and
and now
oh sorry against Bishop C6 there was no
springing forward no
it was Rook oh excuse me it was Rook F1
to E1 and then
instead of
going Rook A3 Rook A2 basically it's
saying the Knight is pinned and he moves
by the Knight Will potentially cost you
your Pawn on G2 so with the move Rook A2
pardon me the we go E6 now this is what
I was thinking release push the park
well I'll take it and now you do have
Bishop E5 check as an Intermezzo if you
want I don't
you're going to take it you're going to
take on okay okay and then I will
um gift gift now you can actually take
on G7 I think I'm gonna take that pawn
yeah okay then go back and give the
beautiful check okay I'm with you I'm
still wow you just have to handle the
pressure there that could be solved by
the pawn coming forward yeah yeah you
want to move your Pawn forward the G3
right yeah and uh I wasn't sure G3 I was
thinking keep
it okay but uh two Bishops and uh I
think I'm winning back the pawn on E6
and this guy
well
[Music]
um
what I'm not that convinced all right is
there am I missing something obvious
here not obvious no no no come on
I have to trick you somehow okay okay
let's try niter C3 back
uh Knight C3 never crossed my mind that
you would allow uh me the opportunity to
play Rook G2
never crossed my mind wow
um okay so Rook takes E6 walks into
Bishop C7 while watching tonight takes
A2 first yeah well I was thinking of uh
but later on yes right yes yes
and then in case I gets too greedy you
you've prepped Bishop C7 that's right
yeah
exactly
um
okay uh that's inspiring I convinced you
wow I'm not sure I'm convinced but
that's the first time in years yeah E6
the same uh more importantly Sam wasn't
convinced by E6 he played yeah
G4 pardon me he played G4 that's
that's a bit of a unexpected move uh it
is unexpected but at the same time yes
we likes it because you know there's no
way for black to activate those two
pieces so easily and you know it moves
like H5 can be simply met by G5 and you
know suddenly this whole born flanks of
calm is coming at you the pond storm
right how bad is it if I just play
Simple trust Bishop B sub
Bishop E7
I know it doesn't look very encouraging
I have to say allowing this F6 yeah
you're kind of kind of doing that
encouraging that
on the other hand you you kind of need
some development I'm sorry I've been
remiss let's jump to the Champions uh
bracket and see how Hikaru our number
one seed is doing against linear again
they are playing the classical games
with 90 minutes for the whole game and
oh boy
I mean people are really struggling
against the Petrov because they are now
going in to weird spaces
Queen Knight D3 and queen E2
okay white is struggling to get an edge
against the petroff and it's really
surprising that they're going for uh
that he car is going for this line it
doesn't feel like it's offering the
white player that much c76 that's true
but I find that modern day chess is all
about this type of advantage and take a
look at a little bit of space you know
and one bad piece so say for instance at
night only seven it's a bad piece you
know where is it going to go it could go
to F5 but then or to G6 as you pointed
out but then you know on G6 it can be
kicked away on F5 is getting in the way
of the light squared Bishop yep and
white just has a lot of freedom with
their pieces it's not much right and
white has to be very precise to keep
that pressure ongoing but
as long as they kind of forces your
opponent to kind of burn the time on the
clock then I think that that's an
important consideration for Hikaru
because he knows that Lanier is a
thinker that linear really likes uh uh
burning the clock and so he just wants
to create enough problems and enough
problems and extend the gain to where
hopefully the clock becomes a
a key factor H7 H5 I played C7 C6 in
order to release the Knight I think that
Lanier was a little bit fearful that
maybe H5 will end up keeping this Knight
imprisoned and I also don't think he
wants to give his opponent any space yes
he wants to match every single expansion
right that Hikaru is doing you play tour
I play H5 you play A4 on the other side
I'm probably going to play A5 on the
other side as well I'm not going to give
you any space because I know that that's
what you want right we know that this
position is supposedly very very close
to equality the only way you can create
any sort of separation is if you
increase your space Advantage as white
you are moving first you are getting
there first so you will dictate the
tempo of the game but if I manage to
match that I'm probably going to be out
of the woods with proceed with precise
moves now let me tell you a funny story
about this line though because please
take it back a couple of moves
early on after Knight to D3 Knight to F4
the idea is pretty obvious you want to
play the move Knight to D5 and I've
analyzed this position for the match in
2018 between Fabiano caruana and Magnus
Carlson and actually that this position
uh did end up on the board Fabiano's
move was Knight to C6
fast forward to 20 I think it was maybe
in January this year we were getting
ready with my students for the
pan-americans and we were looking at
some of these lines and playing some
Blitz Games and I played this particular
line somebody played uh this with the
white pieces against me I'm not going to
give his name and he played this move
Knight to D5 which makes a lot of sense
this was the move played in the match as
well Knight to D4 and now of course the
main line is Knight takes E7 Knight
takes C2 it leads to a very complex
battle in the end game but he played
this move Queen to C4 quite quickly and
I started thinking wait a minute what is
this queen to C4 now my queen is under
attack my knight on D4 is under attack
and my Pawn on C7 is under attack I
spent like a minute and a half trying to
figure it out I played Queen E5 and
after F4 I lost very very quickly but
after Knight D5 you have a one move win
Knight to C3 I appreciate that Knight
takes C7 Knight takes C2 that's a
Checkmate so this is what we bought and
this guy is like a 2600 Grand Master GM
but he still played this funny move
Queen to C4 himself not remembering what
he was supposed to do after Knight ac7
and thinking wait a minute Queen to C4
seems to be winning right but it's not
because of this nice cute trap so yeah
if you ever face this Knight to D3 and
you have the option of setting a very
nice trap for your opponent try this
Knight c694 and maybe they will play
Queen to C4 well your opponent was right
Christian Queen C4 is winning
for the opponent
let's jump to the game between Fabi and
Wesley again I mean two heavyweight
matchup and I I must say once again four
to four 26 draws between them I mean
there is nothing between these two
Gladiators uh Queen's Gambit accepted
take that number also seven and eight in
the world as well so two rating Point
difference between them right minuscule
minuscules c75 Knight C3 Now isn't that
amazing uh how fashion changes
um when I was learning this uh defense
as black uh the Queen's Gambit accepted
uh Knight C3
was taboo they you didn't want to play
Knight C3 you wanted to play these
variations where you go castles
a7a6 Queen E2 B5 uh Bishop B7 and after
moves like Bishop B7 you wanted to play
A4 if your knight was on C3 A4 always
gets met by B4 and the Knight is in the
wrong place and if you could provoke
your opponent to play the move before it
comes to D2 How Sweet It Is Right you
get this wonderful Outpost so the whole
point uh again this was uh decades ago
was that you didn't want to play Knight
C3 because you were anticipating A6 and
B5 by black and we get there and oh E4 I
believe this is uh Geller's Gambit I
think this uh gets its name from ethem
Geller a great great player from the
Soviet Union passed but it's been so
long
uh that I've seen these positions I
forgot oh my goodness
doubtlessly uh uh Fabi very very aware
that Wesley is one of Wesley's main
defenses is the Queen's Gambit except it
has set himself up for this position uh
I'm going to turn it over to you
Christian and ask you what's the latest
and greatest in the theory of this line
of the Queen's Gambit accepted so it
does seem like this move Bishop to D6
surprised Fabiano and perhaps Wesley was
just simply not remembering his opening
preparation because it does seem to be a
novelty this bishop to D6 a novelty that
allows white to get some advantage of
their Bishop to D6 let's continue with
the idea of pushing E5 and creating
problems that way with the move Queen to
E2 this seems to be the best move in the
position and now you probably have to go
something along the lines of Bishop to
E5 your Bishop is not going to be
ideally placed on E5 I'm going to be
able to Simply drop the Knight back to
F3 put some pressure and it doesn't seem
like you're that close to finishing your
development at the same time my queen on
E2 actually it's an improvement because
I don't have to worry about any Queen
trades anymore but also after Knight F3
let's say Bishop to C7 I have ideas of
E5 and then the transfer of my queen
either on uh to the Queens to the king
side excuse me via Queen to E4 or even
creating this battery on the B1 H7
diagonal for the future because I know
most likely you will end up castling
short side and getting the king to G8
and this battery on the B1 H7 diagonal
between the queen on e4 and the respawn
C2 is going to be very potent is going
to create a lot of difficulties for you
this position in fact is losing for
black so
Wesley does have to be very careful
Bishop to D6 now Fabi uh was stopped in
his tracks and he's trying to figure out
why is this move Bishop to D6 not the
right move in the position if he does
find the move Queen to E2 he's going to
uh he's going to put a lot of pressure
on his opponent now Knight bd7 is the
main move Bishop to B7 has also been
played quite a few times Bishop to B7
does allow the move E5 and it does seem
that that uh leads to an advantage for
White Knight bd7 of course is the
mainline Bishop to E3 Bishop to B7 and
now ideas of Bishop takes E6 perhaps
this is what Fabi had in store for this
game just a line which most likely by
force leads to some sort of uh an equal
position perhaps a Perpetual
nevertheless if black doesn't remember
the very precise moves they will end up
in trouble and I do believe that this is
what Wesley was predicting because he
try to remember okay I know that Knight
bd7 is most likely the main line but do
I remember later on all the intricacies
after this uh Bishop sacrificed he
decided against it he decided try to get
out of his opponent's opening
preparation as early as a move this is
movement nine with the move Bishop to D6
and this is what we have currently on
well excuse me but I just really have to
say I find this impossible to believe
like I really want to emphasize that I
do find this impossible to believe this
is the Queen's gamut accepted
basically one of the oldest lines of
play that you can imagine against queen
palm we have 500 year history you don't
make Novelties on movies
you make Novelties on Route 15. Bishop
D6 is a novel it's a novelty yeah never
been played in the hundreds of years yes
nothing is not in the database that I I
have that is I find that really
remarkable I I and again I played the
Queen's Gambit accepted my whole career
and the idea of coming up with a novelty
this early it's usually move 20. mostly
yeah it's like ridiculous forget about
it right I kind of want to also
piggyback on Christian's point you know
because this position I mean there's no
Pawns in the center so I thought in my
opinion open positions right and you
have to judge them on a move by move
basis I mean and it's all to do with
peace activity it's all to do with
maximizing the harmony of your pieces
and also as Christian pointed out
sacrifices and I I think Queen E2 is
very natural it's an old idea sure
because I play it myself
I've shown this idea quite a few years
ago okay a long long time ago right and
you know this whole idea of going
Queenie too and then you're getting okay
and a quick Rook D1 and life is good
because I mean the thing is though if
white doesn't do a single thing in this
type of position then black is going to
have a very comfortable position
yeah the queen can come to C7 or I don't
know Queen E7 maybe and uh Castle's good
times so you know I think this is why
Fabby has just decided to take a pause
and he's thinking I have to do something
I have to put pressure on the web on the
black position a quick question for you
um I mean I know I understand you want
to play E4 E5 with the move Queen E2 so
we've been looking at Bishop E5 can I
get can I say the move Knight D7 uh I
mean there are such sacrifices but in
this particular case it doesn't quite
work it feels like it it misses it
misses the mark right but okay the moves
that I would be thinking of in this type
of position would be okay first of all
do like pinning and winning you know
even though in this particular case it's
probably not winning there's Bishop G5
comes to mind uh F4 I'm a pawn Pusher
right you like that yeah but if you were
going to play F4 it comes with a little
bit of strategic risk right I mean I
understand you want to play E5 but at
the same time you're king after a move
like Bishop C5 I kind of remind you just
a little bit that it's not fun in games
all funny so this is why I was my my
first instinct was Bishop Chief in this
type of position because I feel like
development is King yes get the bishop
out and you know maybe start signaling
that Rook D1 is coming your way or even
Castle queenside as we've been inspired
by uh previous games yeah with castles
uh Queen side I think that was a hit
horror game yeah yeah Bishop G5 well
okay we're we're in New Territory we'll
uh keep an eye on this what's going on
but I do think
because Ray only has two minutes on his
clock left let's not forget they're
playing rapid chess so they will be
finishing their initial games very very
quickly way before the classical games
so
Sam with 16 minutes right now and
Counting Ray Robson only two minutes and
40 seconds definitely
hinting at the fact that he's not very
comfortable in this position
yeah wow okay that's one but also in the
game between Levon and Sam Savion uh
um Levon is just essayed a very
promising looking exchange sacrifice
Rook takes C7 with the idea that after
Queen takes C7 Bishop takes H4 white is
dominating a lot of the dark squares
most specifically F6 is it worth an
exchange uh very intriguing game going
on here I think it is and check it out
for example if you do try to Castle
well no he played Knight F3 check I
don't F3 check uh he says okay you're
gonna take the Knight
I want your piece to be on pre after
Knight takes F3 Queen takes so you don't
get the bishop on F6 you don't wow I
don't know how I'm gonna say you know
the night will come to H4
F5 as we all know will Thrive yes new
rhyme there oh there we have it
okay but uh we're inspiring exchange I
like this I love it
last two minutes and 40 seconds now he's
down to his last one minute and 20
seconds okay so we can definitely how's
the position because there's a lot of
pressure piling up on Ray Robinson right
now how is the position uh we left it at
G4 we saw the move Rook D3
finally E6 takes takes
good move
check businesses Rook to D3 Bishop E7 on
the board
and uh okay that is a pawn bishop takes
G7 I'm assuming that after Bishop takes
G7
I had I can't afford to lose both Bonds
on the king side can I I I'm assuming I
have to play Rook H7 is that true or not
Rook A8 and Rook A2 not only that but
this indirectly depends upon an H6 if
you take on H6 I take on e4 and I
Checkmate U because you don't control
the A1 Square anymore yeah
you do indeed oh
puzzle rush you would have to take the
bishop the rook and The Rook yeah yeah
so okay I think rookie Rook A2 might
just be quite problematic
Knight D2
no Sam is is is is putting a lot of
pressure right now I like this move
Knight to D2 trying to spring with the
Knight once again springing uh you guys
are springing everywhere but uh wait a
minute that's not the I always like it
when my opponent Retreats you know yeah
if you want to go back to B1 yeah
but Knight Knight D2 why is that any
good because you want to go Knight C4 so
what that's the black king look at it
well okay you you frightened me with
your last turn Okay a moment ago Nazi
forchak okay that's one
so now you defended the A3 Square I did
that was very cleverly thank you very
much but you know you still have
yeah I mean is there any trouble if you
get what if I go Knight E3 now I want to
take Knight E3 sure okay my my I I'm
stunned by I defend the critical
I like it
protect it and then you can go for the b
g seven point that's right what let's do
a joke yeah what
oh
12 seconds for Rey this boy uh and he
did play Rook a we might be going into
that variation okay you guys went check
and Knight E3 and I I'm my my head is
spinning here because I'm thinking about
Rook takes
C3
and the idea that I had was that I
wanted to put my Bishop on my Rook on A2
and my Bishop on D4 you know I'm gonna
give back my Rook I know you are you're
not going to tolerate that Bishop are
you no I
oh I mean I think we're on the same page
with that one but okay I I wow yeah and
a lot of time for Sam Shanklin right 14
minutes for Sam 12 seconds 12 seconds
yeah but there is like
a silver lining on the cloud for Ray
because yes the position is pretty
complicated but it does get added time
on the clock so yes he has 12. that's
right 10 seconds 10 seconds but it's
enough to kind of make a few past moves
and build up maybe up to a minute and
plus you have to remember these guys are
insanely good at fast time controls
yeah what if I remain calm ridiculously
greedy and I take on G7
after Rook a a ridiculously greedy yes
and just take on G7 I like it first of
all
the training is working first of all I
do like it but uh yeah well Bishop G5 Oh
I thought he was going to play Rook A2
that's why I meant by greedy I was
taking on H6 as well ah and that is why
we played Bishop chief that is why Ray
played Bishop G5 defending the pawn on
H6 attacking the Knight on D2 and wow
um okay where do we go from here
at the same time
and this might be a bit too much can we
go Rook E2
set up this discovery track with Knight
C2 for Knight C4 first well aren't you
walking into a nasty pin here my Bishop
or Bishop B5 yeah but Bishop be five
years Bishop B5 is also a good move yeah
no I don't like this okay I might have
some some escapes there but I don't like
it Bishop takes G7 by the way Bishop G5
you said he had 12 seconds did he gain
much he's now 13 seconds so he gained
one second yeah
that's not a lot it's not a lot but you
know but I mean the thing is the big key
to kind of playing this type of
situation is that the player with all
the time in the world needs to use that
time and not get caught up in the Heat
of the Moment because it's often such a
common thing one person has 10 seconds
is just blissing out the move and you
get just kind of enthusiastic and you
try to match that pace right you try and
that's what I learned to do with Walter
Brown I played him numerable times and I
think in our first five games
he won every game
with like a minute on his clock for the
last 10 moves and each time I blitzed
them
and failed
I learned to use my time play very very
slowly and set up traps for him to fall
for and then the tide turned in my favor
for a change uh double double edge game
uh going on here uh between race sorry I
just have to check in on Lavon I will
come back very very shortly this was the
game where Lavon sacrificed an exchange
we left it at this moment Knight takes
F3 Queen takes C7 Knight H4 Knight C6
what is the Knight doing on d8
absolutely nothing at least on E7 it
will defend some key squares Knight F5
Bishop takes F5 Rook takes F5 H4
is it time for another sacrifice Rook
takes F7
what do we think about it what is going
on if I go Rook takes F7 you could go
Queen B6
and remind me that you have your own
um foreign
actually so Queen E6 and then Queen
you had the same glitch as me that's
great uh so okay H4 on the board wow
these elimination games are yeah
exciting what is The Rook takes F7 I
probably have to give up the queen I
think so okay Queen takes work
you like it yeah Queen tags okay it
needs must Bishop takes Needs Bus okay
uh what do we think about this position
I like the queen uh because I've got
ways of bringing the queen in usually
whenever I'm playing against the two
Rooks I always think in terms of King
vulnerability if the Rooks possess a
safe King I like the Rooks yeah if the
and he's played Rook takes F7 and
quickly Queen takes F7 by uh Sam we're
walking straight into this line and now
the question Bishop E1
unfortunately for us the bishop sadly is
not participating on the other hand if I
can go Queen G4 Bishop H4 you know in in
a row the bishop will will be dominant
yeah so
and he's played Bishop E1 and how do you
evaluate the position I also evaluate
evaluate it according to King safety but
I also try to add in another Factor as
well which is peace coordination I mean
if the two Rooks can work well together
Bingo that's great right and uh here
yeah they're great but they're
coordinating on the back rank I mean not
not much to speak in their favor so I I
do feel that white has a big Advantage
here as you say and well what I would do
if I were in black shoes is I would play
G3 with the idea of not that I just want
to save my Pawn I do want to save my
Pawn by the way but what I really want
to do is I want to keep the bishop under
lock and key so that if you ever play C4
a bad move I will play B4 so then the
bishop is eternally kept out of the game
so I'm thinking G whoa he played H3 a
move I would have never have played age
three now the bishop goes back to G3 and
G4 is going to come
whoa instantly the the somehow this
doesn't feel right for Sam and he's
playing Knight easy this was a move
though I was considering but actually
more in the context of G3 because I
think this is a great defensive strategy
because uh a knight is a king's best
friend it really is it is it is true it
is true I I agree let's open up the
center right D4 D4 maximize that Bishop
precisely that's what I was thinking as
well is that you as wide you want your
Bishop to be
nothing you don't want to do is actually
take the pawn on G4 because that's going
to help black right opening up the G
file yes Queen takes G4 will allow Rook
G8 and great counter play against
White's King
uh G4 hg2 okay by the way yes I
understand Rook H1 is the threat yeah
okay he did play King takes G2 I was
just wondering could he play Queen
B3 check I guess not yeah it's have
fascinating tussle actually and all the
elimination matches because to me it
looks like uh Sam is now Winnie Sam yes
Sam Shanklin yes
I like lavon's position very well as we
switch but I do see what you're saying
about uh Rey being an exchange down
where did that happen Okay when we left
it we saw the move Bishop G5 Knight to
check E7 Rook A2
Bishop B2 what a move talk about closing
off the two Rooks wow and I think we're
also going to see a results in the game
between
um Zana sotonski and atusa percussion it
looks like it's headed into a draw okay
so we do think Sam Shanklin is well on
his way to converting
right they have to make a little
repetition are they is that what's going
on
I think so I mean it's just a rook rook
and four pawns on one side against
another rook and four pawns so it sounds
like this
repetition yeah and yeah this is easily
winning for Sam Shanklin against Ray
Robson let's turn our attention back to
the game of Lavon for just a moment I
don't get it yeah here's the update
um
whoops uh
strangely enough
my board's not updating
and also can stay with the bird's eye
view ah something happened to my board
because uh after he came
right now only 38 seconds
Bishop here
97 D4 hg2 King takes G2 is when we left
it what happened after King takes G2 do
you have it on your board no I have I
uh we're just having a few technical
glitches on our side but we'll we'll
watch it live
King takes G2 I'm assuming Knight G6 was
played Queen B3
King came to F6 and now the queen has
stepped forward to B4 attack
is definitely saying a dark Square
strategy in this one he's trying to
focus on that pressure on the E5 Pawn as
well as
its defender on D6 and this is exactly
what he's doing right now
and the King on G2 is so safe right what
you don't want to do as black is play
the move Knight to H4 and allow the
trade between the bishop and the Knight
you want to keep that Knight and try to
create some sort of counter Chances with
the Knight on G6 which is not going to
be easy by the way I'd love this move C5
all right this is like a dream move by
white because it just blows up the
center yep against Black's King and it
freezes The Rook on B8 you were talking
about coordination of The Rook the
bishop on G3 does a great job at
defending the white king this is looking
five seconds four seconds
and he took on D4 oh Bishop with two
seconds on his clock he took on uh D4
levonne so you've got Queen
three check that might be a nasty
intermezzo
but why well where do you go with the
King maybe to
an attempting to leave have that
check-in reserve and instead just go
well no no no very specifically where do
you go with your king it's a very good
question like you know if you go to D7
I'm gonna go check on F7 and that costs
all kinds of material so I probably have
to give you the d61 go to F6 perhaps
that's my refresh my board and it did
work sorry F6 F6
and then I take on D6 with the pawn it's
not looking good yeah it's not pretty
right you you can do that I I feel like
you can probably also take on D4 but I
feel the move that you recommended Queen
to B3 is just so forceful right and so
clear right there's no counter chances I
am going to take that pawn on D6 and
create a ridiculously strong Pawn Center
as well as a passport by the way now
that I I realize that I I I missed a
point that I I was fearful that I had to
take on but I can go D5 yeah yeah and
that is incredibly powerful so a lot of
things seem to be winning yes just
checking in on Sam shanklin's game yeah
Sam is definitely converting this he's
got a passer uh and he's material ahead
so Lavon and do we have a result in that
elimination match well I I'm just
assuming that the game between Anna
satonsky atusia is going to finish in a
draw any time now and but everything is
completely up for grabs in the game
between
Catcher nemtva And tatv okay I mean it
looks wild and both players on their
final minute and by the way we did see
the move Queen B3 check by uh Lavon
forced the king to go to F6 and then he
just simply recaptured on uh D4 this
bishop is eyeballing The Rook on B8 and
that was why we saw them of Rook E8
isn't it is it time to just capture a
pawn here
maybe even E5 oh boy the problem is
sometimes
you get so attracted to what you can
achieve in these positions that you kind
of freeze a little bit
of options right yeah and they all look
very promising indeed
so how do we continue this one
can we go D7 uh and I've got to check I
guess it's just a single check
can I go to F1 perhaps even even F1 but
for the moment you still have
you have an issue how are you going to
stop this guy this guy is really
streaking up the board the answer is I'm
not I mean that is the correct answer
there's no there is no answer maybe
seven
King
this is why I wanted King F1 Queen came
back to C2 Let me refresh my board my
apologies
uh he didn't play D7 he played Queen
aha he's not allowing the rookie to
check uh Rick pigs you walk into
an absolute pin
after Rook D5 but I mean
is it so dangerous because I'm just
thinking you know there's a lot of ideas
for check
Bishop takes F4 Bishop takes F4 Rook
takes F4
I like the bishop on G3 very very very
much look you're still probably winning
am I Rook takes D4 Rook takes D4 Queen
F2
thank you that clears the cobwebs Rook
takes D4 Queen F2 check and for that
reason he played Rook h8 okay but now
isn't queen queen C8 just gonna bag it
sequence is seven well Queen C7 the
queen C7 rotates
bag it yeah put it in the back okay
Queen C8 on is that like you're at the
grocer and you're gonna bag it up take
it please put it in the bank okay that's
another one that I like it seems to be
over it is going to be over Queen C8
that is that is a winner no question
about it
and we see the first resignation well
done and we are expecting a draw in the
game between uh
Anna and to take a look at the game
between Ray Robson and Sam Shanklin
because that one is about finished as
well
I also wanted to turn
another elimination
game between uh tatev and Katarina
okay because that game is a crazy Pagani
Brooke
a moment ago there was a a board full of
pieces and now there's been some very
significant trades and
tatev's doing well isn't she I I see you
have the game of uh Sam Shanklin maybe
we should follow yeah let's follow that
one if we've
because
we'll go with the cameraman
you remember Ray Robson has had 12
seconds for the past half an hour
for the past 20 moves he's had those 12
seconds and he's holding on to him too
well here you just as white how is it is
this to convert
it should be
quite easy I would suppose right
you're going to put the bishop on D4
defend that pawn on C5 and try to go for
B5
okay but at a certain moment three
seconds he's done it I don't know but at
the certain moment I'm just gonna go G6
and I'm going to take the bishop and I'm
going to go G7 that's okay no problem
that's okay then I will try to say that
your king is way too far I'm going to
sacrifice my Rook
and he's played B5 so he is inviting
Rook takes D4 that's fine that's fine
yes
he hasn't come to us uh before it
doesn't look that clear to me guys
it really doesn't and
let's not forget Sam has been having a
lot of trouble finishing
his games especially that game between
himself and Wesley so yesterday he was
winning
he wasn't met he didn't manage to take
Wesley down and then lost the match
we see a reiteration of that hmm
good point
I don't know King B4 and that pawn on B3
I mean so he's played Rook F5 I assume
with the simple idea that when you do
play King B4 he wants to defend
talking moving his way it doesn't look
clear at all right now
I have to reluctantly agree with you
here this is not the clean Victory I
expected Sam to cruise to so I
understand what he's trying to do right
now he's trying to go Rook to E4 and
that's why he played Rook to G4 Rook to
E4 Rook takes D4 and then go G7 and with
the Rook on the third rank I'm going to
be able to both stop your d-pawn and
defend the B3 bomb sorry that was my
fault yeah so the idea was that what you
were saying was that the Rook goes to E4
I take and thanks to the fact that the
Rook keeps the black king at Bay I could
then trade and play G7 so here similar
idea something like Rook d
I'm going to take back with the rook and
then G7 I'm going to sacrifice the rook
and create the past one with C
almost gotcha I was thinking to play
some kind of Rook
yeah I was played with three seconds
Bishop C3 was played with three seconds
King takes B3 is coming
that's
I look I'm going to go ahead and predict
that this is an easy draw for
for Ray robs
why Rook to D3 Rook Bishop D4 Bishop D4
rugby Rook G3
Rook to G3 thank you
thank you very much for that by the way
the Rooks belong as we know behind the
past bonds and Bishop E5 was a good move
to stop that very idea that you just
mentioned uh Jovi uh Rook to G3
oh my gosh but now this is looking like
a draw Rook D5 Bishop C why didn't he
play Bishop C3 repeating
repeating the position he didn't play it
he played Rook to D5 Bishop to D4 what
I mean
right sorry Sam hasn't been very
successful he can't quite play Rook
takes Bishop because of the issue of
Rook takes right
so our our main achievement is that we
can win The Rook but unfortunately with
the pawn already on C4 black will make a
draw this is what
um
Sam is trying to avoid essentially
so Rook takes D4 Rook takes D4
exclamation mark that's the that's the
key yeah that is the key and
it's very easy for some
build a bridge right to stop this I mean
let's do this exactly I liked your idea
a moment ago of somehow bringing the
Rook behind the pond but in this case
yeah let's go off the B3 pawn it
certainly does I don't like that move
Rook default the very last moon right
here I thought you have to make some
move I don't know maybe like Rook E3 or
something I really wanted to get in that
move Rook to G3 but after
Bishop D4 I now
thinks that's the draw that's the draw
Rook takes Rook takes and uh Ray playing
that move very quickly with alacrity you
bet uh G7 Rook D7 check he's gonna
sacrifice his Rook for the passer okay
so him will he picked does the same idea
Gets behind the pawn okay
I was going for the yes and then okay
and uh I think the players are now just
gonna be
what is those moves what is saved by Ray
impressive
I can see the detection on Sam's face
and uh there you go it's King against
King it is
what an amazing and you just saw Ray
exultant like
how did I do that how did I get out of
here with a draw and what about the
ladies elimination do you have a result
between Anna satonsky atusa percussion
that has finished in a draw as we
expected and whoa there's a king of D3
it's a one elimination game last and uh
Tata has a has a Perpetual check in her
pocket anytime she wants it with Queen
G4 but she's clearly got her eyes set on
promoting their Pawn to it right so the
first move that kind of brings to mind
is just to move the king okay I was
catch catcher's move okay nice move from
catcher Queen Eve well we're going to
see you four questions I'm going to go
check your check and then H2 then you
make a queen yeah yeah but then the
queen of
she's done it uh Queen E5 was a mistake
Queen G4 and she can promote her Pawn to
a queen which she has just done
properly by the way for all of those of
you in our audience please note that you
put the queen on the board then press
the clock not the other way around
and Tata
wins the first elimination game with the
black pieces putting herself it really a
great position to continue in the
tournament let's see
um
going into the regular uh classical uh I
have the game between Arena
and bacon it's one of those Queens
Gambit accepted uh Pawn sacrifices with
Bishop H5 good time for a break it is a
good time for a break
oh okay yes are you ready to do some
modeling yeah
I mean I'm I'm the Vanna White of the uh
yeah I'll give it to you okay give me my
modeling my modeling career is about to
come up go ahead okay right okay because
today we are offering this premium 20
inch vinyl roll up board featuring The
American Cup and St Louis chess club
logos with attractive red and blue
gradient squares this easy to pack board
is perfect for the on-the-go trip and
travel shop today and line online at
qbtxstl.com I've got one of them you got
a collection
and uh okay during the break we're going
to see a video where we asked the
players about the future of American
chess
[Music]
there's a lot of rising talent in the
United States how do you see the future
of American chess yeah things are going
great for American chess I mean I
definitely think the St Louis chess club
has contributed a lot to that uh since
it opens its doors in 2008 has provided
so many opportunities good tournaments
for young players lots of support United
States the best country in the world to
be a chess professional right now so we
have very strong up-and-coming players I
see it at the like chess camps that I'm
teaching that it's becoming really
crowded and we can see like how many
talents are going to come out of that so
I think maybe in 10 15 years it's going
to be even more crowded than it's now
every generation of American players has
had so much more opportunity than the
one that came before it I know that I
had so much more than all the people who
mentored me and the ones coming after me
have so much more than I did and the
ones coming out for them will have so
much more further and you know the
United States has produced some pretty
strong players you know we've got Ray
Robson and myself and Hikaru three guys
over 2 700 that you know the US has
produced from day one and uh and yeah I
think that we have a bright future ahead
with all of our up-and-coming youngsters
I think um it's it's really great to see
what has happened with chess here in St
Louis the opportunities for the junior
players I think right now at least as we
look at this event in the women's field
specifically there's Alice Lee who's 14
years old and certainly she's a very
bright future ahead of her just in
general for the players who are younger
the players who haven't had these
opportunities to compete against the
best players it's really something
special for them and I think it's really
good in terms of further American Trust
I think American chess has been growing
the last decade a lot I keep hearing
from players around my age complaining
how at the open tournaments there are so
many kids and they're also underrated
and they all play so well but of course
for the future it's great the US has a
strong team and for the last couple of
years I think they're supporting
especially the Young Generation we did a
lot of tournaments in Saint Louis and I
think we're going to see a lot of
Juniors to shine in the world
competition so yeah they have bright
future in my opinion well I think the
Young Generation they're insanely strong
and they're working hard they're playing
a lot of tournaments this is really
great that we have these tournaments
where the very top players get to
interact with up-and-coming players we
have and for women's chess we also have
some very young players like obviously
who's playing here she's I think she's
still only 13 she's 23.60. for me
personally that I'm a newcomer to
American chess it's a great joy to see
so many talented kids you know and
they're up and coming
to
Mishra and also Alice Lee
we're extremely talented and they're
very very young so I think the future is
bright you could probably have like
three really strong Olympia teams if we
are allowed to send three teams in the
future yeah I think it's great obviously
I think the chess club has definitely a
part to do with that just incentivizes
young players to really think that there
is a path in professional pursuing
professional chess yeah I think there's
a long way for us to go there's a lot of
potential it's going really well there's
a lot of young players you mentioned
Alice Lee today I played on a team with
her in online chess event for the St
Louis archbishops and she beat a 2700
rated player so she's she's done that
before I mean she beat another like
super Grand Master very recently so I
think we'll see a lot of like 2600 plus
players from that group 2600 maybe some
2700 plus players as well and maybe some
future top players as well uh I think
definitely
um like my peers and people are slightly
older are definitely like really strong
I think that American chess is like
really bright I know that chest itself
has become super popular lately and for
me to see like a lot of my classmates
who wouldn't normally be playing chess
uh start playing chess
um in class for in free time I feel like
that indicates that because of the
popularity of American chess is growing
more people will start to play another
result we would definitely see a lot of
new strong players in the Next
Generation overall like us chess uh St
Louis chess club is doing a great job in
like advertising the how like chess can
be like really great super fun to play
and overall yeah I think that
um American chess definitely has a
really bright future
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
and we are back day three of the
American Cup and so far we've started
off by focusing on the elimination
around they were really compelling they
were great the Ray Robson Sam Shanklin
game what was going on there Ray makes
an amazing save Great Exchange Sacrifice
by Lavon he gets Victory and then of
course in the ladies uh to have Four
Queens on the board the Queens on the
board and she's now
let's take a look at the results let's
have a look at the results in D and in
the matchup between Sam Syrian and the
one aronian Devon just played a
fantastic game you know he just
completely I was demolished Sam with the
white pieces but now Sam needs to win
and he will be playing with the white
pieces and in our second elimination
match we have Ray Robson who was
skirting on the edge of the feet you
know definitely had 12 seconds at points
and he will have the white pieces
against a very well prepared Sam
Shanklin who perhaps will be
disappointed right in the first game and
when it comes to the women's section we
saw a very calm draw between atusa
focusion and Anna satonski so everything
to play for here right but in the last
second game in between tatif abrahamian
about this one it wasn't calm in the
first game that tattoo scoring a very
critical win with the black pieces and
now she will have the white pieces
against catcher who is in a must-win
situation as uh Sam sevion is as well
which gives us a chance to catch our
breath in the classical games and
bringing up on my board the game between
Arena and a begum and this is a
well-known Pawn sacrifice in the Queen's
Gambit accepted this uh Bishop G4 H3
Bishop back normally I'm used to seeing
Bishop takes F3 followed by Knight D7
but maybe this is prep and if so we're
gonna have a Christian to explain to us
the prep of today this isn't prep you're
shaking your head
no prep going on I've just messed it up
completely begging that is she played
the move Knight bd7 and as you were
mentioning yes sir you do have to take
the Knight first F through a bishop
takes F3 excuse me and only after you
can go Knight to D7 Queen takes B7 now
C5 comes right and it does give lack a
lot of compensation for the simple fact
that right now whenever I take on D4 you
don't have the Knight hopping and
joining of The Fray after taking on D4
so this is a completely different
situation this would have given baggy
man I would assume this was in her files
as well but of course she played Knight
D7 first which allows just a simple pick
of the pawn queen takes B7 this is what
we have C5 this is still not over
there's still some compensation because
I do have this idea of taking on D4
lingering this queen on B7 is going to
get tapped by the Recon A8 let's see
Rook to B8 Queen to A6 Queen to C7 so
she decided by the way not to take on A7
because after Bishop to D6 later on well
perhaps it would have been
um she would have been able to actually
take this Pawn on A7 I'm looking at the
engine right now and it does give white
quite a significant Advantage my guess
is that she did not understand that the
queen actually gets out the A6
B5 A4 and then finally finds her way
back home to D1 or C2 so yeah taking the
pawn on A7 would have given white a
tremendous advantage two points
Advantage out of the opening she did not
do that Queen 286 Queen to C7 now we
have Bishop to B5 on the board I have to
say look white is still in poor position
to win this one definitely she still has
a significant advantage and back him
will have to fight very hard to to find
the compensation in this particular game
very very big mistake early in the
opening by not taking on F3 first and
playing Knight bd7
thank you for that Christian in our
other game between Alice Lee and Naji uh
we had this such I really like what
Alice did right up to this moment after
Knight B8 to D7 this I've played uh
numerous times as white and I love
White's position with a big big
exclamation mark after the move castles
like if you play castles and I get to
play G3 and I put my Bishop back on G2
essentially I'll play A5 I'll put the
queen side under lock and key and then
I'll play F4 and I get this free attack
with the two Bishops and I love White's
position
um the move Bishop E2 maybe gave
Naji just the the timing she needed for
the move Queen A5 this is a little bit
um
I want to say risky because after Bishop
to D2 I think Alice
got stuck around these parts like Queen
before she's seeing the pawn on e4 she's
seeing the pawn on B2
doesn't work I have no idea A5 A5 and
you invite me to take the pawn which I'm
going to do I'm committed
and I'll take your knight oh yes
okay okay yeah it's all right I didn't
thought I did not see that right yeah no
no no good morning St Louis it is good
morning
yeah but it's strange because what
happened is she kind of messed I think
Alice messed herself up a little bit
after castles B5 Bishop back to F3 it
looks like a little too much uh chewing
and throwing Naji has compromised her
Queen side pose I mean we're not
compromised as a strong word but I want
to say is that she's determined the
structure which does allow Alice to hop
in with a knight to C4 because I was
warned by a coach a long long time ago I
know you're trying to say something it's
okay that you should be very reluctant
about pushing B5 B4 said quickly
we're going to get you a new coach
because it's actually the reverse the
reverse is that you don't want a
situation where White's the one who's
played A5 and you never get any space on
the queen side you're going to have to
play B5 and after an opposant you're not
going to be enjoying the position upon
on A6 conversely what we have in the
game is a dream you're taking a Pawn on
B7 that's really kind of backward and
awkward I understand you've got a square
but after Knight E5 Bishop here we're
going to take this fellow we're going to
take this fellow right we're going to
play castles you're going to play Knight
D2 I'm going to play Knight D7 you're
going to play Knight C4 I'm gonna go
Queen back to C7
and this trade of the minor pieces
because I have this real space deficit
this trade of the minor pieces has
actually worked out okay I still like
white don't get me wrong I I have a
preference for white physician but it's
nowhere you put the pawn back on B7 yeah
yeah and you put this Pawn on eight a
five yeah that's my recipe for uh
success in this particular structures as
well without without fail I'll you'll
see me putting a Pawn on the A5 and I
also wanted to kind of highlight one
idea that black often has when you do
put your Pawn on a the white Pawn on A5
we'll get there yeah like let's say just
here right here A5 yeah okay here here
but you know if that pawn were on B7 yes
and you know black did try to break out
yes what's a very nice idea is actually
you just exchange pawns yeah and then
you sit with your Rook on A2 nice and
then you double up on this week
because a lot of people are like why are
you putting a reconnective and you're
just like it's fine it's right I'm
holding everything together nice but
even here I I mean black has got the
dream kind of benoni structure I kind of
call it benoni structure it is a benoni
uh it maybe not the greatest dream or
anything like that but at least uh
you're not as cramped I've got some
space right but I mean even then I would
say white is better sure sure I'm not
arguing that I do like white I'll put my
Rook
at a certain moment you have one break
one break only you can prepare it but
eventually you're going to have to go E5
eventually and then we're going to trade
everything on E5 and I'm gonna hope that
I'll be okay uh so I feel like although
I do like Alice's position it's not as
good I would say as she had it a moment
ago Arena's doing fine and let's see
about the
um open uh first of all let's go to the
gate Christian is uh okay well let's
jump over to Christianity
just because you guys jump to that game
and that's actually the game that I was
checking as well and it does seem like
Fabi had a very intriguing opportunity
and he's been playing and hinting at the
idea of sacrificing a piece on E6
especially in this variation with the
pawn on e4 not necessarily forcing but
trying to coax the bishop to get early
on to B7 and allow this bishop takes E6
which he did Wesley so did play this
move Bishop to B7 and right now Fabiano
could have taken on E6 Bishop takes E6 F
takes e66 and we would have went
straight into this line Queen to E7 you
have to defend uh the queen and the pawn
on G7 but guess what this Pokemon G7 is
not in fact defended because this queen
is over protected Queen takes D6 Rook to
G8 this has been played before between
Checker and Andrew Hong and if I'm not
mistaken I think I was doing commentary
for that tournament and I was quite
impressed with the preparation that
checkout came into that particular
matchup that was a huge huge Grandmaster
uh clash and after G3 checkout went on
to win that one it's three points for
the piece nevertheless I do have this
beautiful Center and after E5 potential
uh E5 the Knight is not going to find
the right place where to land and it
does seem like the King on E8 is also
quite exposed you don't have a clear way
to exchange the Queens you would love to
do that as black to play Queen to E7 and
force the trade of the Queens that's not
going to happen I'm going to shy away uh
from that with a move such as Queen to F
or maybe even Queen to B6 and with the
King on E8 so exposed you will be in
danger he did not play that yeah
he played the move after Bishop to B7
Rook to E1 which also makes a lot of
sense first of all you're setting up
this idea of E5 that's a huge threat in
one move defending upon on e4 but also
you're setting up this move that just
landed on the board Knight to D5 now of
course the idea is pretty clear if you
do take on D5 I'm going to recapture I'm
going to get that Bishop back on E5
you're in trouble right now with the
black pieces you do not want to touch
that Knight on D5 but what can you do in
the position the idea is pretty clear
after Knight to D7 and this is what Fabi
is looking at and Fabi has tried to
assess which is Wesley so uh Wesley saw
his homework right now as well is that
after Knight to F3 Bishop to B8 doesn't
really make a lot of sense because
you're losing simply too many tempies
and I'm going to Simply Be able to take
on F6 if you do take with the Knight
Queen takes d8 King takes d8 and it just
seems like I have the better placed
pieces right now you still need to lose
the tempo to make the connection between
the Rooks and get the king to safety
that's actually two tempies in the
position so you're still far away from
finishing let's say your development in
the position you don't want to see this
on the board as black but what can you
do I am attacking your Bishop
will you allow me to get to Bishops and
this is what Wesley needs to understand
yes I can give you the dark Square
bishop and in return I will get very
Dynamic play after Castle you will take
only five you still need to lose a Tempo
because right now this Knight on D5 is
under attack so you have to take on F6
Queen takes F6 Rook to d8 comes on the
board Rook ac8 comes on the board and
this Knight most likely will land on D3
despite the fact that white has the pair
of Bishops you're just simply too far
behind in development and black has
enough Dynamic compensation in this
position in fact the engine is saying
that black is better in this instance so
this is the opportunity that Wesley has
in the position right now check out that
head to head between these two
incredible exactly not much um but I
mean is
I don't know somehow I didn't feel like
the the kind of resulting position was
that bad for white I felt like white
could go in it's not that loud but
definitely black has equalized them
probably is on the better side of
equality but I mean is is there because
sometimes you have to be careful with
the quality sometimes it or like one
side being slightly better because it
involves like special kind of moves but
on a practical level it might not be
because I was thinking I could hear you
you can't really sound a retreat with
black with white because if you do the
night Springs forward to D3 but after
Knight takes Knight Queen takes and I
was thinking just one consolidating move
like I was thinking Queenie too okay
my moves are also quite easy right yeah
your pieces are quite active okay
and then Queen G6 is happening isn't it
that's right yeah it's a very natural we
should be three very natural and then
somehow other you need some magic I mean
could you do things like no it was like
Bishop 52 and then Bishop A5
can I take on e4 probably that's too
much
um asking a lot but uh well it might be
possible you know Knight to D3 and then
Bishop A5 was my wonderful tactical
Point well what you've done is got
yourself a little bit worse right
yeah like I'll say and they'll take you
don't have it the two Bishops anymore
and yeah okay it's not like you're a
danger of losing no no no no no nothing
like that but something kind of feels
like black is maybe the one who's uh I
don't know dictating a little bit G5 H6
and join the better side of equality yes
exactly something like that enjoying the
Sunny Side of the torture a little bit
um not what Fabby had in mind when he
was thrashing uh Knight D5 on the board
um Wesley's uh you know calm the storm
how about Hikaru what is going on in the
game between uh hikar and lanira and we
when we left it we left it exactly at
this moment h7h5 a good move not giving
up anything essentially uh linear saying
I'm going to match you on the king side
and maybe play the move Bishop to G4 in
anticipation of the move Bishop G4 G3 by
Hikaru in order to give him himself uh
Bishop back to G2 Bishop F5 castles
castles
C6
and it sure feels
even
in fact wait a minute A4 okay yeah it's
it didn't I was about to say uh who
who's getting the Sunny Side of this
torture it it feels like it's just even
uh yeah because okay I I don't know if
you have this definition for yourself
but it's a definition I've used my whole
career when is the opening over
when is the opening over yeah when is
the opening over and you're now in the
middle game
well that's the modern definition no the
old definition my definition is when the
Rooks were connected so in this case we
would say that Lanier's connected his
Rooks there's nothing between the two
Rooks and therefore the opening is over
for black whereas white still has to
connect his Rook so I use this old
definition and I have always thought of
it in those terms that when I'm
connected my Rooks are connected yeah
yeah yeah Applause on the back I've done
I've done what I'm supposed to do but I
I have to say
despite this position looking as level
as they come I still feel that white has
a bit of a pull even though they haven't
connected the Rooks just primarily
because this Pawn on age five it's
undefended and it's different it's it's
not defended by porn is what I want to
say by the rook and so you know you can
use that aspect
in a very small way say for instance now
you connect the Rooks of Bishop D2 you
can
at the right time going I don't really
want to play Knight G2 but you know that
kind of thing where you say well give me
control over the E line now it's such a
minuscule thing but I think it's enough
to kind of give someone a niggle okay
fair enough uh one of the uh
definitions that uh Victor korchnoy hit
me with when I was training with him and
he said a weakness is only a weakness is
if you can attack it and this Pawn on H5
is kind of hard to attack I mean I get
the fact that your Bishop on F3 is but
there's not many other pieces and in the
meanwhile black yes he will play 97 or
Knight f8 himself and go for G6 so I'm
really feeling a balanced game going on
here let's go to Alice uh well that's
that was not honest that was not Alice
sorry uh Arena and here is Alice because
I was more than curious is if she was
going to play yes she did
playing 19. followed your life right
they are but there's one little
difference that Naji can do here is she
goes Queen C7
she could play Queen C7 and after Knight
C4 Knight B6 exactly Knight C4 Knight B6
and I think that that's actually
more precise if you manage to eliminate
the Knight then you're happy exactly
then you're very happy with that this
bishop is uh unobstructed on this a long
diagonal and that is why I think Alice
is not getting that plus she played that
Bishop E2 and Bishop F3 she lost that
key Tempo how's your pupil doing uh
Christian well not that much happened we
left it off after this move Bishop to B5
and she is still thinking trying to
figure out her way out of this difficult
situation because once again the onus is
on her she needs to prove her
compensation right now and it's not easy
to do uh that because Bishop to B5 I
have to say I really like this move it
sets up a clear plan and that is to play
the move Knight to E5 followed by either
Knight to C6 or maybe even Knight D7 and
start exchanging pieces start getting
ready to enter that end game with an
extra Pawn which would be the ideal
scenario for white so this is what we
have right now Rook to B6 seems to be
the best move maybe C takes D4 in the
position as well I'm looking at this
position C takes D4 from a human's
perspective it's not an easy move to
make because you're allowing the Knight
to get into play Knight takes D4 then
you start seeing Knight C6 ideas maybe
even Knight takes E6 ideas on the board
it just simply doesn't feel right so the
first move that I was looking at was
Bishop to E7 but this is the problem
Knight to E5 now if you go Castle I have
this idea with Knight to C6 everything
comes with Tempo and just your one move
short from defending of all of your
pieces so this is what I'm worried about
for a good Rook begin to hear jonova and
I'm definitely liking what Irina crush
is bringing to the table also right now
51 minutes for Irina 35 minutes for
Tokyo Genova with a very very difficult
position and a very difficult
compensation to prove in this particular
matchup the difference between playing
Bishop takes F3 earlier it's it's huge I
mean it is it versus the current
position where Arena can recapture with
the Knight on F3 is it's like night and
day there's compensation versus no
compensation exactly yeah yeah because
now C takes D4 and Knight takes D4
that's probably what you have to do but
you're going to play down a pawn and and
this bishop on H5 is no longer uh a pot
it has no potency uh castles for white
and as you've been pointing out that
missing B7 Pawn has made this the C6
Square uh extremely extremely important
I agree with this completely
but I mean is there some compensation
only because I mean a little bit you
know the night on D2 the Bishops right
right but it's like castles Knight B3
and I'm you have to prove it in the next
three moves right yeah yeah this is what
I'm thinking you know can you do
something immediately immediately
um the problem is you also need to
finish your development yourself as well
I mean it's a difficult like for
instance Bishop comes out to
okay I didn't know where that
comes out
the
four before okay four you know okay I'll
I'll ask the question and now the bishop
can drop back to no no don't go A3 don't
go away through Castle why why not right
I was trying to oh you want to play Rook
B6 or you want to play I did want to
play Bishop Bay five 56 that was like
Central oh wait a moment I love that I
love chasing that Bishop too he yeah and
then the queen comes oh hang on wait the
queen can come down to
[Music]
um
you know that that
um but it was very strange in in
American circles during the 1972 period
of Boris basket versus Bobby Fischer uh
the media in America always portrayed
Boris as the Communist Soviet super
robotic agent and Boris was actually
completely opposite of a person you
thought that would grow up in an
autocratic Nation like the Soviet Union
because he was very much his own man
and so one of the early games that I've
ever played with Boris baraski we we
reached the position where he was
winning that he needed to put together a
series of very good moves this actually
happened at the board
so there I was playing the superior
Soviet youth model Boris baskey and he
goes
[Laughter]
it was like you
you back
okay you know he rolls up the sleeves
and he crushes me but it was like wow
you know that was not what the media
portrayed Boris as you know like it was
some good comments it was never a
communist it was never a good communist
remarkable on that subject did you not
call her the Arbiter and go distraction
I was just like amused this is like
great
no I don't think I would have liked to
touch the pieces afterwards and Well he
kind of rub them together but good point
now that you think wow I mean not even
use the sanitation lotion either right
well those were the days where they
smoked at the board so I mean what can I
tell you
um I'm having trouble for begum as well
she did go Rook to B6 because she did
make a move she did play the move Rook
to B6 and the queen will drop back I
suppose more or less instantly most
likely and now A4 you need to address
that pain because it is again
you don't want to see that land on the
board so you have to go point to B7 any
anything a queen to B7 oh and that is
the thing I want to take that yeah that
is a Tempo against the bishop
um okay Bishop
I think she needs to go for this okay
it was going to be in a much worse
situation but
you know do we invite the end game with
Queen takes D7 right well you were the
one telling me that uh you you your your
Pawn up and you play and I think Knight
takes decision Knight takes D7 you when
when you're a pawn up you should yeah
you go to your ending feel the game
immediately so let's take on D4 now
I suppose
I suppose I should play what do you
think Knight C4 okay I like it you're
allowing me to give you a nice little
question oh check no I don't like I
don't like it if you give me a check
sorry apologies neither C5 or to E5
isn't that night coming to D3 yeah
have I have I spoiled it or not just uh
let me know
yeah so let's go Knight D3 okay castles
Knight to D3 and it's very nice
yes you have to find the place for my
Rook which is not easy and queen A4 by
the way is on the board queen Queen on
the board yeah on the board right now so
let's say I go Rook B7 it's just a guess
right right let's go Rook B7 no you can
just develop your Bishop because there
is one throw no there wasn't even one
thread on the board
ah but um
I want to Rob
black of the two Bishops yes I mean okay
you you your knight is still
uncomfortably in my business but you can
do things like oh Bishop takes Bishop
yep
and then maybe E5 and then E5 yeah
Christian understands me
channeling
channeling his inner Jovi yes I got it
again but we're in trouble
don't allow uh my tricks yeah
um okay but besides okay I was trying to
solve it really isn't I was trying to
solve uh arenas
uh problems if I can say it like that
most directly after Queen B7 was there
an alternative of maybe retreating
perhaps just go back right the drawback
of getting the Rook out on B6 is that it
will always get hit with the move Knight
to C4 but but here the problem I thought
was I've got a G2 issue so I can't play
Knight takes D4 okay so that after takes
I if I take with the pawn I think that's
compensation that's right but if I take
with the queen I think I'm going to get
uh A6 was played whoa whoa whoa yeah
boxed around pretty good E6 was the wait
a minute can I take that pawn
wow the training I don't know about this
A6 move this doesn't inspire me any
confidence uh-huh that's pound number
two it is uh
it is true
I think I can think that
I'm not 100 sure what her idea behind
this is yeah Queen A7 just 37 Bishop P5
um
yeah this is not looking uh promising
for a young
no no
um I liked Queen B7 because of the
um x-ray attack on G2 yeah I thought
Queen B7 followed by C5 takes D4 offered
a measure of compensation a7a6 feels
like
the wrong the wrong move uh quickly just
taking a look at Alice before I believe
the elimination games will start yeah
oh Queen B3 okay uh again from
um
naji's point of view I mean this is like
uh it's great that she's instead of the
pawn being on B7 the pawn is now on B4
as black I would be very anxious to play
the move a seven eight for me a6a5
myself just to stop this and I'll meet
Knight C4 any day any yes yeah exactly
and I think that she is equalized I'm
gonna go quickly to hikaru's game Hikaru
found an interesting place because he
retreated his Bishop to G2
we're treating the bishop on G2 and
threatening Rook D1 and uh obviously
lenya is not going to
missed this one and move the Knight to
E7 giving the bishop an escape square
and now
well the ball is in linear's court where
is he going to retreat the bishop I mean
I'd be a little reluctant to go to Asics
myself not that I find the move Bishop
A6 the square A6 unattractive the thing
I find unattractive is that be my
opponent may find B4 B5 and that's
probably why I'd end up going the other
way is this a draw invitation though why
why after Bishop E2
uh I didn't think about that Bishop
Bishop B2 is a great group and a river
can go to D2 yes
that is the only alternative but then it
looks like one of the most
ugly you know like rubbish based six
right then it doesn't seem like but now
now you can kind of well the same thing
right B4 B5 and The Rook on D2 nicely
placed maybe this is his plan right yeah
but I mean I was thinking the bishop
would go
somewhere else okay G4 that's the
ultimate that's an alternative
alternative
uh if you do end up capturing you might
this light squared Bishop might ask
what's my role um
it's all about two Bishops right well I
don't know that light Square Bishop is
looking mighty a similar situation is
happening in uh the Fabiano game he got
the two Bishops did he yes
he did go Knight F3 as we Knight takes
Knight takes and he play Bishop to F4
but whoa whoa whoa whoa my spidey sense
is tingling is that a pawn that is a
pony
I don't ask for much
just give me a fun and I'm perfectly
content you know
um is there enough compensation is the
question well first of all which which
way should I be if I if I take right I
think you have to take with a part and
if I take and then take on e4 yeah
so I mean I agree this bishop
has never had such a joy
but that is can I set up some sort of an
attack on the C file perhaps group The
C1
legal legal
um
[Music]
as if you get rid of the Queens
trade Queens okay fair fair
Rook 81. yeah and isn't Italian
to challenge one of these uh open file
looks
I mean it does seem like white is going
to have enough compensation for equality
for equality that's right not more than
that no just go H3 and perhaps with the
two Bishops yeah it should be enough
uh let's remind everybody as we get
ready for the eliminate the second
elimination game where things stand in
the Elimination Brackets definitely
because some players are already on
their last legs and uh taking the
elimination bracket in the open section
we see that Levon aronian does lead one
point by one point it uses a draw to
move on to the next elimination and
Samsung Edge will have to
basically defeat Lavon aronian with the
white pieces when it came to the other
elimination match between Sam Shanklin
and Ray Robson that was a very nervy
draw but Ray Robson was resilient so he
does kind of claim some more Advantage
but still everything to play for that
exactly I mean he's feeling good that
he's not down and in the ladies section
the elimination bracket for the ladies
yes similar story it is exactly say the
same story so we had a decisive
encounter between tatef abrahamian and
katika nemkova abrahamian leads by one
point sir kachika must win but this time
with the black pieces that's tough it's
very hard and so Anna satonski and Tusa
percussion they ended in a draw and you
have to remember that those people who'd
lost and are in a muscular situation it
is their last chance if you lose the
match that is it you are out you are
eliminated
Scandinavian defense yeah I see from the
game with tat have that the game is
underway let me see if I can find it on
my
no I think I'm missing it
for the moment I don't have my link set
up properly how about you yeah I have it
yes okay
so and we do have a Scandinavian I think
we need you for the moment because I
don't think we have your board set up
synchronized with the cameras
but here we go we have a Scandinavian
with Queen A5 these days the
Scandinavians being played almost
exclusively with Queen D6 which I just
find so shocking
26 yeah or I believe it's called is it
the patser's variation we're going to E5
how do you know I was playing this queen
this exploration for a long time
so we should probably be called the no I
work I got given it was in the days
before computers oh my word so old
before computers and so I got given a
pamphlet by um one of my old mentors no
it was just like some some photocopied
pamphlet or from somewhere and it was
given to me by my old Mentor Bob Wade
and it was all about this queen D6 A6 B5
variation and I was like okay this looks
good okay and I remember Tony miles
looking at it and going what nonsense
have you concocted at the board and I
was like whoa
don't blame me or blame the pamphlet
exactly okay so uh
this variation with Bishop f
I mean I have to say it has fallen out
of fashion okay because white tends to
react very aggressively like Tata is
going to be indicating you can just jump
in from here with a knight to E5 you can
Pawn storm you know black has to be very
very careful and one of the things that
you really must avoid when you're
playing with the black piece is white
exploding open the Santa with D5 okay I
see with this move e70 I used to play
this variation and remember a game from
a US Junior championship against Michael
wrote but I put my Bishop on G4 and he
Hunted Me Down in an H3 G4 Knight E5 and
I actually put my Bishop back on G8
as David bronstein once did but Bishop
D2 I understand that what I want to do
is I want to play C6 as you were saying
White's ready to explode with the D5 and
I I don't want my queen to get trapped
by a knight D5 jump so I play C6
to B4 Bishop B4 that doesn't this
allowed just simple A3
thank you you're meant to wait until the
queen comes to E2 before you're doing it
yeah so so the whole point is uh is like
I don't want to allow this Knight to
jump maybe uh to D5 so Bishop B4 A3
sorry Kristen I was going to say no I I
love your A3 move just take on C3 you
take back with the bishop and you're
just going to enjoy this very stable
Advantage for the remainder of the game
yeah well let's Queen goes back to can
you not go back to B6 I think B6 if you
could play for Queenie ah you want to
take on C3
[Applause]
you guys get guys gonna make moves
this is too much greed I mean even for
me
okay
young lady it's my style
I'll give you the pleasure yes all right
Queenie two you you take on c yeah okay
let's figure okay now now I'm now you
got me scared I I have to try to allow
you to stay there too oh my goodness
okay how do we feel about this position
I don't know how do we feel
night too
okay uh
this one is very complicated but let's
look at the other games okay first of
all a true uh etusha versus Anna they're
still in some Theory but I like White's
position I must say a knight on E5 as
she's getting ready white is getting
ready to play F4 and in the words of
Larry Christensen storm the barricades
of of Black's King how about Sam
sevillan uh let me just uh quickly go to
that one as well oops I don't know if
I think I don't have it oh nope that's
not it
I apologize I'm not okay sure I have it
that game seems to be
in
and I do have an Indian there it is
right here
with the classical Queen C2 yes
and they're still in theory
very much so I must say and Ray Robson
versus Sam Shanklin
another one of these
well yeah it's a Choco piano with Knight
C3 Bishop G4
um
what's the
am I playing G4 here
what do you think
am I worried about the piece I should be
worried I mean I'm just having a look at
the theory and Theory says yeah
absolutely grab that pawn but
it feels kind of scary to me
um Jerry's out for me I'm not sure
what's going on here because I do have
King H2 and Rook G1 in my pocket as a as
a method for breaking this pin
um
wow okay
um Christian jump in if you don't mind
uh what's going on in this game uh
should white play G4 it does seem like
we are still in the troves of theory
right now G4 is one of the moves he did
not play that he played there should be
more Bishop to E3 which makes a lot of
sense because he's one of the main
topical moves what doesn't surprise me
is that Sam Shanklin is still within his
theoretical knowledge and Ray Robson is
not because he's spending and burning a
lot of time right down to his last 22
minutes while Sam has added extra time
to his clock he has almost 26 minutes
right now Bishop to E3 was played King
h8 immediately his response the idea is
pretty clear you get off this diagonal
this a2ga diagonal and what you try to
do is create your own counter Chances
with potentially Knight to G8 followed
by F5 that's an idea now we have this
pin set up on the H5 one diagonal why
not try to play for F5
yeah that's borrowing a page of the
Lavon arunian chess book but before we
get too deep into these elimination
games we have to take a quick commercial
break and but we'll see you in a few
minutes on the other side
[Music]
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program in the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grand Master
varusha nicobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve relationships between at-risk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since 2019 the St
Louis chess club has also created a
chess merit badge for the scouts VSA
quickly becoming one of the most popular
badges with more than 200 thousand
Scouts earning the badge since 2011.
students of chess can also pick up a
copy of read and write Jess thanks to
Club co-founder Dr Jeannie Karen
sinkfield anyone can learn how to
understand chess notation in no time we
view chess as a valuable educational
tool learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
[Music]
thank you
can you hear it
it's the sound of Hope
and health
and strength
it's the sound of compassion
of open doors
where people and machines are in tune
and miracles occur
[Music]
the sound of personalized Health Care
and active communities
it sounds like life and it's what you
hear when you really listen
listening to you caring for you we are
Ascension
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why Jess has
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the games the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
and we are back all for all the action
on day three of the American Cup
Bittersweet day because we're gonna say
goodbye to four players and meanwhile
there's a lot of exact excitement
happening in the championship bracket
but also the elimination bracket where
the players are playing the second game
of the foot match uh game the match has
got my immediate attention I must say is
the game of Alice Lee uh Naji just
played the move C5 C4 move that we
hadn't really been looking at ourselves
because we were kind of mesmerized by a
fight and it seems to us that uh Naji
has got a very promising looking
position we love this Knight on C5 we
love this bishop on G7 and well uh to my
eyes uh I'm looking at Knight D3 I'm
seeing a lot of threats and I think that
Alice Lee is actually in trouble and
that is something we haven't said very
often in this tournament no
yeah I agree with you I mean black has
the dream position you know the black
king sounds better than the white king
the black Bishop as you pointed out the
beautiful piece
um yeah we live for these kinds of
things in the night on C5 is hitting
A4 hitting D3 and hitting E4 uh all
those little sensitive uh places uh in
White's camp and
the bearing down on the B2 pawn bishop
on F4 doesn't look it doesn't work well
play I used to do so some issues here
for Alice in the game between Arena and
um
begum
I
didn't capture on A6 for some reason
oftentimes when you get into these types
of situations you you tend to be more
trusting of your opponent you see the
move A6 and you go okay I don't really
need that font and maybe because of that
uh begum has a little bit more
compensation she was forced to recapture
with the pawn isolated Queen Pawn uh
having said that as as you said
Christian the onus is still on black to
show compensation and maybe she doesn't
have any compensation no and especially
this move Bishop to G6 just doesn't feel
right uh that Bishop was doing fine on
that diagonal at least you cannot move
Knight with pony too right there's a pin
on that why would you waste another
Tempo and play the move Bishop to a G6
why not just finish your development
it's all about the king safety right now
if you want to create any sort of
problems for your opponent find that
compensation you'll need to finish your
development you cannot do all of those
things things with the king in the
center and this is what he's trying to
do it's not going to work out Bishop G6
followed by Bishop what if I just simply
go okay I under actually I don't
understand what if I go B3 exactly that
was my question too because the
desirable Rook V4 well that now now give
me another pocket right now I'm very
happy the queen is offside
uh he doesn't even take advantage of it
though yeah this is the problem I need
like three moves I need pressure to come
out
right from h8 yeah maybe create
something but there's nothing I mean it
just seems like yeah
wishful thinking wishful thinking this
situation
and uh in our other elimination uh group
uh in the champion of Pardon Me in the
open section uh Lavon is really feeling
it today I mean he is channeling his
inner Petrosian of exchange sacrifices
because uh the players raced more or
less to this position and after Bishop
takes Knight takes Bishop E7 in his mind
Sam was thinking I'm going to win an
exchange I provoke The Rook to the E8
Square so that when this Knight Retreats
which it did Bishop B5 uh-huh and
the one said you know in my judgment
that exchange sacrifice is really good
for me I love this imbalance I've got a
couple of Pawns or pardon me I've got
one Pawn these are double pawns still on
the board but I have light squares
and I'm the one doing very well after
this move C5 C4 is that true Christian
or actually you've got the other uh game
behind you uh I like I do have a
different game Devon's uh position of
course sure you sacrifice The Exchange
but let's not forget what the match
situation would be quiet yeah Sam
Sevilla needs to win this one that is
true to force to continue the match
right right if he makes a draw he's
eliminated not from the bracket but from
the tournament itself so his tournament
is over if he doesn't win this
particular matchup you want to see some
sort of imbalances in the position and
this is what he's getting right now sure
most likely Levon is doing just fine
without the exchange you have a lot of
compensation for it you have one Pawn
but uh two of them are connected right
now right b5a5 potential B4 if I manage
to get those pawns all the way to the
fourth rank then you're going to be in
big big trouble but at the same time
look I need change is an exchange
material is material and this one
finished in a draw I have to say Fabiano
pulled the brakes when he had to because
uh it was getting dangerous out there
for white
when we left it uh he did go for that uh
extra Pond did Wesley the queen trade
Rook C8 h2h I think we were looking at
this but you can't offer a draw
where what was the repetition try to
refresh your Bora perhaps yes okay that
might be our analysis ah I I think
you're right
I think you're right that is our
analysis so let's see because you can't
offer a draw right okay
takes takes
coming now
The Rook comes down
there it is they're professional that's
why I have this type of repetitions very
very nice right okay so an easy day at
the office for Wesley so uh a novelty I
still find this shocking uh on move nine
this move Bishop to D6 is it novelty it
was a force novelty it wasn't a prepared
novelty this was just Wesley trying to
get out of fabi's preparation okay and
finding some sort of a normal looking
move that's not going to lose on the
spot he found this move Bishop to D6 and
I mean look the gamble paid off because
he equalized after after that quite
easily and perhaps he was just even
better at one moment in time so
definitely an interesting one what's
happening in the Lanier versus yeah I
was gonna say you know I think Hikaru
has been working his in-game magic once
again and once again you know I mean he
he found this ingenious I think Retreat
of the bishop and started asking
questions of Black's Bishop on D3 I
really like that Bishop E2 and Bishop G4
idea I'm not a big fan of the bishop F5
move that linear essayed in the game
because it does allow this well I was
about to say Bishop H3 which came on the
next turn
but yeah
um I'm liking Hikaru here because I see
that I could play for example Rook A2 in
order to protect the square King here I
do want to capture this Knight and I do
want to put my king on F3 and in those
situations those double F pawns are a
weakness I will tickle them uh with a
king on F3 so I do feel that Hikaru is
for choice but again we've got these
elimination games going on and I'm just
very curious as to what's going on in
the game of Ray Robson and Sam Shanklin
because Sam
looks to me like he's under a great deal
of pressure
when we left it we we had seen this move
King h8 and this is like modern chess
this is kind of an old type of idea I've
seen it done before Oh yes this can you
trade Queen C8 yes I mean he would it
seemed like Sam was trying to prevent
this move G4 uh with the move Queen C8
and King h8 and all the rest of it and
this makes no sense to my eyes I know I
I'm sitting there saying I like what Ray
has done if I'm in white shoes right
here right now I'm Dreaming please don't
do anything don't don't make a move
don't disturb the position I want to
play F4 I want to bring my Rook to F1 or
maybe even double on the G file or
treble on the G file and what are your
pieces doing they're all huddled on the
king side Bishop G5 on the board
plate Bishop takes E3 immediately one
thing that Sam is doing Sam Shanklin is
doing correctly in this game is he's
putting a lot of pressure on race clock
right and we've seen Ray have a lot of
difficulties managing that clock so
that's one of the well let's say good
news about the position the position
itself not great for black so what you
want to say is that
Sam's excellent control of the clock not
necessarily the position
[Music]
the bad news is your Physician's not
that good the good news is you're you're
doing fine on the clock but the position
is solid enough right and that forces
you as white to work because you need to
find a way to break through right how
are you going to do it and I like this
move F6 I really like this move F6
you're going to play it for of course I
am most likely we're going to exchange
I'm not going to allow you to gain even
more space with the move F5 I want to
take that pawn as soon as it lands okay
and now finally I have the E5 Square for
my queen so let's transfer that Queen to
E5 okay where's the killing blow I just
have to The Killing broke low though I
mean all he has to do is just carry on
building you know just improve the Rooks
but you know what the problem is he's
spending one minute or two people every
single but this is the type of position
where once you've established what you
want you can just make some nonsense
moves like nonsense
you keep making right I've seen these
guys these grandmas don't be fooled you
know they get it they spend their time
and then suddenly they get themselves a
position where they can just go King G2
king of three kingy two can then before
you know it they've built up five
minutes on the clock and you're like
okay well I'm still worse yeah I don't
know this I feel like this is modern day
chat
I like what
um just to share a tweet I think it was
a real fun one I think all fathers in
our audience are going to appreciate
this one right Randy sinkfield the son
of rexingfield that's his son good
and he said to Logan as a very young boy
look if you ever beat me in a game of
chess I will give you one thousand
dollars all right one thousand dollars
and Randy thought his money is safe as
safe can be well
Randy is a proud father a little bit
lighter in the pocket as we've got a
picture of uh Logan
holding a thousand bucks
so be careful of what you tell your
children they're going to get motivated
if you say something like I'll give you
a thousand dollars if yeah and our
congratulations to Logan on his uh
Victory there yeah I was gonna say and
what what uh Randy has to now do is
change the goal post like my father did
because you know as soon as I started
beating him yes he was like okay I don't
like this very much so we had new rules
new rules new rules was that if I
blundered or made a mistake he would
just stop the clock and announce it as a
victory for himself
oh yeah I mean sometimes it was super
irritating because he'll stop the clock
I'm sorry you lost and I was like I miss
this and sometimes I would be like
sometimes it was true I had missed and
other times I was like it does not work
and then he would go oh my bad
oh my goodness oh my goodness and we
have a guest in studio uh with Christian
Wesley a rather tame and comfortable
there at the office but when he saw the
Catalan and uh you remembered what
happened to Rey yesterday were you a bit
worried at any point yeah and I thought
that he fabi's been hanging out also
with Gregory operand
uh so I figured I'd play something else
I thought he might go for D4 considering
that they're working together and uh
yeah I think we got an interesting game
uh thought we played this line very
quickly this bishop B13 he's following
uh uh cram next game also
um
uh Richard report against mvl from a few
months ago last year were you aware of
this idea of Bishop to B3 you were
trying to re remember yourself your
analysis or yeah I never expected this
to show up over the board like uh here
white wants to play quick E4 I mean I
could play Knight C6 but I didn't really
you know 936 Castle B5 then Queen e22
it's a completely different line yeah
but our adventure I mean Fabia some
ideas
but I thought this line was pretty
harmless if black knows what he's doing
with C5 early on B5 C5 and 684 yeah yeah
and and here the critical line I guess
it's Bishop B7 or Knight D7 but I wasn't
very familiar with Knight D7 so I
thought I played Bishop D6
is this something that you prepared at
home or you heard that it works or yeah
I prepared no I prepared after Castle
Bishop B7
so so I prepared with the white can
Castle we should be serving castle and
now Bishop is now Bishop D6 so this is
uh the usual Theory yeah but I guess
Bishop B7 Fabi had prepared E5 so I
thought I'd play Bishop D6 first huh D5
yeah bb7 E5
and it's very tricky like he told me
after game the after Bishop B7 E5 Knight
fd7
Bishop takes no not Castle apparently
97. yeah after Bishop E6 black cannot
take on E6 finally Knight E6 is just
much much better for white yeah although
it wasn't that clear to me during the
game but that's why I played Bishop D6
just to avoid all this and
and it did seem like this move surprised
him he made him pause
yeah it's not the more suggested by an
engines and modern Chef these days we
kind of have to as the one would say
play sometimes some Sidelines yeah yeah
because if they just keep following the
mainline clearpoint knows it very well
too but not partly it's a solid movement
were you worried about any any moves at
this point I think the engine was saying
Queen to E2 yeah Fabi was calculating we
need to for a long time that's the best
move Bishop to E5 but still it was very
complicated
seven ah and then castle castle Bishop
Bishop B7 Castle oh
this position
this position in your calculation yeah
looks playable for black
but I did I don't like so instead of
Castle move 13 and I guess Bishop A3
seems a bit dangerous yes yes definitely
dangerous so it's it's very tricky
amazing the pawn Castle you still have
to hide your king somehow not easy but
dangerous for both five yes at least I
win upon yes yes so but I got an
interesting game I think there's one
Bishop B7 I'm back to my preparation
one thing that he could have done maybe
was to take on E6 did you spot this one
yeah just remember it's harmless for
black women
Queen D6 yeah I wasn't sure Rook G8 or
Knight did this
um yeah I was going to play Rook G8
Queen E6
ah and then you go for an end game huh
oh heavy queen of five or queen it's
yeah
with deep engines it would end up in a
draw at this point yeah white get the
13. go for this now yeah it'll be
interesting too but I remember E1 was
what I like Bishop E5 and now Bishop B3
Bishop to E3 yeah Knight C6 takes takes
probably black is fine here oh although
it's slightly worse but what he play in
the game was interesting like this five
like I didn't expect this at all
night bd7 yeah it's probably nothing for
white now one and you defend it
accurately and in fact it felt like at
some point well it might even have been
better after Knight fd7 did you spot
this movie yeah try this move thinking
about this for a long time but then I
got really low on the clock and I was
thinking at what this move for 15 20
minutes and he decided to simplify the
position yeah decided not to because I
wasn't sure after Knight C3 Queen F6
yeah my first intention is why it's
ambitious Bishop g3965 Queen D6
like he did three have likes just much
better here
seems like it yeah but yeah if you don't
have the engine open it's not that easy
to assess this one yeah
maybe a move 17 Bishop E5
uh Knight takes I would like also better
okay yeah yeah I should have played
knife D7 but definitely not not easy too
for sure yeah I wasn't sure about better
or worse and decided to I looked at my
clock on the side that they just take
the pot Wesley you're you're doing it
all tomorrow with the white pieces are
you going to try to pressure take uh any
extra risks or are you okay with a
potential playoff
uh
uh well it's hard to say I mean I
just want to play some good chess you
know like
try to make use of my chances and become
you know that I put pressure if I can
but by the same time also it's still
very tired from my third birthday so
it's hard to say what the right decision
is
it's nice to play again so I'm a
defending Champion absolutely nice for
you but nice for us as well and for the
fans around the world we're definitely
enjoying this huge Clash we'll see you
tomorrow thank you uh Wesley because you
had such an easy day at the office I'm
going to have to put you to work for
just a second before we let you go
taking a look at the elimination bracket
game between Sam Sauvignon and levonne
aronium give us your quick uh need your
um
tell me who you like and why in this
game uh well I I don't like Sam because
he has to win but I think that he that
he has a very good position right I mean
it could be wrong but Bishop Jitter and
H5 is coming
um
maybe black of the plane Knight C5 I
guess and then Knight A4
okay I don't know it seems that white
has
why there's some chances not much but
definitely something to play so
especially in a must win situation yeah
probably yeah it's the best I can help
for I mean his time is okay
he's got the dark for control but Knight
C5
followed by Rook d8 or Knight A4 seems a
bit annoying to me so
uh it seems are you in time so Bishop to
G3
5 H5 oh he's black okay then that's
problematic yeah yeah Knight A4 King C2
maybe even Rook d8 to start off with
yeah
C3 Rook D3 is coming Rook d8
yeah now that I see this seems like
black is not risking anything
at all because also the epon is double
basically it just limits White's Bishop
yeah
all right thank you uh Wesley and good
luck tomorrow uh nice to have you in the
commentary Booth with us
absolutely uh Ray Robson uh Sam shankler
and uh Ray uh nobody's surprised to
discover he's got a whole four minutes
three and a half minutes and uh Sam at
some point I think I think he's on now
16 and a half minutes and you got to
give great credit he's the one pushing
his pawns you said you like pushing your
boss that's what he's done pushing e44
man just look at it it's a thing of
beauty four Pawn attacks you have to
actually yeah but there comes a stage
where you have to stop and crash through
somehow right yeah but I think you can
build for a long time or you can you can
do my favorites which is actually sit on
your space just enjoy everything it's
like you are in a chair you spread
yourself out and you make your opponent
just enjoy
and because they drew their first game a
victory by either player uh decides the
match and we have another great guest in
studio with Christian Fabi yesterday you
had the the dream Catalan in the last
game against Ray Robinson you try to
emulate that in today's game as well
explained to us this idea of Bishop to
B3 what were you aiming at
I actually am wondering what you mean
how how is this trying to emulate the
catalog yes The Bishop's on Beats sorry
I'm not on G2 no I had a small idea in
this game
um I was still a bit surprised that
Wesley went for the qga but not super
surprised he does play it from time to
time
and I had this very small idea which was
a based on a game grishu kremnik from
Kansas both Wesley and I played in 2018.
it was played near the end of the
tournament and so after Knight D4
kramnik played
or after B5 E4 cd494 kramnik played uh
Bishop B7 E5 Knight E4
and it's take take Castle is extremely
unposable position so
so it can easily get very dangerous for
black here yeah and Wesley played a move
which I am didn't wasn't familiar with I
mean I
I thought my bd7 is supposed to be the
best move
and but certainly Bishop D6 is not a bad
move it's just uh I wasn't sure exactly
what to do I thought
Queenie two here is very interesting for
example
yeah Bishop B5 Knight of I mean it turns
into a mess yeah it's very concrete it
could be very dangerous for black so
maybe I should have done this and then
Castle I really thought he would Castle
because I I thought that Bishop B7 would
allow Bishop takes E6 yes which it does
right yeah it does but then when I
started to calculate it take take Queen
E7
take take Queen D6 and like well Knights
I mean many moves Queen E7 is a move
going for that and give immediately for
example
um
or Rook G8 yeah Rook G8 I don't know if
I have like Queen E6 I think this was
some sort of a game played between Chaka
and Andrew Hong 2021. yeah Queen 26.
yeah I thought a lot better
queen of Five Night D7 Bishop G5 yep
uh was this the game oh I don't think so
no yeah at some point but I think Queen
E6 was still the game no G3 yeah G3 but
g39 C6 looked very
I didn't want to play G3 because now
yeah F3 F3 is a weakness yeah and
uh of course it's also super complex I
mean probably I should have gone for
this but I I really
um
didn't think that I would be better and
I was kind of attracted to this 95 idea
and then I realized
yeah empty idea
like okay if he if he gets very greedy
and takes on D4
Queen D4 ed585 King f8 doesn't Bishop
before and I'll have a lot of fun here
of course I I didn't didn't expect he
would do this but um
but I thought after 97 I kind of made a
very strange
and I had the hallucination I thought
like Bishop F4 would be strong
and then I I don't know why I thought
like he should take something but he
just castles in there and it's very
stupid for what
um because now finally the Knight is
under yeah yeah to be honest I was
getting a bit confused with all the
pieces hanging and then I realized 97
I'm probably slightly worse
uh I went for this bishop F4 which was
like an attempt just to try to end the
game but I was very worried about Knight
fd7 Knight C3 Queen F6 and it does seem
like the computer agrees with you
it's not easy to equalize with white
yeah I I was
rather pleasantly surprised when he
decided to simplify the position
yeah because here I thought I'm not
really like
yeah D4 works even I didn't think I
would ever be worse yeah of course also
impossible for what to be better here
um but yeah it really came down to
probably finding something after Bishop
T6 and or maybe going for this bishop
takes E6 and accepting a complete mess
but uh what I did was was definitely not
good
what do you expect from your opponent
tomorrow and what are you going to bring
to the table without revealing too much
of course well I expect him to try to
impress with white that's the
I mean he he's a rather solid player so
he can press in a way which doesn't take
extreme risks
that's sort of Wesley Style
um but I do have to be ready for both
possibilities that we go to a playoff or
that uh that we have a tough fight in
the classical game guys any questions a
quick one for you uh Fabi is uh for us
as we started our show and your
head-to-head matches with Wesley in
classical chess are you aware what your
score is
I assume it's tied it is it is it's um
it's not I I wasn't sure exactly but
it's not a big surprise four to four
with 26 draws
there's very little between you too yeah
yeah we have a very close score also I
think we've played a number of matches
and uh they've been very close matches
as well so we played like a bunch of
rabbit matches in 2020 the clutch chess
you're probably right
well
um and also those matches were tied one
to one so so we do have
a pretty tight record that's true and
yet at the same time when I think about
you both I think that you have very
different styles from one another but
somehow you match up incredibly closely
no I I agree that we definitely have
rather serious stylistic differences
but you know we we do also tend like
we're both quite good at calculation I
think that's that's the strength of
Wesley's for sure and probably also for
myself and usually if two players are
calculating
um rather than following intuition then
they tend to reach very similar
conclusions in the game so our stylistic
differences might be in terms of let's
say opening choice or
um in terms of some sort of decision
whether to you know play safely or go
for risks but in terms of our actual
chess it's probably pretty closely
matched so very good luck uh for you
tomorrow
uh just uh jumping into the game of
Arena Crush uh begum ended up the bishop
made an incredible tour of the board it
went Bishop to G4 to H5 to G6 to C2 and
took a knight yeah and she could have
just gone Bishop takes F3 uh you know
ages and ages ago yes and after Bishop
takes B3 it takes B3 whites upon up got
the two Bishops feels like a very nice
position for arena
um okay the isolated Queen Pawn some
little compensation but uh I I really
like White's position a lot I would
personally I'd probably just take on A6
and after you take on B3 I'll play
Bishop to C3 and bring my Bishop back to
C4 now and enjoy the extra uh Pawn Alice
Lee uh well uh do you think she's yeah
porn hasn't she she certainly has uh
Naji did uh she was the one uh with the
pawn yes I nah it's okay
um
but no uh where should I guess I have to
go to C3
is The Rook coming
down to C7 in this case it would most
certainly appear that way yeah right I
mean you've got ideas of Rook A7 and
well yeah it is time to foreign
Castle yes get out of Dodge get out of
Dodge get the Rook behind the bee
okay but can I try to make a draw by
just exchanging the Rooks and going
Bishop B6 early on uh sorry say that
again please just to go Rook C8 and then
Bishop B6 but you do have A4 at the end
of Rook C8 drinking goes out to D7 and
then trade-off works
with this A4 right there is A4 and if I
go Knight to C4 then my E4 Pawn is
hanging so yeah that's not good no and
we do have after night a similar idea
but why trade Rook says Alice uh Knight
C3 let's just tickled upon immediately
that's perhaps a very good point
it's a great Point actually
and in fact doesn't this
well I have to play A4 right
so yes otherwise I may be worse I mean
I'm thinking about Wesley losing his
Pawn on B4 and C5 yesterday but if I
lose both my bombs I'd be worse I at
least I should uh be willing to trade
one oh there's a check
hold it hold it hold it hold it
check work no I I guess I'm okay but you
can do this uh you can throw in the
check
before
like right here yeah right here also I'm
not sure you're okay in that position
check
so I've Alice would have at least a draw
in her pocket here with a prepat
so perhaps after a bishop to B6 let's
try to make some space for the king
let's try to go F5
all right good move and in general this
is a bishop very typical idea to soften
up the B5 Square
so you can get something like this that
at least in this case Alice has one
backer pawn and uh I wouldn't say well
okay maybe she is still a little bit
worse as uh White in this position I I
like the king 97. castles immediately
oh uh Naji did not play F5 okay she
castled immediately what do you think
she has in mind I think she probably has
this F5 idea that uh Christian was just
pointed out yeah you know
because
okay F5 uh
if I take the pawn I guess the same you
take on e4 you take on you
yeah all night takes and you probably
play Rook B8 yeah yeah
okay uh Chris Christian we can see you
getting excited what's going on I'm
definitely getting excited because uh
this one is definitely turning into a
huge uh combative battle the game
between Ray Robson and Sam Shanklin but
I have to say I do like as you guys were
mentioning as well race position I don't
like his time management but I do like
his position and it seems like his
position is in fact improving with each
and every passing move Rook to you on C5
C3 black is struggling to find some sort
of compensation for the fact that he
doesn't have any space in the position
this beautiful night on F5 controls
everything and potentially after the
opening of the G file this Pawn on G7 is
going to become a very tender Square for
a Black's position and right now we have
Rook to C8 A5 and E5 came on the board
well that's a blasting move in the
position you take I probably take how do
you continue right now you have to be
very careful if you do take I have a
feeling of the root takes C5 I'm just
simply breaking through right now you
probably have to go Queen to C4 Queen to
F6 Rook 28 is coming Rook to E7 is
coming and once again the cooperation
between the Knight on F5 very powerful
knight and a rook on the seventh rank
that's going to be deadly because of the
G7 Square so this one is not looking
good right now we have Rook to C4 on the
board by the way the engine is saying
this is completely dominating for white
I just simply Retreat Queen to G3 still
you have to worry about your time
1 minute and 45 seconds for Ray Robson
right now
almost eight minutes for Sam Shanklin
nevertheless his position is suffering
Sam Shanklin with the black PCS is
staring into the abyss right now because
if he loses this one he's out of the
tournament exactly yeah and talking
about tournament we do have to do a
quick checkup on the situations
everybody's yeah
and and in case you're just joining us
uh let's have a look at what the
situation is so so far in the Champions
bracket we see that there has been one
result Wednesday so and Fabiano Carona
they drew so that's tide so everything
will be decided decided tomorrow and uh
in the elimination bracket and in the
elimination bracket I mean they're
playing a much faster time control so it
will all be decided today and in the
first matchup between Psalm 7 and the
one aronian navon arono was the Victor
which leads Sam Sabian in a must win
situation
when we see Sam shankland and Ray Robson
you know Ray Robson he survived it was
seconds left on the clock he managed to
do a Herculean task and they're still
fighting it out in game two but uh Ray
Robson as Christian has indicated seems
to have the upper hand but once again
struggling with a clock and uh in the
women's section so yesterday we saw
Arena crash and took in Genova progress
to the Champions bracket they are still
very much playing that one game it seems
like Arena crash has the advantage there
and in the battle between Nazi pakiza
and Alice Lee again everything to play
for they will be playing just one
classical game today right and how are
the ladies doing in their own
limitations in the elimination bracket
it's almost like the same situation as
in the open we saw a very decisive game
between Tata abrahamian and Katarina
nemsava and this leaves nemsava in a
must-win situation with the black pieces
if she wants to remain in the
competition and in the battle between
Anna satonski and etusa percussion well
that finished in a draw in game one so
still very much everything to play for
so we could be seeing even more playoffs
or we can see everything decide guided
in the next game all right and that
brings us up to the current position and
I've got to tell you I just think that
Sam Shanklin is really in deep trouble
uh just looking at the board this visual
of look at this incredibly powerful
night versus this very passive night on
f8 the double Brooks along the open file
I wouldn't be surprised at all if some
kind of Knight E7 check and G5
might
do serious damage his only hope is the
time right now is the clock and what is
the time raised down to his last 30
seconds and he did play 97 check by the
way I I agree with you both I feel like
in a classical game this would be like
one nil probably maybe eight times out
of ten but here you know we're not so
much time the position has a wildness to
it that if sorry if Ray doesn't know
doesn't play it very accurately then of
course White's King is open that is true
and the position is already equal what
Oh you mean 97 was the wrong move 97 was
the wrong direction not only that but he
takes F6 was the wrong direction as well
right now after King 2 H7 black in fact
doesn't have that many problems anymore
so this was all ill-timed this move uh
that's the problem with living yourself
with only 30 seconds on the clock you
don't have time in the critical
positions to calculate everything
precisely
and one thing actually I don't know
maybe you guys can comment on this when
you don't have so much time on the clock
humans have a tendency to either
simplify because they can't you know
maintain the tension or just push pause
because they want to just go forward
would you guys go agree with that oh
yeah I think the generalization of what
you said is absolutely true uh when
you're when you feel the tension of the
clock you want to simplify you just you
just want the tension to stop and just
as you said so many times uh on the 40th
move you make that extra pawn move and I
will tell you what was missed right now
guys rupo F3 by the way is on the board
and if Black Sam Shanklin doesn't find
the right move he is completely busted
but he does have an incredible move Rook
taxis Queen to A6 say what
F4
get out yes
this is not humanly possible okay well
then we in my opinion this is not
humanly possible if he manages to find
this line of defense I mean shower him
with all the coins wow
Queen 86 and Rook F4 I'm sorry if you
find those moves
good for you that is that's not
happening and if he doesn't he's lost
and if he does he can look at his uh
his uh what do you call it the eye
demeanor no the eyes
wow wow Rook takes her faith and race
like what okay
seven good enough good enough good
enough yes oh my gosh seven equalizes as
well I thought you were leaving his only
moves
I can't believe it you missed out a key
story I thought it was an only move so
if I go Queen F3 defending my Rook now I
pick up the and then then I take a chat
that's fine G6 G6 because I was hoping
to trick you with queen and then I might
be able to do it since you haven't
exchange that is a good point so you
have to take only seven and then do the
same thing right and now I'm forced to
go G6 and now because of Rook h a check
in case of Queen to G6 guys rate three
seconds left on his clock what three
seconds he played this move with two
seconds Queen to E5 similar idea he's
setting himself up for a a queen to F5
check
um you have to take only seven right now
yeah you have to
let's see if he takes only seven or goes
Queen to F5 well I can't take the Rook
I have to play Queen F5 check he did
play G6 immediately and there is Rook E7
check now this is going to simply be
simplified Rook F7 you're pretty much
forced right now that was an
extraordinary find by by Sam Shanklin
that Queen A6 that was a very hidden
tactic Queen to waste wow you absolutely
have to actually take the repetition yes
F7 check and he found it in like 30
seconds yes I mean impressed are these
guys yeah you know but these guys this
is their bread and butter thing you know
they train on calculation they train on
these exercises day in day out and maybe
here Ray can actually try to nurture an
advantage no way no no no no no four
versus two versus two two versus two
queen and things you can plunk your
queen in the middle and then you know
come up with your king
okay well if you guys are confident it's
going to be a draw he's not even trying
I don't think he's can I can I please
can I move where would you like us to go
to Sam Seville and Levon oronia let's do
it
and if that Matt if that game is drawn
then they go to the faster Rapids or do
they go immediately to the blitz I go to
Foster Rapids 10 minutes plus five
seconds okay and we're uh okay let's
just uh wait for the end of this game
because we will see a move repetition
yeah and a shake of hands okay uh
jumping to the game of Sam sauvian Again
Sam is in that situation where you
cannot believe it look at him yeah how
did he find that Queen A6 Queen A6 look
at him sami's already gone right he's
counting His blessings right now he's
dead there
um I don't know but first impressions
are that Lavon is giving his opponent to
Sam sevillan every every opportunity
here
um yeah I I love what uh Savion has just
done with the bishop uh coming to F4
cover on E6
oh my gosh
don't take C6 Bishops move backwards
difficult
oh my gosh uh you're right Rook takes E6
which it did
eliminate you know I had it in mind that
the bishop is going to come to G5 the
pawn was going to go to ESO E7 the ABCs
of Chess and uh Bob's your uncle yeah
did
that's that's British isn't it it is
Barbara it's quite funny though because
not many people know my mother yes I
have a license to speak
uh Rook the C5 so an exchange up again
Sam must win to prolong the match to the
next two games uh Lavon just needs a
draw it's a time to push our h-bond push
our seats well wait one second there is
one big threat on the board Bishop who
can come to C7 threaten checkmate
Whoa by the way Anna zatansky and
is still at work let me bring that game
up yeah
just kind of blitzing out there in the
last 30 seconds went under our radar and
what do we have Anna is up a pond but
maybe on the worst side Rook H3 as white
as pre oh I was about to say white is
about to play G no I was G6 no
and uh here we see uh the game between
tative I catcher nemsava
these two are also under a minute but
remember she started with a win today so
all she needs is a drop it's like a race
yeah but this is but uh
mighty quick Bishop takes G7 yeah you
have to yeah or play H5 first that's an
option as well well I'm afraid if I play
H5 first then the Knight will come back
to F5 oh but then you can still take her
the bishop can actually prolong this uh
and by the way you don't even have to go
Bishop f8 you could have played H5 first
yes but you know when you're riding on
seconds it's sometimes better to be safe
than sorry that is very true okay so uh
Katya she needs a win
are we even thinking no of it is it like
is there I mean how is she gonna stop
the age porn from exactly pushing past
those Pawns
exactly this is a very typical example
of uh why the bishop is better when the
response on both sides right okay she's
going for that pawn so she wants to
capture on F4 so H5 takes takes takes on
F4 H6
age seven
get whoa okay pushing f 5
similar similar idea you know
not sure this does make sense but you're
not creating that past Pawn anymore
why start of shaking her head
um I think she should have just played
H5 right so take on F5 and this allows
her black to get her King yes into the
game with King D7 and King E6 yes a
moment ago there was a Pawn on E6 so
she's still got H5
no take on F5 now okay she's taking on
it this makes a lot of sense if you do
go King D7 I think I have E6 check
[Music]
and uh 16 seconds well King D7 E6 check
King E8 right that's an option yeah
it's going to go Knight to D4 but
what about this is an E6 really strong I
think it's sixes
what upon break through that that is
that's looking E6 is a beautiful visual
as Tata is looking at the clock
whoa and she might actually take
Katarina down in this game as well
this E6 was missing by five seconds for
kachka she needs to make a move two one
one okay
age six nine to F5 to H6 H5
there's no eight night on age I would
also go G7 and just
96. but H5
H5 kind of plays itself that finishes
the game yes it does
you're not in time you're not age six
will remain in the elimination bracket
whereas we will say goodbye to kacha
nemsava if she loses again Knight takes
born but okay there's no way those two
those pawns are actually going to defeat
the bishop Bishop Jack and Bishop F6 and
I think The Bishop's going to defeat the
king
that's that's the killer move and uh the
pawns are completely arrested and King
will come up congratulations to Tata
let's just jump quickly to etusha and
Anna and we see a handshake there
remains in the competition yes she does
moves on in the elimination bracket Rook
to A8
um
I believe this is the first eliminated
player
in the American Cup yeah Catherine and
so on we thought it would be Sam
Shanklin but he is
six man Queen A6 was a remarkable find
truly
um I'm not sure what's going on in Anna
satonski's game uh I've just seen this
move Rook to G6 back to G4 what's your
quick take on this one Jovi would you
like to play white with
yeah any day the pawn on H7 is kind of
stuck right yeah
the bishop is like looking at the A4
Pawn also those yes you can grab a pawn
but you know whites works are active
um
I'm thinking I've got a little bit my
own place so we'll do the pawn on H7 but
the problem is if you do leave the H
file with the Rook you're going to get
almost checked well for starters for
starters you can go Rook G8 I mean
yes I agree with you there uh let me
just refresh my board for just a quick
moment apologies
because they're down to their last 30
seconds yeah after Rook 96 Rook H5 she
didn't she missed Rook G8 I think uh
that Rook G8 move
well actually what am I saying let me
correct myself why it is still for
Choice here no question about it Anna
zutanski in trouble
big trouble right now and down to her
last 20 seconds
and now it's down to 10.
and moving the night to G4 she's trying
to get Knight to E4 that's the right
direction that's a good move
but am I not allowing Rook on F6 to H6
that's probably a very good response yes
I'm I'm very worried about the Rook
sneaking in and skewering she might want
to defend him she's done it with Knight
H7 but that's so passive
it's very stressful very passive as well
because you know the black's position is
just Lee creaking I have to say you know
the Rook is going to come to up to H5
every five seconds
of seven
she's done King F7 good move
uh sidestepping that nasty little tactic
But Here Comes Rook C6
and 6
seconds for Tuesday and she gives a
check
and by the way uh Lavon is also
just about to finish his match against
Sam Seville yeah
Rook F2 she goes back King F7 I like
that move Rook C6
uh
had it for a repetition I don't I think
so there we go Rook C6 playing for the
win 94. okay at least I'm hitting that
Bishop
that's a good point you are hitting the
bishop
and it is a good night on e4 despite the
fact that it doesn't have a strong
Outpost right still you need a few moves
to Target it
and in the meantime
[Laughter]
listen I was the U.S women's team
captain every time Anna zatoski sat down
to play I was nervous you know because I
thought there was going to be a time
trouble
yeah and uh and and as we see the
players we can see that the game is
finished it was a draw which means that
Lavon aronian remains in the competition
and Sam Sevin playing with the white
pieces sadly leaves the competition
absolutely we did have uh oh Hannah is
setting up some kind of a cheaper with
Knight C3 yeah but can you take on A5
she did it we have two children
Bishop takes C3 and that's it that's it
two pawns up that's going to be an easy
win for our team and she's done it Rook
f2j Anna was Anna was hoping to escape
with a Perpetual check based upon
Russell she missed Rook F2 and that's it
what a heartbreak for anastasi in this
one
I must say it too she took that night
with joy in her heart
oh my that was uh
that was a definitely uh quickly
captured
I love rocking this was a tense
so some ideas of playing Rook to day
seven I think it's just gonna hide
itself back behind its two extra points
two extra funds yes that's exactly what
she's doing yeah I'll just give a check
or push on D7 let's go I think it's time
for A5 I like the idea of checks
maximize the position okay good point
and you go Rook eight seven or Rook H7
anyway C7
forcing you to defend that C5 pawn and
then just running down the board
Rook on D7 to C7 Rook to G5 A5 and as
you say just run the pawn
Basics now there's a Checkmate sighting
in the air in the Roku C8 you have to
Define defense and stuff gosh what's
terrible to be down two pawns and facing
Checkmate yeah I mean that's well that's
not fun I can add an extra element of
Despair I'm gonna get eliminated from
the tournament as well
to A6 isn't that a close to check mate
yes yes there's just no way and there
you can see the despair on Anna's face
who knows she is out there's no way back
there's no saving this position
is going to follow up that forces
resignation for sure
and she plays it and there you have it
our congratulations to a two Chef for
eliminating many time my U.S Champion
Anna zatonski in the elimination bracket
um we have one eliminate we we have
three players eliminated and one playoff
going on yeah one playoff that will be
between Ray Robson and Sam Shanklin so
they will now play another rapid format
of 10 minutes plus five seconds two
games we still have a classical game
my I've been holding my breath for a
while here in the ladies yeah I'm just
turning our attention to Alice Lee uh
versus Naji this looks like a very
balanced game I will uh I mean it's okay
it's early to call it a draw but I would
suspect after but this is another
position that's not the position oh
sorry I've got the wrong position oh
you're right
oh
whoa it looks like uh wives of white
better
I don't know oh my gosh uh the bee Pawn
instead of being a weakness became a
strength
my goodness
when we left it
oh oh
a lot of strange things occurred here
takes and this move at the end Rook E1
and this bishop ending is definitely
better for white good move by Alice G4
and in the meantime let's
let's elimination bracket because we can
see there have been some decisive
results we saw Tata convincingly beaten
them two nil and she goes through to the
next round whereas we also say goodbye
to Anna satonsky because after our first
game draw it was a critical Victory a
clutch win in atusa percussion
we do have one decided games because
Lavon aronian again quite convincing
what he needs to be right defeated Psalm
7 to remain in the competition but still
one game one match left to be decided
that's between Sam Shanklin and Ray
Robson they are moving on to the
playoffs yes and in the meantime we do
have a guest in the studio with
Christian
father first of all congratulations a
difficult match against Irina but you
bounce back immediately with a crucial
Victory against nemesova how did you
approach today's match
uh I feel like this match was very
similar to last year
okay I also played Katrina last year and
I was under a lot of pressure in the
first game it's very hard to predict
what she will do she plays kind of
systems she doesn't really play a lot of
theoretical stuff so I reviewed a lot of
things not the one that she played in
the first game I my position was quite
tough but then
when things got messy I think I got the
upper hand and second game I was again
getting out played which is what exactly
what happened last year that I won the
first game second game I was getting out
played but were you getting any
flashbacks from yeah yeah when I was
playing it it was like all come back to
him because it was also like usually
position like again like I had a pun
breakthrough and then one of my pawns uh
Queens so it was like exactly the same
thing but they both worked it out it was
good at what point did you feel like you
can breathe a sight of relief in the
final game
um yeah I'm in here
I mean I feel like I don't know it's
just I feel like here I'm just getting
out played somehow
it's still a very powerful night more of
a closed semi-close Center but go to a
position and then
making you turn then I realized she was
93 or Knight F4 even so I'm just walking
into the tactics I'm like okay then I
wanted to go H4 something yeah it is you
have
93.4 yeah it just wins the exchange or
the queen and I wanted to go age four
but then H4 like takes away this some
queen d8 queen H4 Perpetual ideas so
that's the thing when you have this idea
that you want to play with for a draw it
just kind of influences how you play but
maybe H4 is more of a normal move at
some point I can go H5 like if she goes
King f8 then I have H5 Queen H7 maybe
something
yeah get some counterfeit because
otherwise I just don't know what to move
because my queen side is still under so
much pressure at the same time playing
the move H4 weakens your position a
little bit and it's difficult to make
with so little time on the clock you
play the H3 and you entered this uh end
game
yeah I think were you feeling safe at
this point no still not safe
um
yeah because she has a knight and we
have no time and it's so tricky with
nights yeah yeah okay once I went to
five I thought I was okay and then and
then I realized oh she's just like
that's what she did but then I was like
oh the G7 plus some you know this carol
conversations where you get the
structure and I was like okay I didn't
even calculate I was like it just has to
work out for me somehow this H Pawn is
going to run down the board
part of congratulations uh tomorrow uh
you know who you're going to face or I
thought I'm not playing tomorrow not
playing you're getting arrested
a well-deserved rest day for you guys
any questions for our Victor our
congratulations start to have good luck
in your next elimination match thank you
wow
um cool well I I we we've kind of lost
uh track of the game for a bit but the
Hikaru Nakamura versus Lanier game
somehow Hikaru had won a pawn uh he had
doubled up the f-pawns Lanier played F4
but then
undoubled uh uh the hikaru's pawns and
basically Lanier is saying look I'm a
pawn down in this King this uh Rook
ending but I've got a fortress is he
right well you know he is a pawn dial
but take a look at White's extra porn
it's on it's on G3 and to be honest you
know as long as you keep a small eye on
it and I'd say small in the very loose
sense like you don't go wandering around
with a king all the way over to the
queen side yeah I mean
so for example after rookie two you're
trading you're trading and you're just
waiting yeah then I'm just gonna wait
because G4 is not going to be a threat
and C4 you're you're waiting for the
pawn to get to see yeah exactly that's
my claim okay and uh that is my claim
and in the meanwhile we do have a guest
in the studio alongside Christian
yesterday's match didn't go your way but
still it feels like you're always
enjoying yourself whenever you play this
rapid faster time controls especially
this particular moment I want to drag
your attention to when you decide to
sacrifice The Exchange quite easily
quickly
yeah I'm honestly enjoying playing chess
a lot lately so it's a
I mean it's type of thing that uh you
really want to do when you're getting
such a bishop on H4 uh
it's uh difficult to explain for
non-chess players but it's one of those
feelings that you know you feel the
Harmony and everything is just going
your way and
that that kind of worked for me would
you say this was the critical uh moment
in this particular match
so sure I think there are many critical
moments let's keep going later I think
uh I I misplayed it of course I I saw
Rook F6 I should have played Rook F6
yes I actually plundered this idea with
H4 which was uh very very good very fast
played in the game yeah yeah great idea
and then I thought okay let's just play
safe and here after G3 I thought black
has enough counter play I was thinking
that I'm still better after D4
it's just in in this in this time format
it's so much easier to play with white
because the weekend yeah in the worst
case scenario I always have this C4
Bishop to C3 and individuals yeah yeah
lots of perpetuals yeah you're never
going to be in danger to actually lose
this position which is but after H3 uh
which was I thought uh a positional
mistake things are very easy yeah Bishop
to G3 now finally your Bishop found a
very safe and defensive uh placement as
well as well as offensive because you
played before yeah with a lot of
pressure in the center like this you're
feeling pretty comfortable at this point
yeah I think this was the critical
moment actually this H3 H3 was the big
mistake yeah yeah yeah and after that
you executed quite nicely but I have to
say
the second match the second game was not
easy at all right yeah I think I mixed
up some moves I think on the eighth move
I'm supposed to play H6 before D5 the 45
H6 and what is the difference
well it's kind of a Tempo yeah I think
uh
yes here he hit Sydney Bishop D5 Knight
F3 97.
uh
yeah Knight E5 I think this is so much
much better version than what I've got
also there is this G5 here I think which
is also totally fine for black yes and
only after he played 95 I realized so
maybe I forgot the player six without
this and now if you play H6 the problem
is Knight to D7 is coming in that's just
a very bad situation after take so I
kind of had to go to this end game which
of course it's not very enjoyable to
play at least there's a b plan right
at least there's a B flat Bishop to E7
you are defending against the two
Bishops but he found this
exchange sacrifice I have to do it you
have to do it yeah yeah
and did you feel like he was fighting on
the pressure did you feel him oh yeah
but but you know it's also a type of a
position that is not so easy to play
with white because
you're especially when when it's a must
win situation
yeah you you have to really pay
attention
pay attention not too loud like to get a
fortress and it didn't seem like at any
point he got like any sort of
but here he was he was doing very well I
think yes H5 yeah
yeah rukish one was not the move yeah I
thought the bishop H4 I also thought
about this
and then kind of Rook G7 and undermining
because the F7 Pawn
I think Sam forgot that I have this
counter play with Rook V8
of The Rook to G7 Rook to d8 and our
Knight goes back to C5 yeah
interest and that makes a lot of sense
and he had to defend with Rook to D1 but
that allows it yeah I'm not sure what
happened later but it seemed that I I
was always in control someone else yes
yes except at this point where I
actually forgot
that he can just retreat with the bishop
ooh it doesn't seem like he did have
this move yeah yeah here I was a bit
worried yeah I hear I was a bit worried
and the idea being that he just wants to
push the pawn E6 Bishop to D6 yeah I
think after so after uh where did I make
the mistake on move number 41 or
um King to A4 was the mistake you had to
play Knight to B4 yeah I thought about
this yeah night before I was I was
actually afraid of some rookie
932 and you know kind of take and then
E6 yeah and this is winning ah but uh
after okay they don't have to uh I can
just create the kind of play with F7 and
Rook F3 yeah you have to yeah this is
this I somehow didn't believe so much
and because I was already it's gonna
become a race are you getting to this
king or is he promoting his Pawn right
yeah I was a bit scared that he'll give
this check Rook C8 you know it's a rook
F7 check can get for Rook C8 yeah
and the only movies it's not easy I mean
only a few seconds on the clock that's
pretty much impossible it can be five
with Knight C6 ideas definitely I mean
it's easy to see but it's not easy to
assess yeah yeah yeah but still not easy
for him to finish the game either and
find the best precise move to get the
advantage which he didn't you managed to
equalize Levon congratulations so uh
tomorrow you have a rest day what are
you going to do are you going to enjoy
it spend it with your family what are
you going to do well it's a
well-deserved dressed
yesterday's display
uh I mean in the rapid section of course
uh
I think uh I'll I'll just go to the park
probably you know apparently the weather
is going to get better because it's
super freezing last couple of days yeah
so this this is what I can do go and
have a little exercise get some sunshine
get some vitamin D guys any questions
quick question for you
um uh Lavon who who is your future
opponent
um what I think
probably whoever loses between Hikaru
and Dominguez the system is so
complicated I don't even know who I'm
playing
because I was just I was just curious if
you would play linear a rematch
potentially it does seem to be the case
yes that you could potentially place but
which is
no linear right now is most likely going
to be a draw so there is yeah but I'm
just saying that there was that
possibility that uh that was what I said
so I don't get to play more rapid what's
going on oh yeah yeah
if you if you end up in the finals oh
like like a year ago yes oh my God this
is so beautiful you're only going to
play rabbit from now so happy
very nice okay good luck and enjoy the
cold weather brisk yes weather yes and
let's check out where Lavon actually
stands and the whole brackets I mean I
think he he won he won he won but he
still with elimination yeah he's waiting
for an opponent to drop from the heavens
right and into the elimination bracket
and for uh Sam Shanklin and Ray Robson
they still have a Playoff round to go
that will be starting at 5 30 by the way
for those of you
looking forward to that match as we
certainly are and we do feel that the
game between Lanier and
um
is going to be a dead draw as king just
kings are gonna dance right I think the
players or we can just see Hikaru is
getting ready to count the three move
repetition indeed
no no but okay the main point in this
whole position is that black has to be
ready to meet King B4 with King C6 so
you don't want to play King C6 and allow
King B4 hey so you can go King D6 King
C7 and just wait uh and uh draw is uh
inevitable yep
and uh whilst these players are going to
finish any time now we do have a guest
with Christian in the studio we are
indeed with atusa percussion atusa first
of all welcome to the St Louis chess
club this is the first time that you are
playing here at the St Louis jazz club
tell us how do you enjoy the atmosphere
yes thank
you first time
never been to San Luis even though I'm
in the states for a long time so it was
kind of strange and uh uh yeah it's
really nice here I heard a lot of good
things about the club so when I came
here it was really beautiful the venue
and also the big the giant king I really
love that
so yeah everything is great here and one
thing about this tournament a lot of
these players have played against each
other but they haven't played against
you did you feel like that will give you
an advantage going into this event
I think it's okay because I mean I've
been playing chess since I was eight
years old and my games are in databases
and I used to play in Olympia's menu
olympiads so we might have you know
played in international tournaments
uh and actually it was kind of difficult
for me the first day here because I
didn't know the environment and uh it
just kind of uh
happened so quickly especially with the
time control but I think now I'm more or
less adjusting to the environment
definitely felt like you adjusted well
and a big game and a big match between
yourself and Anna zatonski tell us about
this last game assess it for us explain
it to us
yeah I mean uh and I was playing very
well and I couldn't get anything out of
the opening so I thought okay I'm gonna
go to this kind of end game which is a
little bit better for me although the
bishop was not that great because of the
pawn structures
so I just came up with this idea G4
because uh if I don't play G4 then it's
kind of hard to break through so I
thought that I need to get my pawns so
you just want to take more space yes
because the point is I want to play
because she's gonna put the Knight on E6
and I need to kind of play f45 to attack
the Knight if I want to penetrate to the
seventh Rank and so on so and that
seemed like a very very good plan uh
Rook 2 D7 she managed to defend the
seventh rank but now you're getting
ready to double up and reinforce the
threat of getting on the seventh rank H4
take as much space as possible
where did you feel like you're taking
control of this game
I mean at this point I knew that I'm
better but it's kind of tricky
especially in this time control
uh just one move it can just
go the other way so I was
just be careful that I needed to be
careful to not miss a move or something
like that I mean the Knight and E8 was
passive and this idea b3a4 I really
liked because uh cement the weakness on
a fire very nice yeah very good
strategical point and G5 and now you're
going to focus on the H7 weakness
and at this point it just felt like her
King was so weak right here yeah this
group swarming around her King this Rook
was tight defense of the Pawn on A5 you
are enjoying your position
I mean yes I was better but I was just
playing you
know each time 23 seconds and 50 years
that was kind of stressful I knew that
I'm better but I needed to find a way to
get through and you did indeed find that
way you took that pawn and this is what
you missed this Intermezzo check on F2
after that you took on C3 two pawns up
and you delivered the full and you took
the full point after that atusa
congratulations a big matchup for you
tomorrow you have a rest day how are you
going to enjoy your wrestling uh I think
I'm gonna go outside and see the city a
little bit yes
and it's nice to have a rest day in jazz
tournament so yeah guys any questions uh
our congratulations satucha big St Louis
welcome for you
thank you very much I appreciate it oh
absolutely uh we've got uh well first of
all to refresh our brackets yeah and we
can see the standings in the elimination
bracket we've said goodbye to Anna
satonski after atusa's nice fourth the
second game as well as Katya also
yeah and we've had to say goodbyes and
lyrics to these two players I mean
that's very with both tatif and Tusa are
waiting for their opponents which will
be The Losers of this next of the
bracket the Championships brackets and
uh yeah interesting I have this uh game
going on uh very intriguing end game
Queen and Knight versus queen and Bishop
extra Pawn for arena still but I must
say begum has really fought well uh her
way back into this game it was one of
those games where it felt like she had
no compensation whatsoever some time ago
and she's got
which I think was a key move not to lose
the pawn on uh B4 and E4 but what if I
just can like what's your plan with the
black pieces what if I continue pushing
the people I guess it's I guess I have
to wait like something like jeez let's
say I go perhaps you have check on A1
and on E5 and that's why she played E5
E4 right yeah right okay yeah that's
that's something that is that is
something but I mean so the point is B5
let's put it on the board Jack King here
and against check you're you're very
reluctant to play G3
yes but okay but I mean how dangerous is
it if you just go whatever
I'm allowing it you're allowing it yeah
because my the whole reasoning is that
after night if three check or whatever
King goes to G2 I can't go Queen A1 and
allow Queen takes right C4 so what do we
play as white right now do we go Queen
to E1 to try to defend the first rank
even though I was quite Brash
um yeah I want to move that I kind of
did spring to mind was Queen to E3 Queen
to E3 yes oh that makes a lot of sense
trade queens and the point also is that
after check my Bishop is defending F1 so
I don't have a knight F1 getting me from
behind but I also have queenify Queen G3
as a way of
what just like dislodging the queen and
the Knight really so yeah Queen E5 Queen
G3 right I mean after all that Bishop on
C4 is hitting F7 so that I do have ideas
of check and
dare I say it winning upon
we have a guest with Christian then
you're a difficult match against Hikaru
Nakamura in a difficult game today did
you expect him to transition early on
into this type of end game and try to
pile on the pressure in this type of
situations uh yeah I mean I I thought
it's possible that he placed this line I
mean he played it before but I thought
it's such a solid line that I shouldn't
have too many problems in fact I think I
got a good position
um I I played this line again so I share
in in Romania last year in the ground
but yeah overall it's a very solid
position I think I was doing quite quite
okay until the moment when I play
yeah all this looks fine in Rook d8 but
here I missed that yeah I thought I was
just a few moves back when I took on E3
93 of course my plan was to yeah take on
E3 take on E3 I thought knight uh Bishop
B4 of course but then I I saw Bishop E4
got it yeah and because if yeah if if
takes or we should do one then I'm fine
but but Knight C4 suddenly oh it creates
some unbalance in the position because I
have to play Bishop C7 or uh Bishop
takes E4 Pawn takes and I didn't want to
allow this like I wanted to keep the
structure to symmetry I thought it's
more safe but then I was hesitating
between a few different moves and
finally I just got worse uh yeah Rook D1
Bishop F5 I think it's it's a bad
decision actually two supposedly was the
better B should be two Rook D2 I was
thinking about it before yeah takes
takes and Rook C2 I wasn't sure
I mean of course I have yeah two Bishops
and maybe white can play B3 C4
immediately C4 at some point but it's a
similar situation to to the one we got
in the game because yeah take stakes and
before yeah I wasn't maybe before is
interesting I was expecting something
along the lines of B3 and C4 or maybe A5
first and then B3 C4
um and I thought it's quite quite
unpleasant for black here so I didn't
like my position at all
um
but uh yeah before actually giving his
Bishop error with Bishop yeah because um
I want to play Knight D6 now so if B5 I
think not 96 but takes on B5 a B96 and
maybe I'm kind of holding Aya with 94
and born on B5 this week on C3 and so on
so yeah I mean but overall I was happy
to see Bishop takes at five and and
because then I and you found this nice
movement yeah so like in the game with
levonne I'm playing against this double
F pawns uh this time two or three but
yeah I think this is pretty pretty dead
here because once you close the position
it's very difficult for white to open
yeah on the queen side yeah a difficult
uh game uh difficult match tomorrow you
will be having the white pieces what is
the general strategy yeah well it's uh
better situation than than the one today
so at least I have one game with white
I'll of course
um try to to press
um and and see what happens guys any
questions for a year good luck tomorrow
uh linear
yeah this is like that pause afterwards
it's somehow weird yeah of course I was
thinking about thank you very much
[Music]
and and here is now you know how it
feels to be rejected rejected yeah the
Crickets and champions bracket and we
can see the scores that it is very much
Even Stevens between picar and Nakamura
and linear Dominguez as well as in a
match between Wesley so and Fabiana
caruana that means that everything will
be decided tomorrow if the match is tied
then it will go on to playoffs tomorrow
and uh whilst we catch our breath we're
going to perhaps take a break exactly
for those of you at 5 30 uh the playoff
game between Ray Robson and Sam is
coming up but we'll see you on the other
side of this break
[Music]
we're the Corey family Welcome to our
show
[Music]
you guys gonna see this
that's our show now go start yours
[Music]
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the world-class St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
we all know St Louis is a championship
Sports Town from the 11-time world
champion Cardinals to the Stanley Cup
champion Blues
but I bet you didn't know about all the
championship places there are to get out
and play here like the World Chess Hall
of Fame Westport social and Topgolf and
now even our own MLS team so whatever
Sports your team is into you can always
bring out your A game in St Louis
oops sorry St Lou is always exploring
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
we are back with day three of all the
action in the American Cup and as we can
see there are two championship games in
operation and we just going to see the
closing moments I think of one of those
games indeed it looked like Arena Crush
was completely winning as we came back
on air she's about to clean upon
certainly was and I think we're gonna
see this last decisive moments and she
is facing off against torque John irvo
Donovan
and she she was playing a very
impressive game yeah
the march of the bee Pawn actually as uh
Arenas uh beep on just kind of went all
the way up the board Alice Lee on the uh
on the other hand she is in a Bishop's
ending
for some time she's been better but I
don't think
she's really
has chances of winning uh as it's kind
of like one of these standoff game black
has her pass Pawn on the D file but she
doesn't want to push it prematurely a
move like for example uh D4 would allow
Alice to play King E4 so you don't want
to give up the square she's played the
move Bishop F2 and
my question I guess I I want to ask is
am I taking too great a risk if I play
the move King G5 well King G5 I can just
throw you away with Bishop B3
oh just so you know I was thinking you
were going to match me this way or you
were going to play for D4 but Bishop E3
check does uh
to stop me from playing King H6 doesn't
it yes it does it does but okay you can
hold this idea for a tiny moment you
know maybe bishop F1
by the way Bishop Alice only has 25
seconds on her clock oh she does so
definitely some tension right now he's
exhibiting some nervousness
[Music]
seconds
hovering down to her last 10 seconds in
case she drops the king back to attack
the bishop King F3
we do have to say though that they are
getting an increment of 30 seconds per
move and the nice nudge to the king I
was about to say I I liked a little
flick as a professional player it's sort
of like you're you you're intimating
excuse me you could put the peace
centralized oh and Alice quickly plays
uh King okay
let's repeat the position right three
times and I suspect you know something
she's gonna make she's going to make her
attempt now because
if she lets the clock tick down I think
instinctively she'll just go okay fine
whatever but I don't think there's any
reason to force matters because okay can
she say B5 sure and
and but how are you going to continue
after that uh somehow I want to play B5
and Bishop to D4 as white
that's a good dream you you have yes sir
okay so you know King F B5 King F3 King
E2 King D3
or is it two way too slow
okay I think we've seen this actually uh
during our break I saw that the there
was a king on F7
yeah a time ago you know I have you kind
of mentioned that that we saw this
position or perhaps I've seen something
similar but uh since
since the games all broadcast online
yeah I mean can't be Arbiters like step
in when you've repeated the position
three times I I believe that the without
you you have the Rapids they they step
in on the fifth repetition that's
correct
um otherwise you can definitely say to
the Arbiter hey I'm claiming a
three-time repetition and if your claim
is upheld you got the draw if it's not
your opponent gets a few extra minutes
and you don't feel like it's it was uh
you have to ask for it yes H6 putting
the pawn on a dark Square means you can
never crawl to the H6 Square anymore and
I think that has made uh naji's life a
lot easier she has a clash
that's clever
but okay I mean you can play Bishop E1
threading Bishop D2
and uh the black king will take care is
close is close enough yeah by the way
isn't just Bishop to E1 and Bishop takes
b40 if I manage to sacrifice the bishop
for a pawn isn't that just a drop yes
yeah you can get your king the h a no or
to G8 I just stay on G8 and I think
that's a draw yeah it's a fortress
King J King F7 and that's it
it's saying Fortress that's
that
yeah it's a similar uh position as the
one I believe Sam Shanklin resigned
against
yes
yeah and it was a drug
Bishop C5 most likely we're going to see
on the board right it's the only way to
try for something well if you go Bishop
C5 and I take it then you go King D7
what do you do
King he's five also you can take and
play D4 I think that just finishes the
game I was keeping an eye G4 and D3 yeah
that that's the simplest that's that's
yeah Bishop C5 yeah let me just uh sorry
I'm just going to refresh my board
quickly and what we're talking about is
Bishop takes Pawn takes
D4
King E4 D3 yeah takes King and uh
and then the black king will chase the
white king
and prevent it from getting
to the golden squares right
um yeah Bishop takes C5 and D4 al-naji
taking a pause
good just making sure yeah very
professional double checking
and I was just checking the time because
we are soon going to be heading to the
elimination playoffs
and everything to play for is they are
will play playing two accelerated rapid
games
um each both players who have the black
and white pieces as one of them will be
eliminated yeah
and uh just to kind of remind ourselves
if the match is drawn even after these
accelerated rapid games it then goes to
Blitz playoffs three minutes and then
finally if there's nothing separating
them then we're gonna see absolutely
Armageddon
and uh you guys really are calling it
Naji
did everything right D3 thing takes born
and
Alice
who actually won two games here
previously yep drops her first half
points exactly
Arena by the way
3-0 Yeah clean slate wow very very
impressive
and um
Morrow Naji will have
thoughts we sort of play a very
beautiful impressive game against Anna
zatonski the decider and yeah match with
Anna in the first round yeah who do you
think will be
feeling
more comfortable
well I would say definitely definitely
Naji because
when Alice laid down a 2-0 mark
you know that's rather frightening and
what you said her her rating performance
was at 28.50 for that second game that's
like wow so you can get you you can
really frighten yourself you build up
your opponent it's um yeah terrible
you're going to see a handshake yeah
okay have a greater drawer and indeed
they'll come tomorrow with everything to
play for uh begum will have to win
and we can remind ourselves of the
Women's Championship bracket as we see
Arena crash taking an early lead against
begum talking to Genova and also
neutralizing honestly and I think a very
well-fought game absolutely
and we have guest arena with Christian
Arena almost flashbacks from last year
this matchup between yourself and uh beg
him you start off with the white pieces
you get an early Advantage out of the
opening what surprised you at the
beginning yeah well I mean everything
surprised me I certainly didn't know
what um what was the evaluation of the
position
um you know her choice of Bishop G4
Queen's Gambit accepted was not
something
um that came to my mind and
um you know it's funny because I I tried
this line myself maybe a few times in my
life and most recently against hampi
conero a few years ago and so I know
that if white doesn't play very
aggressively like black can count an
equality in this line so I just came up
with this move Queen B3
um you know not because I knew anything
here like how this would go but just I
mean I knew it should be like a testing
move
um but I thought she had a lot of
compensation for the pond and it does
seem like Bishop takes F3 first and
perhaps this is what she messed up about
her position Bishop takes F3 and then
Knight to D7 is the main line yeah well
you know there's if you don't have any
computer analysis it's very hard to wait
like through this position like I had no
idea what was going on for probably like
15 moves do you feel she still knew what
she's doing at this point I felt like
maybe Queen B3 surprised her a bit you
know I think she knew this Knight D7
idea but like you know her real thinking
was after Queen B7 like I was actually
thinking like if she goes rugby eight
instead
um can I just take the second Pawn I was
gonna take it you know I was like well I
don't know why it's losing so you know I
was probably gonna take it and there
were so many times in this game where I
could have taken a pawn and it was like
some difficult decisions in that way and
I think that was one of the moments
after c592 and now Rook to B8 you could
have still 28 was what I didn't like
here because Queen C8 and okay
interesting so I can escape the album
Queen A6 that seemed yeah you know what
I think that move I didn't really and if
she goes to da then you have Queen C6
later on and if she goes to C7 then she
doesn't have a way to attack your queen
yeah I mean you know
um I was trying to figure out her idea
and giving up that pawn and so I came up
with this queen seed and I kind of
believed and I was like oh she has ideas
of like you know CD and then like room
B6 were B4 when the bishop I mean like
so yeah he trusted her in a way I mean I
mean I calculated it but you know just
wrapped you for a second I do believe uh
our playoff match between Ray Robinson
and Sam Shanklin has become
let's get back to it I really yeah we'll
they have a few more minutes
10 minutes we're going to have
some fun with your game no yeah tell us
so I mean basically I just felt like she
had a lot of compensation for a long
time even here like I was wondering
should I take the pawn why didn't I take
it here it was
um this probably would have been the
worst place to take it so you made the
right decision intuitively you know I
went Bishop E2 and it's funny I went to
eat too because I was still thinking of
taking with a knight on D4 and I didn't
want my Bishop to be hit with Knight C5
yeah but when she took on D4 then I was
like you know I thought she still had a
lot of compensation after Knight D4 and
so I went for this Ed position yeah so
this plan with Bishop G6 and Bishop C2
was definitely wrong like I could feel
that because I actually realized because
my Bishop's on E2 she might have this
idea of just like but it's actually not
that good like I get to Castle she
spends a couple of moves with his bishop
and she doesn't Castle herself yeah
she's not castled and basically she's
not winning my queen so at this point I
knew I was doing really well
um and the only thing is that
technically speaking this was still
pretty tricky this was a task yeah yeah
I mean
um winning with those doubled pawns and
I'll just tell you like 93 was I'll show
you something kind of interesting wait
wait oh can I show you a trap go back a
couple of moves yeah instead of Queen B7
for example if she goes Queen D6 here
because of the threat was you know Rook
takes before yeah I have Knight takes F7
I really did want to do this idea yeah
that's a nice one yeah it would have
been quite nice because I pick up
everything you know on this whole sixth
Rank and the before night before as well
so you don't get a rook at two pieces
but look at one piece and this is
completely losing yeah but she played
Queen B7 she must have seen that and but
this gave me this chance to play Knight
D3 I mean
um to transition with this trade of nice
to finally win the A6 pawn and perhaps
this was her last moment to try to save
the game with the move Rook to B8 she
has to focus on the point not the people
yeah that makes sense definitely I mean
okay we keep going I'll show you the
other mood that I thought was
interesting
um so here yeah big decision so
basically the idea of Rook D1 you know
was to provoke this E5 move right like I
figured like actually the whole point
was to give my Bishop on A6 like a
better life you know and so I had to get
her to play E5 yes and you know that
Bishop won me the game yes and it's
incredible like you know how you tell
your students like focus on your pieces
you know take care of your pieces so
they can help you and I took care of
that bishop and he won the game for me
the bishop didn't did win the game
the bishop and the double Pawns in fact
the Double B pawns right yeah and after
that you clinically defended everything
no checks on everyone it didn't feel
clinical to me I mean it was it was
scary with those seconds on the clock
and when and you know when I had to
allow her Knight F3 I mean you know
intuitively you really don't want to do
that but you have to yeah you have to
continue pushing your pawn and that's
exactly what you did in the right
configuration
she never was able to get in time to
your king right because this race
between you promoting the pawn and her
getting to your king she never got there
and you won after two Queens on the
board that's a nice nice check or a
discover check yeah Arena tomorrow with
the black pieces obviously she will be
coming to the game with aggressive
intentions yeah it's a good thing I'm
aggressive too there we go it's going to
be definitely a fiery match up guys any
questions for everybody uh
congratulations are in a very very
impressive 3-0 good luck uh tomorrow for
your match thank you Yasser absolutely
uh jumping to our playoff game because
this is what it's all about they're in
the elimination bracket they have
equalized to this point uh yep they've
played two games and so far it's been a
draw a piece so I mean there's nothing
separating them so we've had to spice
things up a bit by taking away their
clock by taking away their time
time and here they are Ray Robson I've
been playing four draws together
yes and they're playing with a Time
control of 10 minutes plus
move and Ray Robson begins with the
white pieces and to my eyes looking at
the position and looking at the board it
looks like a good start
for for white okay just just checking
just checking yeah just um looking at it
you know I know black has double pawns
but I'm not really going to focus on
that I'm just looking at White's pieces
white has a lovely night in the center
and has the ability to open up the
position at the right time everything's
always at the right time with the move
F2 the F4 which you know I'm obsessed
with this thing okay uh from my
perspective is if I was on the black
side I would sit there say to myself
just as you did
um you've got one break I'm not really
afraid of c3b4 I mean what are you doing
over there not afraid of C3
there's only one it's all about you're
getting in F4 right and so if I was in
black shoes I would try to put my knight
on the E6 Square
so something like Knight to D4 Knight to
E6 in order to restrain you from ever
making that break or you could give up
your bishop and I'm kind of thinking
that if let me just put that okay let me
make a bad move pardon me apologies
apologies apologies apologies I got my
knight here if you ever gave up your
Bishop then your knight on D2 is kind of
yeah you know I I've got I've I've got
you hemmed in if you will so I'm
thinking in Sam's uh situation all he's
got to do is get his Knight to E6 to
restrain the the brake F4 and then he'll
be
equal I agree
well I think Queen F3 a dynamic position
actually both sides not over okay too we
did funnily enough we didn't see that
one so the queen comes to F3 presumably
with the idea of sliding away to the G3
square and initiating
this F4 break that is if black doesn't
stand down with a queen I would probably
again I I don't want to trade and allow
the Knight to take on F3 but I do want
to play once again Knight to TV yeah and
that's annoying so you have to go Queen
E3 and say how about on the E3 Square
okay and no I I keep declining uh this
opportunity to trade Queens uh the
Queens have been traded though the
queens were traded okay that's a bit of
a surprise
so we're just ready to get the Knight to
D4 okay E8 Rook to E8 Knight D4 on
Black's agenda hmm
it makes a lot of sense if you think
about it right
I thought it was a little bit this time
but I don't see exactly how how I can
take advantage but also why would white
be right now better
why would there be an opening Advantage
I know this was this was why I don't see
the brain was saying why are you about
UV did you say white was doing well
why did you not stop disappeared because
I mean take a look at it I mean F4 is
not really happening I mean uh
I mean F4 is the only break in the Box
I'm not afraid of C3 and D4 and once you
play C3 which was played on the board
the D3 Pawn is going to be forever weak
right so now I can focus on that you're
definitely not playing D4 anytime soon
maybe I can start with Knight D5 or A5
myself to just I kind of I I find myself
drawn to the move Knight A5 because
after all I don't mind eliminating this
bishop I I would be happy to take it put
my Pawn on F6 put my Bishop on E6 so I
would probably go Bishop D5 right
and can I play
May I boldly ask
the obvious the obvious yes
um can I try it
E1 which one wait wait wait wait a
minute wait a minute yeah that's why I
was also considering before there is
Bishop takes Bishop okay first
and uh if you take the Knight back to
I maybe on P3 I can even go Knight to B3
to D4 I don't uh carefully is on the
board Bishop D5 is on the board it might
be Bishop to E6
by the way I can also toss in C6
here
does that make any sense to toss him
remove C6 probably not I
wish that help you or uh I'm not sure
I'm not sure uh because you you
mentioned very specifically the pawn on
B3 is a Target and it it's absolutely
true you know you would love to double
up
uh against the D3 plot no I mean I'm
looking at the position and I feel like
black has absolutely no he did Play
Bishop E6 immediately by the way Sam
Shanklin equalized if not even more yeah
because of this weakness on D3 I feel
like it's time to
I mean are you looking at Bishop takes
bishop and going um yeah or are you
I think I suppose so you have to right
Bishop takes Bishop
um yeah okay let's do it let's do it and
then move the route to D1 and then go
say you know what there's Pawn on D3
it's my one weakness and I will hold on
to it you know what we say in Seattle
what seizing the defensive
exactly I I have an expression as well
yeah Thou shalt not pass thou shall not
pass I will put the King on E2 and thou
shall not pass borrowed from Gandalf's
Playbook absolutely
nice uh Bishop E6 on the board uh so
something went awry for uh Ray Robson
here yeah no I mean right now he's down
three minutes on the clock he's sorry
I'm just going to find the equality we
refresh my board no I'm not I don't like
the way that looked or maybe I did
excuse me I'm just doing this uh it will
just be a quick second he did in fact go
for the trade trade and then actually
did make a breakthrough with c3b4
again very committal because you do give
up
at all over the D4 Square takes B4 and
we have B5 on the board I guess this is
the way Ray pulls the brakes by
calculating some very very you know
straightforward forcing line
and now you take on beef yeah five and
just you know we remind everybody that
they alternate colors right they do
alternate colors and they will play a
second game
rapid time control because if the match
is still tight after these four games
then we were going to see them play oh
no there's lots of Blitz Games of three
plus three plus two and speeding it up
each time until we get to the arm again
and cut it and Knight B5 I love this
move Knight B4 by the way by uh Sam that
just kind of like clarifies that hey
look you know I've I've got I've got my
own tickles in the position Rook C1 whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa
uh things are suddenly getting
interesting are they are they yeah I'm
convinced what are you gonna do your
Pawn on C7 is hunted yes but this Pawn
on D3 is a very promising Target as well
so let's say I play the move Rook E7
yeah C3
3 C3
and I
kind of tempted to play A5 or Rook The
Rook to d8 right away okay and if you
just
hunt rugby seven whoa okay that move was
not on my agenda that was a surprise I
was about to say that move was not uh
even number two on my list uh Rook to B7
whoa
okay
he is forcibly reminding uh White uh
that is to say sam Shanklin is forcibly
reminding white that there is a pawn
hanging
that's a strange move but I mean it
doesn't work because I mean can you go
deep
D4 D4 before I take and then my whole
idea was to put the Knight on C6
and just after Knight take
wow you're going to be upon down the
whole situation
uh C7 C5 maybe on uh
as Sam's agenda I like I like to move C5
by the way because if you don't amp us
on then the Knight is you know boss on
the B4 square but we learned yesterday
that when it comes to Ampersand you
always nine times out of ten you follow
the streamers right and you always take
nine out of ten dentists repre recommend
capturing the pond
Rook A3 on the board and if you like D4
I like the the idea of Rook C4 and D4 in
uh
Ray's position so and C5 definitely
connects very well with his last move
Rook to B7 right because at least
silicon p7 is not going to be deaf
um
F6 F6 looks
passive uh why not Rook C4 give me the
Knight
85. A5 D4
yeah now you get my idea no I got now
now I feel my mojo is working a little
bit
C6 or C5 and again you have to play
let's say C6 yeah just makes sense well
wait a minute I do have check a knight
D4 so maybe I have something so perhaps
that's why I have to go uh C5 right
okay but there is a danger the danger is
that if I get a knight to C4 I'll keep
your majority under control and I'll
have a very powerful
um
Knight on C4
uh just a potential concern
uh yeah maybe
don't know uh we have King F1 on the
board
sorry king of one is the move yes
against F7 F6 King F1
tempting just to break out with C5 C6
absolutely no I think uh C5 situation
will this work on B7 makes such a
strange impression why did we fee in
Shadow or Rook uh but no definitely C5
uh or yeah the C5
and how it has to be played right yeah
another move could be Rook D6
keep Rook D6 King so but then I guess
eventually I am going to be going
to C6 C6 or C5 right uh again I'm
thinking that the one thing I really
want to avoid is G6 I think is on the
board
okay five two seconds A5 never mind yeah
A5 and I guess white is simply gonna
continue with the plan of just improving
the king move it to the Santa can you
too
makes a lot of sense
and uh just to kind of
remind ourselves of the clock times Ray
Robson has just under three minutes
whilst Sam Shanklin has over four
minutes it just happens to refresh we
have the breakouts
so I'm breaking through with C6
but perhaps it's too little too late
because you're not actually obliged to
capture this Pawn
but if you don't then that a pawn in the
future is going to be very dangerous he
took it yeah he doesn't like that and
very quickly uh Sam said no I'm not
interested in Rook trades and I like
this I like this movie because Rook C3
Falls for Knight A2 be careful
that's the fork that's a fork that hurt
but don't I have something like what
I've been kind of dumping the table for
92 tonight to C4 he's going towards that
yes
I I think that the Knight on C4 will do
a terrific job at holding up the
majority on the on the
Queen side
but how do we assess a position I mean
is white still playing for an advantage
I don't think so
what do you guys think
um I would say slightly yes I I I
wouldn't say it's a great it's not like
I'm doing cartwheels over here but I I
do think the king's a little bit better
white has more potential with F4 and D4
and blacks Queen sided a little bit
rigid and that's all on the board I was
going to say wise position I mean it's
not winning
but then again you don't need every
position to be winning you just need it
to be you have to slightly better but
and The Clocks by the way what is the
seven o'clock situation is Ray is
playing with just over two minutes okay
and uh Sam is just under three and a
half minutes got it so
okay so if I'm white it's not again I'm
not doing cartwheels Rook to C4 Rook to
C3 I've been visualizing a lot of Trades
but I'm thinking that the pawns on B6
and A5 wait a minute
oh no he must have seen something very
forcing here because
I was about to play F5 and Rook G1 so he
got in G5 just in time before white
could uh put this put the clamp and this
is such a risky decision
it certainly feels it doesn't it I at
five then I'm going to put the Knight on
C4 as you want it to prescribed yeah and
at some point I'm going to transfer that
route to the other side of the board The
Rook on A3 yeah okay one Rook H1 and I'm
going to open up the position with the
move h4n if you don't have a clear way
of combating that yeah you're going to
be in a worse position well well let's
start with the obvious I I capture which
in it yep
which he has done but I can go Knight to
see Ah that's a nice move H5
anytime you play H4 I play G4
yes that's a very very nice move Rook to
A1 he's going for
this switch he's just gonna move his
Rook right yep and also it just allows
the king to go to E3 well not right now
E3 at the right time it shows that the
Knight on C4 is just so much better than
Knight of B4 that's exactly why I
thought that white had the pull again
it's nothing you know like magnificent
but King to to D2 to C3 this night
these guys are inflexible I'm thinking
that the Knight on B4 is gonna have to
go
swing around he played Rook C5 that
gives a pawn what Rook seat five I don't
know if you want to take it but it's an
option check and Rook H2 right yes
I believe that might be no no need to
King C3 I love your plan yeah then
follow that you can also follow that
through with moving maybe you can if
once you've got your King on D3 D3 for
me once I've got the King on C3 D3 D4
it's an idea
and the King
goes back to d8
but now we start getting this Rook G1 E5
ideas yes we do king C3 Rook G1 D4 E5
ideas you betcha
again I feel that these pawns on B6 and
A5 are stuck on molasses that's just a
shake of heads by I think Sam is kind of
he's not happy with his position right
now Rook to be one that's intriguing
um why did he need he wants to go rugby
too
and then
okay
C3
small improvements King C7 okay
I guess he wants Rook B2 yeah Ruby too
he's prepping King C3 he just doesn't
want to see a knight A2 check
uh so Rook B2
and he's just saying well you can't play
B5 I'll take a pawn whoa whoa whoa is
that true
you can you play on B5 but I will take
on B5 first and then after you take them
before I take on A5 that's pardon me it
is upon
yeah I was about to say I I'm thinking I
would probably want to play B5 as King
C6 is all black uh you know and two just
clear the queen side King C6 yeah the
king to C3
I would be tempted to go well but if you
go King C3 you do allow B5 at last we
exchanged that
well to D4 right then
okay
I like what Ray is doing you know he's
not making anything
forcing forcing
allow B5
that's right I think it seems like he's
trying to avoid as much as possible
um any
okay that's basically a siren song that
says
you know uh you're not going to go into
any night endings but are you giving the
G4 Square Knight E3 to G4 yeah certainly
are wow
Rook B2
by the way uh Ray's Place so far has
been very carpovian it's sort of like
he's doing nothing but it's nettlesome
each move kind of induces something uh
the move h5h4 did give up the G4 squared
993 group B1 oh King C7 rugby I was
thinking Knight E3 set it up so
perfectly but he's like he's gonna wait
93 I thought prepping D4
yeah no I'm thinking this is getting
serious even though Rey has been very
very slow finally I have to refresh my
board I remember talking about the clock
times we Sam has just under one minute
whereas Ray is also down to 50 seconds
and the clock is ticking down I really
do expect Ray just to kind of play Rook
B2 and then put the Knight on E3 I mean
I can't get my my border refresh for
some reason
I think we can stay on this one for the
moment bird's eye view because we're
entering the final minute of both
players
so we're to B3 defending that pawn on D3
also potentially opening up a rook lift
via the third round after the move d4
don't play D4 yet because the Knight on
C4 is hanging
wait a minute can you take on B6
no no C3 no no
saying to Sam consider the fact that I
might want to stop off works exactly
well here again I'm really loving this
move Knight E3 I want to transfer he's
going to propose into a night ending
there we go where
white has the break D4 and E5 and black
doesn't have the break B5
30 seconds 32 seconds for Ray 37. Sam's
in trouble he doesn't like his position
anymore coming to G4 followed by D4 E5
that's looking threatening yeah and so
he's actually said no to this
works
okay it's looking very powerful knight
G4
eyeing up the F6 Pawn yes indeed light
comes down to A6 you know four grovel
mode
I think that's the proper way of putting
it gravel indeed King E3 and I think
he's going to give up the pawn go D4
give up the pawn on A4 no how dare you
give up night a for Rook A3 followed by
D4
it is no reason to go into any race yeah
that's true he had no reason to give
your opponent uh hope Ray has been
waiting it out he's been so patient
almost had that Borough constrictor of
course why go into the race
well it that would make the game
unfortunately for Rey's perspective
double-edged this is this is nothing
double-edged about it this is a two
result game
oh and uh here comes the eporn that's an
incredibly Powerful movie E5
and Sam is really really feeling it he
knows what's happening he's I cannot
resist I know give me a protective
passport nobody okay wow gray a master
of patience there's no more Rook to
before because of Knight to D5 check
Word
you have to go to C1 right
Knight to D5 immediately he's six
why is the night gonna go back 98 to be
eight okay Rook to C3 oh this is a
beautiful place oh Reyes
this is like masterful stuff that we're
seeing by Ray Robson here he's
he completely outplayed him it's
extraordinary
incredible game incredible display by
Ray
wow
Rook takes A4
13 seconds Sam eight he's trying to go
to age seven and pick up the phone
number
yes great stuff
B5 no way you're way too slow
Jack King D6 group D7 D5 check followed
by E7
you're not catching that pawn
you're absolutely right you are not
catching that pawn you know what
take on A6
[Laughter]
I agree thanks guys
wow okay
sometimes you just gotta tip your head
well done
wow and we're gonna do it all again in
the next five minutes yeah and this time
incredible also wow it's calm and poised
Elegance as well the patience with which
he played that end game was to be
admired Ray Robson takes the lead first
Victory and uh they they've had four
draws up to this moment and now Sam
Shanklin will have to win with white
visas to prolong the match into a
Armageddon yeah and uh this is the
current standings in the elimination
bracket so LeBron Iranian has gotten
through and Sam Shanklin and Ray Robson
offered two draws well now we have seen
a breakthrough Ray Robson snatches a
point and leaves Sam shankland in a
must-win situation Sam if he does not
win we'll be leaving the competition
dramatic stuff yeah and again I just the
Christian uh break down that ending if
you don't mind me asking we're talking
about Alice Lee in 28.50 what was Rey's
performance like that was incredibly
accurate display I felt no absolutely I
mean I think I counted maybe 10 rupee
one rugby two rupee one rugby two and
his position was getting better and
better and I was like what's happening
right now
Sam Shanklin understood very well that
he needs to take on F4 not to allow any
sort of like uh a similar expansion on
the king side the problem is he did not
follow it up well he played the move G5
which allows F5 after which the position
is extremely extremely difficult what he
was supposed to do right now after the
move F4 was F5 very difficult move to
make but the point being that if you do
try to create this past Pawn with the
move E5 finally now I'm going to attack
it with G5 and you're simply not in time
to get your setup D4 you can surely play
that but I'm going to take that pawn and
I'm going to be able to create the
blockade on the light squares take on C6
King to E6 get the Knight to D5 and this
pawns despite the fact that they're
connected past pawns they're not going
anywhere and in fact your King on it
right now is starting to become a bit
feeble in the position so I have to say
first of all I'm looking at the times
right now three minutes for Sam Shanklin
two minutes time 22 seconds for Ray
Robson very very difficult moment
critical moment in this position he
chose the wrong Pawn to advance G5 F5
and after this trade this is already the
engine is enjoying White's position and
this is exactly what Ray did as well
just slowly slowly improve the position
wait for you to create your weaknesses
specifically this move H4 giving up the
G4 square and Yasser I think you're the
one that really didn't like this Advance
with the move H uh for it was like I saw
for you immediately screamed hey get the
Knight to G4 right and that's exactly
what he did later on with patience
Kick The Rook off the C file by a
blackmailing uh Sam Shanklin with the
The Rook exchange you cannot exchange
the Rooks because then the Knight goes
to G4 and also this king is going to
invade King to C4 King to B5 you're
going to have weaknesses on the queen
side as well just a clinical beautiful
display I have to say probably in this
tournament this is my favorite end game
that rate just displayed just an
incredible game
uh through that I mean uh that there's
been some great chats and uh Ray Ray got
uh eliminated uh in the Champions
bracket uh with great play and he just
played
one of the best endings I've seen in
quite some time as they get ready and
they're off and I do believe this was
the exact same situation they were in
last year and then Samsung won On Demand
with the white pieces to take it to an
Armageddon wow Ray using his trust once
again the Berlin defense and
you know one of the things that I've
always admired about you know the
greatest players in the world they are
stubborn
they have their opening ideas and
nuclear atomics could not separate them
from their favorites they will play it
so the cows come home and here we have a
Berlin and Sam is convinced that he's
going to get something has he thus far
proven anything in the match matches
with the white side of the Berlin he did
get some advantages right
I mean he had the exchange up in their
last Berlin encounter true which Ray
saved with 12 seconds for it yeah that
was Ray was very exultant about saving
that uh draw uh and is that the game
where he played Knight D4 there was a I
believe it was something like a knight
D4 so Knight D5 on the board
okay and I can see that this position
has been played before and remarkably
enough A5 is theoretical and now the
wrinkle and even GT5 is the wrinkle in
their previous uh game yeah sampling the
move Bishop to B2 Bishop to B2 Knight to
D4 and that was the game now uh Bishop
B2 new idea
it was their previous ideas that this
player have
per tournament and then do they speak
with their seconds in between the games
like hey if you play this variation of
the Berlin again you're going to change
it up first and you're going to play
this move Knight to D5 like what's their
setup well we want to ask you I mean
you're the one with the world
championship match in 2018 with Bobby
and uh Magnus when they played that they
played the Rapids and they had that
little break did you did did uh well the
rappers didn't go no I know so yeah
um we were on uh yeah on the back foot
from the get-go pretty much it's like
some you know super Elite level it is
the top of the thing so you're gonna
have your red line to your seconds but
in a tournament like this I was told
yeah that I was told on this I
completely shattered my Illusions yeah I
honestly thought that they would be like
hello and go yes yes I need to do the
okay gotcha right in fact I was told no
that they just go back check the lines
on the computer
so they bring the laptops with them and
they have their own room is that what
you're saying yeah I mean but they've
had some time to just think about what
they're going to be doing well if they
leave the playing Hall and they go as
you've described it to a separate room
then they get wandered coming back into
the playing hall because the playing
Hall is electronics free right I mean
you can't just pull in your mobile phone
and say well let me check my file well
doesn't matter because Ray's Under
Pressure right Knight F4 yeah this idea
of Knight to D5 Knight to D4 take take
Rook to D1 C6 Knight to F4 how are you
going to defend that point I have no
choice I have to play C5 Bishop D4 is
just to fail right Bishop to D Bishop to
B2 and I'm gonna lose the pawn on D4 so
C5 is
box as in four but then do you save it
it feels like some things something yeah
yeah yeah with E6 and something exactly
some something could go wrong but you
have to play right so okay so let's
start with C5 C5 C3 this is what um
um Jovi wants to suggest is that look
check this out
and there goes there goes the bishop
Freddie yeah that might be it
so
this is the moment where maybe you
should kick that night away then
because it was a key piece
go G5 first makes sense and then the
night goes to H5
right I've got a bit of one head another
one grows because the Knight is gonna
I'm gonna play C3 and the night will
drop in maybe I just have to give hang
on but I mean should I panic too much if
I drop the d-pawn because after all you
know
it's easiest Double C porn right so
you're about to suggest that after a G5
because you know at least and then you
then
yeah okay we play but you you you do
like G5 because I was thinking that it
was too inviting
to inviting that that square F6 is like
maybe this is not good news for foreign
forcibly reminded of the world
championship match
between Vichy and Magnus where it was
this Berlin and he got his Knight to F6
and
um
white one with this very very powerful
knight on the F6 Square so
G5 hmm I but I hear what you were saying
like if you played for example G6 Rook
takes D4 King C7 how bad is it or
exactly it's not mean how bad is it I
mean even if the Knight does get to F6
you know if you've got the King on C7
the bishop only six and you just say
look at this you know I have two Bishops
I've restrained your Pawn advantage and
we're just gonna pretend yeah that I'm
sorry I think we're just talking a
little bit at Cross purposes I wanted to
say that provided you don't put my
knight on F6 you're doing fine like for
example suppose you would just play King
here Rook takes and you just kind of
like said oh poor me I blundered upon
you know how bad is it right like if you
go like I don't want you to put the
Knight on uh F6 but it's really bad but
when you played the move G5 Knight H5
which is on the board yeah I'm thinking
this is really bad
super that please sorry
I'm going to play Knight F6 and Rook D4
I want to win a piece
yes oops
no and and I just want to show you how
crafty these two games were from Sam
Shanklin he started off with this idea
of Bishop to B2 instead of Knight to D5
for which the reaction has to be Knight
D4 Ray Robson knew the reaction Knight
to D4 is the best move he's the main
line in this position in fact the only
move that has been played five top Elite
level games in this position with Knight
to D4 now he came the second game in the
same position and played the move Knight
to D5 now if you react with the same
Knight to D4 you end up in exactly that
position that we currently have on the
board which is horrible Knight to D4 was
Ray robson's reaction Knight takes D4
Knight takes D4 Rook to D1 c692 F4 yeah
G5 Knight to H5 and now you just simply
have to give up the pawn and try to
survive with the pawn down and so much
pressure piling up in your position this
night coming to F6 I really like what
Sam is doing and he has tremendous
chances to potentially
yeah I like Knight F6 uh at once he
played Rook takes D4 take the pawn why
not hmm
well there is a problem isn't there a
bishop C5 and Bishop F5
so it's a
take a little Rook
look moves away well we're down yeah
down there and this is what I was saying
that perhaps Rook to E4 and Rook 32.
Rook to E4 and repeat well whoa whoa
whoa I'm kind of getting some
compensation aren't I oh you definitely
have some conversation yes well a moment
ago I was thinking I had nothing but do
you have enough compensation
because now with the bishopone F5 you
don't have root 28 well he has played it
by the way he has played uh yeah Bishop
to C5 is the natural progression
natural progression
we're talking about my growth rate
hey Ricky he's getting ready to put the
Rook
we think on the E4 Square
what
have a lot of options Rook to D2 also
seems like P2 feels clunky though yeah I
mean you're thinking I'm thinking you
know go well Bishop beef Rook B2 feels
exactly uh you're getting this nice
Tempo
hey wait a minute you know I'm getting a
little bit uh happy about my Pawn
sacrifice yeah you know like it's only a
blunder when it doesn't work can we ask
Grand Martha's about this do they have a
blunder
Wesley said yes and we're like no no
you have these players met in Berlin
have these players met in Berlin I don't
think I did
because they were both there they were
both there and they're putting me on the
spots because I remember Sam lost to
so I'm lost to uh from the beginning and
uh Ray Robson lost to
no because he got knocked out by lenia
Dominguez so nope they didn't play
big moment right now Rook to E4 seems to
be and just remind everybody uh the top
the the tempo on the clocks they have uh
10 minutes they have 10 minutes and a
five second increment gotcha and this
both players underneath five minutes
they are underneath five minutes or no
pardon me seven minutes for yeah sorry
seven and a half minutes and Ray of
course under five minutes of course yeah
I'm saying of course a bit of flippantly
because we've realized you know that Ray
actually uses his time as we saw very
wisely in the previous game but we just
to reinforce the point
Sam needs to win this game in order to
take this match to the next set of tie
breaks exactly if he loses if he draws
that's it he leaves the competition
Bishop E7 and that was one of the
reasons why I really wanted the Knight
on F6 because now I play the Knight to
F6 you capture Bishops of opposite color
the drawing chances for uh Rego you know
exponentially higher
Rook C4 what did he do seven
they they should be two yeah they should
all Bishop to B2 and we're expecting
Bishop E6 or Rook D no he went Rook d8
presumably we work on h8 yes it's okay
I can guess
I'm Keen to guess
the the Monty Python cheese skit
are you familiar with the Monty Python
he walks into a cheese shop and says I'd
like some cheese well you come to the
right place yeah there's no cheese
whatsoever like some Himalayan goat
cheese oh we're fresh out
okay uh uh how are we doing Christian
what does the engine say about this
position oh the engine is loving uh the
advantage that white has the extra Pawn
good extra pawn and that's exactly what
it says plus one around there plus 0.8
plus one somewhere around that uh level
but nevertheless I mean Sam got what he
wanted he has plenty of pressure in the
position he has a lot of extra time on
the clock and raise under tremendous
pressure to try to win this match
he he doubles him on the clock right now
yeah
I mean yeah I think he just has to I get
the feeling Ray just needs to speed up
and start making some random moves like
I would just be playing A4
well that's exactly it there is a
threat I want to say oh okay and the
threat is maybe E6
so the idea is this Rook on E2 is
x-raying this guy so if you take with
the pawn I've got G4 yep and if you take
with the bishop well I've got this
crazy move that hits you from all kinds
of angles uh Knight to G7 so maybe E5
pardon me uh
E5 E6 is a threat we do have Rook D5 on
the board right yeah okay
do we play C4 now or
C4 or do we try to expand on the king
side
I'd be a little reluctant to give up the
D3 Square yeah
so how do we make any progress
well again is E6 a threat
okay we've been told G4 G4 yeah that was
the expansion I was envisioning um G4
and then try to get a knight to F5
G4 you move the bishop to G6 let's say
Knight g395 okay
or maybe Knight G7 Knight F5
no I don't
I don't think I should go to it I I'm
still having a hard time understanding
why I shouldn't play E6
I take I take with a bishop and then
Knight G7
maybe you can just
hold like go King D7 you know and just
says
um I'm gonna hold it on Bishop C5 after
that
okay yeah and you kind of give back you
guys
if you do take only six I go okay okay I
needed to understand but G4 kind of like
that move G4 Knight Knight G7 Knight F5
uh where's the black Bishop going you
know one
probably
well I was thinking G6 but Bishop E6
maybe F4
so I'm thinking G4 if you go this away
I go that away
G4 on the board on the board and this is
kind of where maybe The Rook is a little
bit funky here because F5 is a big
threat right
um but if you go yeah he has played G4
and if you go the other way this is
where uh Christian said Christian
sad not Christian Sun uh I'm gonna go
Knight G3 Knight F5
maybe even I 276
but what about if you just double double
the Rooks on the d-line and then just
say well
you know d-line that was a massive a
pardon me oh because E6 is still in the
air the five
true that's why you want to go E6 yeah
oh you wanted Knight F5 and yeah yeah it
looks so it is a lot of sense as well
white is having more fun let's put it
that way let me just do something I
apologize this is only going to take a
quick second I'd like to refresh the
board so that the
the score sheet if you will is
accurate and uh Ray ticking down to two
minutes on the clock is the pawn down
and he's having to withstand a lot of
pressure from Sam shankland absolutely
Sam needs to win the game and he's put
himself in great shape to do precisely
that Bishop E6 Bishop G6
on the board
yeah
you like E6 you like rookie one you like
King G2 you like F4 or you like Knight
G3 to be honest they all look pretty
good I'll take all of the above exactly
two of each yeah no I quite like um
is not really working
moving towards the center absolutely and
here you know maybe was there something
to be said for Knight G7 if you put your
knight on G7 then the move E5 E6 comes
with extra power doesn't it it does yes
so after this move I would probably want
to play rookie one and Knight F5 well
this is what yeah five immediately he
has done that and I was wondering here
yes yeah okay now I think you have to
move the Rook but
I'm really fighting the instinct to go
E6 right you know just to determine
everything the position fiber of my
being wants to play E6 yeah I was
wondering whether I wanted to okay so
he's doubled the works because I think
this is good strategy but I
you know it's funny in the Berlin in the
pawn on E5 is always in the way and you
always want to play E6 and somehow the
Berlin players never let you
get this Pawn to E6 and like this is one
of the few times in the Berlin where
I've seen white doubling on the e-file
and you're gonna play E6
come heaven or high water yeah okay A5
now
it's irresistible I cannot change E6
okay he's with King G2 a moment ago
Ray Robson was playing this unbelievably
patient
fantastic ending and then we just saw
King G2 like Sam shanklin's borrowing a
page from the Ray Robson Playbook oh yes
he is yeah but I've been
G3 F4 black is trying to create some
sort of King G3 conversation on the
queen side but I was
yes sometimes you have to strike when
the Iron's hot and you think now is the
time and I'm thinking no now I think you
have to go Pawn taste porn because you
just do not want to allow that apron to
step one square further it's found
itself on A4 can make its way to A3 I
don't like that it's a script straggler
he did not take it he played Bishop
probably thinking it is Rook 8 followed
by Rook A5
you're getting too much compensation on
the a file yeah
yeah I must have I I must admit I I
while I like grabbing the Pawns in that
particular case
and the double A pawns but you made a
point
um Jovi are we afraid of A3
yes I play A3 it just kind of reminds
you that you don't want to see a rook D1
and rookie it doesn't have too many
squares I was thinking about 93. I think
oh okay 93 would have been a winner what
but seriously
wow if the book doesn't have too many
squares oh D5 yeah if any I mean
B5 probably would have been the only
thing but I kind of like what I look I
mean I'm I'm liking what Sam is doing
Rook F3 E6 well once you go Rook F3 I go
Rook D1
aha
okay so let me play rookie two first
he's going for it which he did he really
is taking the patience from Ray robson's
last game right and B4 and Bishop B1
whoa whoa whoa whoa right I don't like
the look of that Bishop on E1 well it's
it's a temporary look because C3 and C4
uh will release the bishop I think
slow A3 is coming I don't like this The
Rook is going to come down
C3 C3 everything everybody's happy the
the pawn on A2 is still protected but
the problem is is that Ray will be
feeling a lot more optimistic about a
position because when you when you pair
this to what he had before
yeah you know he's got a Pawn on A3
that's gonna annoy Sam no end it would
annoy me for sure
whoa Knight to D6 look at this he's
saying you overplayed your hand buddy
boy I'm gonna play Bishop takes B4 it's
forced yeah we're not taking that Knight
C5 you have to play C5 defend the pawn
on B4 Knight E8 check and Knight F6 say
hello to my little friend
yes
they're tricky mates yeah
come back and fight
oh that was a nice move oh and he erased
saw the the night Fork that was hovering
and he played he played that move with
seven seconds on the clock seven seconds
it looks like
C3 can do inflict some serious
damage makes the most sense yeah he's
done it and where do you put the Rook
after that I guess you've got to go to
F4 but if you go to F4 then I can even
have ideas of night back to C4 and then
right 10 seconds
okay at least the Rook somehow
is no longer trapped I'll put it like
this
um
A3 I would I would like to play Bishop
check followed by Bishop B4 or Bishop B4
immediately which he chose I want to get
rid of that apron and that this is this
is winning this is definitely winning
now
yeah and the bishop thank you very much
and Sam will take it all the way into
the Blitz Games
wow three two one C5
yeah it was only a flash word
C5
I'm not finished with you yet
what is Lee playing for here I mean come
on Bishop takes A3 this is I it's
inertia yes he's in time trouble and
therefore
well he either makes a move or he
resigns right resigns sometimes it has
to be too followed by before
B4 yep
D3
okay
okay that's enough you're going to give
a spike that's on
how many pawns did white pick up is Ray
getting some chances here no no no no no
no whatsoever Bishop B4 yeah you can
just take my Rook please take my Rook
Rook takes A3 Knight F5 everybody's
absolutely absolutely protected he went
for it yeah
the safer stuff I know we're gonna
let me just remind you how the A3 how we
count the material I've got a table base
right here
Ray is trying but you know it's really
insufficient
there's nothing to be done Knight's
gonna jump down to F5 e
and we will have a couple Blitz Games
coming up E6 let's go the Dutch have a
wonderful word hooplus
ah it's hoopless
sounds hopeless yes a bit hoopless is
yeah
the situation is hoopless
and I think Ray knows it yeah certainly
I think he's about to resign it's just
so miserable
Rook to D1 you're going to give a spike
check but that's give me another Pawn
Rook takes H6 he goes for uh for a
promotion okay C6 here
yeah we've opened in this kind of
situation
to resign would be to admit defeat for
certainty and yeah you don't want to do
that you just and those there you go
never admit defeat or seldom ever
defeated
philosophical ideas King dashes out I
mean
I mean so what's the pawn count again I
never get this far in my games like one
is sufficient but two okay the other one
is going to be five one two three five
five pounds okay come on Ray
gotta get yourself mentally that ready
for the next set of tie breaks where the
play sometimes in boxing they have a
trainer who throws in your the towel
because the guy is just taking too many
shots
I think uh I'd I'd be throwing in the
towel right about now race taking too
many shots
he's not going to be in a good frame of
mind for the
for the blitz games that are coming up
um okay that's it
now in the coffin Rook takes Knight
comes in and you kind of fight with all
those pawns and those extra pieces I
guess you can
wow
he's still playing Ray what the heck
hey
come on 2700 oh my goodness okay set the
table for us what if he wins on demand
yeah so uh we just saw that they've won
a game a piece which means that after
four game score is 2-2 and it means time
gets slashed we're gonna see these two
players fight it out over two games with
a quicker time control of three minutes
plus two seconds
and whilst they're taking a break we'll
also take a break as well but please
join us in a few minutes because the
action is gonna get intense
[Music]
when you visit St Louis you'll probably
want to watch the Cardinals or the blues
what about after the game
back to the hotel would be a major error
instead Boogie through the city and
discover the music that gave the blues
their name at the national Blues Museum
Broadway Oyster Bar or even the
legendary Blueberry Hill so whether you
love the Cardinals the blues or the
blues come play with us
and you guys know I can't play this
right St Lou is always exploring
founded in 1839 the University of
Missouri is steeped in Tradition the
recently founded Mizzou chess program is
a partnership between the University of
Missouri and the St Louis chess club
Collegiate Jess has been experiencing a
meteoric rise at the national level
through its tradition of Excellence
Mizzou has always strived for the best
Mizzou chess is working towards raising
the bar by bringing our institutions
ethos of respect responsibility
Discovery and Excellence to the
chessboard
thank you
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program in the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grand Master
varuja nicobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve relationships between at-risk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since 2019. the St
Louis chess club has also created a
chess merit badge for the scouts BSA
quickly becoming one of the most popular
badges with more than 200 150 000 Scouts
earning the badge since 2011. students
of chess can also pick up a copy of read
and write chess thanks to Club
co-founder Dr Jeannie Karen sinkfield
anyone can learn how to understand chess
notation in no time we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
[Music]
can you hear it it's the sound of Hope
and health
and strength it's the sound of
compassion of open doors where people
and machines are in tune and miracles
occur
it's the sound of personalized health
care and active communities it sounds
like life
and it's what you hear when you really
listen
[Music]
we're the Corey family Welcome to our
show
[Music]
you guys
thank you
[Music]
foreign
and we are back and as we see on the
screen we see that the match between Ray
Robson and Sam Shanklin the three
minutes plus two seconds increment Blitz
portion has begun and Sam has come in a
fighting mood he said enough of these
e45s instead is going to be a night off
and that's what we have on the board
this uh I've always thought of it of
Ebola slavsky variation the night org
with Bishop E2 and E5 that I see on the
database they they're calling it
something else though open chensky
variation whatever
um how is the position Christian is this
uh
uh the latest and greatest in this line
of theory well I haven't even gotten uh
my name
and disaster than we expected
yeah they're still in uh the throes of
theory right now it seems Bishop to d8
can you explain that one which was a
play a move played by uh Juan Jun versus
costing you all the way in 2012. WoW
definitely targeting the pawn on A5
potentially preparing the move B6 and to
take back on B6 with the bishop
potentially changing pythagonals well
let me ask the obvious question what
happens after 95
.00
let's get let's think with the knife
right take with the knife yeah okay and
go Bishop to F5 I see take it tonight
there's nothing to happen because he
played Bishop to E3 it just develops I
like this idea just develop the pieces
Happy Days wait for black to do
something and black has done something
that played B5 you have to get rid of
that pawn right
uh instant capture and an instant
capture on B3 okay that's a bit of a
surprise really but this that meant is
that there was no Knight A5 uh
um Pardon Me Sam did not want to see
and he just played Bishop takes Pawn
takes Bishop takes uh B6
yeah
and I guess it's all about that D5
Square
um
G4
Bishop takes Knight right then stick the
night into D5 whereas an octopus right
once again Sam is building up a very
nice time advantage two minutes and 30
seconds against one minute and 10
seconds for Ray
but we have seen one of Ray's
Specialties is actually to get himself
low on the clock
it worked to a treat in the game before
that he really is addicted to it how do
we how does the engine pardon me
evaluate the current position do they
see it as balanced or slight Advantage
for white
slight Advantage for white after this
move Bishop to G4 I think this um
definitely asking some very pertinent
questions Bishop takes E3 Rook takes E3
Rook d8 dropping uh out of the pin
prepping the move Knight C5
I am not letting the Knight drop go to
C5 I'll get rid of my bad bishop and
that's one thing that I like about Sam
whenever he thinks for a prolonged
period of time he usually plays a series
of moves very fast after that
putting a lot of pressure
that's exactly what he's threatening the
defense
was on White's agenda defense Queen to
d8 B4
okay I mean look that's the point out
right
that's my extra Pawn
no there's no extra oh there's no extra
point
whatever
we we we lost you there coach
and uh yeah Sam has calculated that D5
is possible wait a minute can I take on
F6
legal decided against it take on D5
Knight takes D5
and this is not a problem for Sam that's
uh if I'm in black shoes I kind of like
Black's position uh I'd rather play
Black here I also would play black hair
just because you know I just it's very
positions and peace activity and King
safety and you know Black's King is safe
what's King is safe but Pawn structure
wise
yeah no problem but I think the best
thing you can get is four versus three
in a Rooks and
something like Queen to D6 it covers the
eight Pawn I would take some time out
and secure the black king H6 well there
is Rook takes A6 let's be fair for Rey
I'll take it
I'll take that pawn definitely oh okay
yeah I haven't seen that I was so photog
okay G6
your idea is is inviting Rook takes A6
and Ray says I absolutely I agree you
don't have to ask me twice
and he wants E4 okay
he wants to find the Perpetual there is
a check on the B8 in D1 and then the B4
Pawn is hanging yeah that's exactly what
he's going for Rook F4
okay
well wait a minute that'll Rook on F4
looks a little bit weird if I played F5
I know it looks ugly but this Rook sure
looks
yeah makes it makes huge sense so let's
go Queen to E6 and G4
I know somebody's lifting their kimonos
dangerous
what options do I have well indeed he
didn't play F5 he did play Rook check
but I think he's gonna go for it F5
okay he included the the check first uh
five
10 seconds
and King G7 G4 and G4 what about Queen
C7 though yeah Queen C7 wait wait wait a
minute it's gonna make an appearance
guys what Sam said how do you defend
that
really King G2 instantly Perpetual with
Queen E7 nice
oh this is a little bit bad news for Ray
because oh yes game
Sam we've seen has come to the table
incredibly well prepared the game has
finished it is a draw wow we are waiting
again two uh Advantage time I'm not sure
what what just happened uh was all
completely copacetic because Rook F4
really has the feel of danger for white
uh was was this correct Christian did
did Rook F4 give opportunity for Sam
Shanklin or was it okay
I think it was okay it was still okay
yes everything was well calculated
maybe that's an overstatement maybe
that's an overstate but he did not have
any uh moment in time where he was
better okay
wow let's just review the end of that
game because that was a bit of a
scramble the players were down to how
much time 11 seconds 11 seconds
12 seconds and then the Perpetual magic
of television
and that G4 was very resigned themselves
to the Fate yeah that G4 move came just
in the nick of time to rescue the rook
and king G2 I mean you have to see
kimchuku yeah to save the game because
you see Queen C7 and your heart stops
you say queen C7 I'm losing the rook and
then you go oh King G2 that's where
those eight hours of puzzle Rush right
really I mean quite handy yeah
our five games this the scores are tied
two and a half points each
which means we are now gonna be facing
another Blitz playoff of three minutes
plus two seconds this time slam Shanklin
will have the white pieces and let's
spawn through the whole bracket
standings because you can see that uh
Hikaru Nakamura and Dominguez they are
tied after one game as are Wesley so and
Fabiana carono they will be playing the
second game tomorrow and everything will
be decided then and
moving down to the elimination bracket
well they don't get that luxury of
having their second day they have a free
day if you survive if you don't survive
that is that that is it you are out and
we can see Lavon aronian did emerge
triumphants over Sam Seville and Sam
Shanklin and Ray Robson we don't know
yet because at the minute it is
completely even after five games and in
the ladies uh
they are back and they are blitzing out
the moves it is Blitz and we are seeing
an exchange variation no more Berlin Ray
learned his lesson he was like okay you
got me
I'm changing first this time
I remember when I first learned this
line Bishop G4 h3h5 and I I just thought
it was really really funny oh today that
I thought they were all playing Bishop
E3
um instead of Knight D2 uh but uh Knight
D2 came very quickly and I did one
visits the E1 engine approved variation
is you cannot capture that Bishop on G4
the open H file just gets you checkmated
936 D4 opening up the center
remarkably enough this is all Theory and
there's a there's a whole series of
possibilities it's crazy uh what black
can play Bishop to D6 Knight to F4
Bishop takes F3 Rook to d8 there's
really quite a a large number and even
including Bishop D7
um so many games
yeah Knight F4 is has the smell of
knowing what you're doing Bishop D6
maybe you're freestyling it a little bit
Yeah reinforcing the E5 I kind of like
Bishop D6 and unless I am blundering the
bishop because one moment you will be
threatening to capture my Bishop right
at a certain moment and uh courageous
nothing Knight F4 Pawn takes so this is
the most popular move by far he also
spent like a minute on it Queen G6 is
standard stuff so I'm immediately
responding with Knight H4 we're going to
see Bishop takes Queen 66 1966 or 61.
this has all been seen before remarkably
about Knight takes G6 Rook takes in
castles
I don't want to recapture the pawn on E5
right away I want to pin your knight
that is probably a very good point that
is and he's done his Top Choice and E6
immediately Sam says yeah you you I you
know your stuff but so do I this is
still Theory there's just like more than
30 Games
F6 as well as F takes E6 have been
played before and rookie one Rook F1
King F1 remarkably of Hope and what is
it yeah and uh the main line here is
actually to stop white from playing E4
E5 and just put the Knight on E5 really
wow and it looks so strange to invite F4
but okay if I'm white I want to play
Knight F3 and then continue my
development but uh your knight E5 kind
of crosses my plan doesn't it
you're a party pooper I can see well I I
I'm just reading the opening stats I say
shoot the messenger oh he doesn't play
it no Bishop
okay now we're a new territory yes
expecting C3 and then your idea comes
into play yourself yeah it might not
come into F3 but the the good news from
Black's point of view is the move Bishop
B4 provoking C3 has weakened nicely
weakened the D3 Square so maybe I can
exploit that in the near future I don't
know this one is starting to look better
and better for Sam wait a minute E5
uh there was a logic glitch there I
don't see how E5 and Bishop B4 connected
with one another you're just playing
down the pawn D7 he's trying to put the
King on E6 makes sense Bishop only seven
you're not going to have any like super
dangerous Knight G5 checks but at the
same time you are more or less upon that
once you're born a Berlin player
you cannot Escape your fate you you
can't tell me this wasn't the Berlin
no but I mean Christina
Christian's really really worried and if
you're a member of the production team
you can't tell me
but it was a clear strategy for Sam
right take him to this type of
intriguing end games where you know
better what to do
and let him spend his time and that's
exactly what he's doing right now raise
on his last 25 seconds two minutes Rook
to D7 I I'm always expecting in these
berlins that I'm supposed to see a
little expansion going on uh didn't work
out last time for Ray Sam can just just
the old recipe which
variations
all the pieces and say hey look at that
cluster of Pawns you have there on the
queen side not doing anything great and
take a look at my advantage there on
kingside I have one extra Pawn I will
push it and I will win
wow so simple Bishop G5 I hear you loud
and clear that's what the that's what
Sam is playing for you know exactly
trying to trade as much whoa Bishop
that is a strange move for to my taste
Bishop f8
um
yeah he's gonna go for that Rook to D1
he's trying to exchange both sets of
roots well that that was why I thought
that if you're going to go Bishop G5 I
would put my Bishop on D6 I think that
the uh the the The Rook on D7 is
perfectly fine and there is he's done it
so yeah
so he wants to keep the Rooks on the
board so yeah
she's done it and then get ready to okay
let's say we go C4 you get your knight
on G5 with a check right very very very
clever but
what's the night doing on G5 is not
hitting a Pawn on H7
H4
now I must say I'm not impressed by the
Knight on G6 either it's not like this
Knight is any great shakes but it is
restraining what's
Pawn advance that is true so Ray right
now is trying to transfer group on the
queen side Rook to B8 B4 try to open up
the B file and penetrate via the second
rank that's the only active plan that
black has at his disposal
I I guess in these types of positions
you you shouldn't be overly active or is
that night going well he won't just once
before
and okay but now
I was thinking that you want to go A5
and B4 oh Ray has really committed his
Pawn starch I would just take that yeah
no way I would have played B4 there I
would have definitely prepped it with
the move A5 I think Ray Ray's clock is
his worst enemy does have a point though
because he's not going to take on B4 he
played The Rook to B8 and now we can go
A3 I go A5
he defended is well defended suddenly
look at C3 E4 is hanging E4 is hanging
is that we're getting crap that's
something but now you can take Rook
takes E4 I mean it's The Rook really
getting trapped I mean the structure or
Superior structure ooh Rey is blundering
upon F3 seconds A4 and Rook takes C3
bad bad bad bad news for Ray robson's
fans four seconds for Ray 18 seconds
for Sam will he be able to convert
he should but you're right the clock it
you know
I think Rey is more of a blitz player
than Sam
but uh having said that uh three two one
[Music]
second
but hey Sam actually did tell us that
he's been walking very hard on to
improve his bullets yes wife keep
pushing
and white is really enjoying 25 here
Bishop to C5 did you say sure Bishop G5
I like that
two seconds once again foreign
it's got this in the bag
Knight takes G7
F6 this is it guys wow impressive very
very impressive uh Blitz play by wow
he's flagged as well and he FLA
what a match
after that beautiful end game by Ray
Robson the gorgeous gorgeous ending you
win maybe the game of the tournament but
you're losing the match
oh no I don't know guys uh uh we're
competitors that was a great Magic Tree
by Sam Shanklin
and let's take a look at the brackets
now that we know who got eliminated yeah
and uh just to recap the Champions
brackets Hikaru Nakamura Dominguez they
are tied after game one as are Wesley so
and Fabiano Carona everything to play
for tomorrow but when it comes to the
elimination bracket today was a day of
incredible drama we saw levonne aronian
Breeze past Sam Seville and we saw it
took them six games but we do have a
winner Sam Shanklin winning the tie
breaks and going through to the
elimination starting going through to
the next stage and we say goodbye to Ray
Robson all all hats off to Sam Shanklin
he went on demand and then in the
Champions bracket for the ladies yeah
and Arena Crush she takes an early lead
against talking General Genova and she
leads by one point Satori General is in
a must-win situation tomorrow and the
match is tied between najib paikitsa and
Alice Lee first half point that Alice
Lee has given up and in the elimination
bracket and the elimination bracket we
can see that there are two players very
much alive
abrahamian she won against
no elimination games tomorrow but we do
have the classical and a potential
elimination yes we are going to see the
culmination of the Champions packet yes
we are going to see who is going to get
knocked down to the elimination bracket
and who is going to continue on the path
and uh it's gonna be incredible actually
tomorrow they'll play one classical game
some players are in mosque is it one
player is in a must win situation
she must beat Irina if she wants to
remain in the Champions bracket and for
everyone else
it's a free-for-all they have everything
to play for yeah we're just waiting for
Sam to come over and I was going to say
that I mean winning on demand is tough
and then something happened to Ray
after that it was sort of like I I don't
know he played this really great game
and he just settled in and was pleased
with himself he didn't put the I am I
have to say I think it was because Sam
just came incredibly well prepared and
you know both I mean in all the games
that we saw a common kind of pattern
really is that the players you know
would Blitz out these like 20 moves of
theory and then Sam just knew that one
move ahead he knew the plans that little
bit better than right and he caught him
there he did he did and this game is a
good example of that and let's see what
we've got here you've got Hikaru I've
got Wesley where Kathy's everyone is
happy well I mean definitely
we have a direct matchup no love for Sam
what's wrong with you guys and for the
ladies how are we doing we're doing good
um it wasn't a good day for me that's
for sure no no but we understood you are
loyal to your pupils I mean we we admire
you I have to of course yeah great
choice yes well you can't go wrong I
picked the the top top rated players
something about those favorites the
favorites for a reason I've discovered
yeah I mean they're just very impressive
I mean what can I say I mean better you
get tikari I'm just not going to do that
he tends to win a lot of things and he's
very used to the situation and Irina
just seems to shine insane yes I think
this format for some reason it suits her
very very well I mean obviously she's
very successful the US Women's Champion
in round Robins here she's impressive
but we do have guests in studio with
Christian
Sam once again just like last year you
were with the back against the wall and
we saw you on the camera you weren't
very happy after you lost that first
game in the 10 plus five what did you
say to yourself
I mean I was very upset of course I
believe I was totally fine and just had
to sit and do nothing and failed to do
so that's usually how people beat me and
rap but it never works in classical like
people tried it never works against me
but like in rapper that's how I lost to
Wesley as well which was a really
painful matches but uh well I'd been
studying the Berlin on game a lot just
said you know I got huge winning chances
the first game let's give it another try
and I was able to finally breakthrough
and you came back with an incredible
strategy you played that move Bishop to
B2 in the first game he knew how to
react to that and then you came with
this Knight D5 idea yeah did you have
this prepared yeah of course I mean I
did a lot of work on the Berlin on game
recently and so as you saw I mean I
played a lot of them over and over here
and I kept getting really good positions
with white so it has paid off but yeah I
mean I I knew that Bishop B2 and Knight
D5 were both challenging moves I thought
Bishop V2 was the better one so I played
it against him the first game and I
didn't repeat it again because I believe
ultimately Black's basically fine
um but yeah I came with Knight D5 which
is a little trickier and in the last
game he shied away from the Berlin play
day six and he took on C6 I haven't seen
that since my childhood yeah I mean
basically when I studied the Berlin
endgame I said if because we all know
that Black's fine objectively in the
Berlin Berlin and game I said why not
just play the same end games again in
equal positions there's no doubt black
is absolutely fine exchange Spanish does
not bust the Royal love that's great you
know I just I checked this end game a
bit up soon I think after he misplayed
it a little I mean already after E6 I
know that I know I know here after E6
the computer claims it's about equal but
come on it's the Berlin Pawn structure
and I haven't pushed upon to E5 yet I
thought at least I can play and the next
thing I knew I had a very nice position
and
when did you feel like you finally are
taking already here I knew that what was
better I didn't
know how much and then I think he didn't
coordinate his pieces right if I'm not
mistaken he's supposed to uh go with
Knight h8 and then bring the Knight to
D6 at some points like I know that's not
the computer defines it's not pleasant
and here it's already a bad version but
like he's definitely supposed to bring
the Knight to D6 and when he didn't do
that like already this just looks really
bad and
here I mean he could have taken my epon
if I'm not mistaken at some point like
instead of A4 yeah I mean here he should
take you for it like I mean it's
obviously miserable with the horrible
structure but at least he's not just
straight Pawn down which he got in the
game like here I just I saved E4 pawn
and got the same position I mean here
like well it's obviously much better but
in blitzly this is far from routine
Samuel played so many games against Ray
uh last year this year what made the
difference this year
well well um
I think
I guess I got a little bit fortunate
like I definitely I haven't checked the
mission but I feel I should have lost
the second game I also should have won
the first one but uh yeah I don't know I
mean um it's funny last year at the time
I would have said I was clearly the
better classical player and he was
clearly the better rapid player and it
sort of showed this year I think you
know our ratings are sort of the same in
both ways so he's improved a lot in
classical like it really shows like he's
so much stronger now than he has been
but you know look I've known Ray since
we were some you know
since we were like whatever 12 and 9 or
something like you know we're the two uh
best players to have come out of America
from our generation and um
and uh yes I've just known him forever I
mean we've had so many games I know I'm
pretty well guys any questions our
congratulations and uh good luck as you
move on in the tournament uh Sam oh I
have a question who do I play next
you're gonna have to watch the show
we actually we're not sure we're not
sure but I'm not playing tomorrow I
believe it will be the loser between
Nakamura and Dominguez tomorrow you have
a wrestling okay that's for sure okay
congratulations good luck I like that I
have a question for you wait a minute
wait a minute wait who's doing the
interview yeah that was pretty good it's
a it's it's fusing because it's quite a
new situation with a double elimination
format and so whilst everyone and it's
very popular at the minute but you know
you still have to come to grips with the
whole format and the loser dropping down
exactly back into the elimination
bracket Christian bring it home for us
your your final thoughts of this very
exciting uh day three I mean what an
incredible matchup is between these two
players sure the classical games maybe
have been a bit quiet today except that
win of uh Arena crash against the
hiroshonova but the rapid and Blitz
Games wow kept us glued to our seats I
have to well to your seats because I'm
standing so we had a lot of fun and I'm
sure we're going to continue the
celebrations in tomorrow's matchups
absolutely thank you for that Christian
Jovi once again my pleasure to be with
you on set with Christian it was a lot
of fun we're going to do it all tomorrow
we're going to do it tomorrow and we're
gonna have even more drama as we're
gonna see what happens in the champions
bracket I absolutely can't wait don't
miss it we will see you all tomorrow
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited